thank you
hello everyone welcome to this
interesting live video series on digital
marketing by simply learn
we are going to have daily live sessions
this week that will cover all the
important skills to help you master
digital marketing in a week
you are going to learn the in-demand
digital marketing skills and methods
each day with our highly trained
instructors
we will concentrate on digital marketing
b6101 SEO social media marketing
email content marketing and more
without further delay let's begin with
day one of our digital marketing week in
this session we are going to touch upon
the basics of digital market and
understand the need for digital
marketing
digital marketing refers to achieving
marketing objectives by applying this
technology and media you will learn the
different types of online marketing such
as seo seo affiliate marketing content
marketing mobile marketing and others
that will help businesses stay a step
ahead in the competition
so you will learn the various concepts
of digital marketing and get an idea how
to use them to effectively increase your
company's growth so let's dive deep and
learn digital marketing 101 from scratch
meet Joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for Amazon
but how did Joey get here a few years
ago Joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it first Joey
Larkin through different search engines
websites social media platforms emails
and mobile applications it would give
marketers the opportunity to interact
with and understand their audience
better and to increase the trust in
their Grant digital marketing would also
show marketers advertisements to People
based on their actions and preferences
on the internet while being less
expensive then traditional forms of
advertising after understanding the main
concepts of digital marketing Joey
realized there was more to digital
marketing than he initially thought
there were also many types of digital
marketing types like content marketing
search engine optimization pay-per-click
social media marketing email marketing
and affiliate marketing
and once understood those times he set
up digital marketing campaign for his
uncle's e-commerce website let's have a
look at what he came up with first Joey
created content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies so that he
could generate audience interest in the
Brand's products or services
this was content marketing it is
audience to actually see him the first
step was to create content on specific
Search keywords that were relevant to
the target audience Joey would make
optimization and have LinkedIn on behold
the annual page of the search results by
continuous optimizations Joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position this was SEO or search
engine optimization and Joey could do
all of this without spending a single
penny he could also Drive traffic to the
website without advertisements
but for this he would have to pay a
certain PE time and the ads were clicked
search engine results images and video
ads that show up and much more
this was possible with the help of PPC
or pay-per-click however Jeep wasn't
done yet your audio to Tapia platforms
he would use social media platforms like
LinkedIn YouTube Facebook and Instagram
to advertise the Brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the Brand's products services with posts
images and more to bringing up the Brand
Story and engage with the Brand's
audience who spend a lot of time on
social media like PPC he could use the
platform to advertise the brand products
or services with text image and video
ads which needed to be paid for that's
social media marketing Joey realized the
large amount of the audience weren't
visiting the Brand's website a second
time he needed to keep them engaged
nurture them to make the product for
this he would send them emails that help
them better understood it on the website
and assist them in the buying process he
would also send emails to advertisers
products or services to potential
customers that is with email marketing
and finally
although Joey was able to grow the
Brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third party web with the affiliate
brand or products for a fee signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
Etc
after setting all of this up Joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through the wait
although Joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success
[Music]
he had to gain more knowledge and
experience so decided to get certified
and get ahead in his career with the
help of Simply
he took simply learns digital marketing
certification and got the skills train
he needed to become an expert digital
marketer
and now you know where he is you two can
the same and grow in your career by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all of your concepts of
digital marketing greetings everyone
Landers and what marketing joining us
talking about Ms M so let's start on the
why so if we're just to fly on the wall
and we're in an office environment we're
looking at two friends having a
conversation about digital marketing so
really if we're listening and
everybody
every martyr is using digital marketing
for his or her business now does your
marketing is become then trademetz nuts
over the past few decades digital
marketing has evolved at a rapid Pace
these days a lot of people spend most
their time on the internet so what
happens in the internet every 60 seconds
well a lot happens every 60 seconds so
according to Social Media today I mean
there's a lot of snow
there's a lot of videos watched there's
a lot of pictures being taken there's a
lot of voice activated activity going on
a lot of nails there's a lot on here
there's a lot of that one Jeff can you
also references between digital and
traditional marketing systems and then
the expert responds of course I can
certainly clarify a few differences
between digital and traditional and so
he goes on to say what the differences
are between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio
billboard
newspaper TV anything that's not on your
mobile or laptop so we know nutritional
marketing reaches Limited with digital
marketing reaches maximum and what we
mean by that is hey when you print
something you're printed it for x amount
of people if you're trying to promote an
event a thousand flyer you figure it's
going to a thousand people maybe they'll
share it so you're looking about 2 000
people maybe just to be generous well
digital marketing we're promoting an
event we can promote it to a whole lot
of people depending on the platform so
2000 is nothing when you're targeting an
audience on Facebook or Google search
traditional marketing non-versatile and
with digital marketing very versatile so
again going back to our flyer printing
an eight and a half by eleven okay
that's it you know with with digital
marketing running display banners you
have 468 by 60 200 by 200 250 by 250 300
by 300 I mean the list goes on on the
types this is not to mention text ads
not to mention video video or multimedia
so there's a lot you can do to get your
message out there okay with traditional
it's always delayed communication okay
so meaning if you're trying to get that
TV spot there might not be a spot open
until one in the morning okay well there
is no hours okay you can simply get your
account out there and have people see it
instantaneously
so which is
a lack of real-time results I mean this
seems like uh it's obvious but you know
digital marketing that's one of the
biggest benefits time results
okay so we could see traditional Market
postcard postcards but you have to mail
those postcards so there's postage fees
we're with digital marketing it's very
very very cost efficient I mean meaning
you could pick and choose who you want
to Target when you want to Target where
you want to Target what you want to
Target and if you're doing search you
can put your bidding in place you can
put your hours in place you can really
control how much you actually spend so
that's amazing one of the biggest
advantages just to digital marketing not
only the real-time results but you can
control costs and then obviously
optimize based on the amount of costs
you're spending based on those real time
results
traditional marketing still let's reach
a target audience you know with digital
marketing it's easy no I don't see much
I mean if you're gonna put a TV ad in
place you know you're going to do it on
a TV show that tends to gear more
towards your target audience but that
doesn't guarantee anything here we can
simply go to Facebook or Twitter or
LinkedIn and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to Target when
we want to Target them so it just
becomes a lot easier
audience
um
and then
which traditional important measure but
you have easy sometimes can't believe me
because results
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally what
that means that's a culmination of
pretty much everything that we've listed
as a benefit for digital marketing okay
so now why digital marketing has been
answered with all the benefits that
it carries
so
you know
that
you know you want to do digital
marketing so how do we go about that
what what is clay well let's just the
digital marketing company doctor service
device obviously what I'm not gonna buy
ice technology you know a cloud-based
platform okay it could be a piece of
software okay so a lot going on on the
digital side in terms of variations and
what you can do but that's in a nutshell
what digital marketing is you're really
just using technology to promote your
product or service so we know because of
the benefits in digital marketing you
can promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all those benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency optimizing
campaigns you could do that on search
you could do it on social via email on
mobile apps Etc so that's what we mean
with the help of business well these
digital devices and technology come in
the form of search engines and emails
and mobile apps Etc so when we want to
go and promote our product or service
using a campaign we have different
options so there are different types of
digital marketing channels that we can
choose from and let's just go through
that list of digital marketing channels
and the first one is what I consider the
king of them all and that
there's surgeon marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile then we can get a subsets
of each of these digital marketing
channels but really you know because
that's and to me that state increasing
Quantum on the search engines including
Google so depending on where you're
located in the U.S market Google tends
has a large market share so you want
your pages on your website to be found
and clicked on organically and so that
means if somebody types in a keyword you
want that relevant page to show up first
on Google so somebody can click on that
link
okay and we know that millions of people
specifically in the US but worldwide do
you search on a deep basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant keywords you
can imagine how much traffic you can get
okay so that's it yeah
okay and here's an example so you type
in online shopping well you can see
first listing here it's gonna get to
that number can't or is Amazon Spain
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsor search or
Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different different names with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bit on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to for one result before
that keyword now when somebody clicks on
it you have to pay Google if it's Google
you're advertising on but that's the
beauty of search engine marketing you
can bid on keywords and appear at the
top of the search results for that
keyword example here if we go back to
online shopping well myus.com is bidding
on that keyword online shopping so
they're actually appearing above
Amazon's organic listing but that's what
they want to do they want to be found
for that keyword so if they're not
ranking forward or organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happened to clicked on that listing then
myus.com is gonna pay Google something
depending on what the cost per click is
and so that could be anywhere from one
penny to to a hundred dollars depends
who else is verification depends on the
time of day depends on quality score
there's a lot of factors involved and
regarding what you pay however the
benefit of sem is visibility and getting
traffic to your website for keywords
you're not found for so that's why sem's
such a popular choice for a lot of
companies okay let's talk about digital
marketing that's traditional type of
digital marketing channel it's been
around a long time you know we all
sending emails on a daily basis we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis just an effective way to capture
your leads and convert them to customers
because with email you can personalize
your emails and you can send your emails
to a segmented audience okay so if you
have 30 fish to four fans say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
Target on audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account
so basically here's an example of uh
email that could go out if you're
selling a product and the products
permission is about to end well you know
get the email out to your target
audience hey you have until tonight it's
a product and if you purchase it you're
getting off and you can put that in
there with a nice call to action go to
that web page and purchase the product
using that coupon code so that's an
example of email marketing okay we have
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is an effective way for
digital marketers to basically create a
sales force of people so basically what
you're doing is you're getting Merchants
to promote your products and services
and you're using usually a third party
broker like Commission Junction or c.com
as an example to introduce you the the
person selling the product the merchant
when with the affiliate so that
affiliate could likely be a merchant
himself
and they can basically be a good partner
of yours machine that they can sell in
order to get commissions so it's all
based on a commission so you basically
are going to use a third party affiliate
like CJ get all these Affiliates to work
for you they're going to promote your
product or service if they do sell your
product or service you're going to pay
them a commission that's more or less
how it works with affiliate marketing
and you know with affiliate marketing to
me it's a good way to you know really
put your product or service and you can
pick and choose the affiliates
or the Publishers of whom you want to
work with
so here's an example of
so social media marketing you know I
wouldn't say it's fairly new I mean if I
think about it we're in 2019 and I
remember talking about Facebook back in
2006 so you're talking about 13 14 15
years of social media it's definitely
evolved over the years and but the
concept Remains the Same it involves
creating different types of content
depending on the platform okay so you
could be on Pinterest or Instagram and
be dealing with photos or you could be
on Twitter tweeting out certain
characters up to a limit okay so it
really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media effects area I mean
Facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on Facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your Social platforms
like LinkedIn and Twitter and Facebook
and Pinterest and Instagram they'll have
a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your proper
service or you can go the organic route
and you know post tent organically and
focus of driving traffic back or website
so with social you do have two options
here but social is interesting because
in a lot of different social media
really depend or service okay exact
marketing especially on Facebook with
Facebook you got mobile and desktop and
you obviously have the opportunity to
post something organically and have that
liked or commented on or shared or you
can post an ad and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do
so moving on to content marketing it's a
Content marketing is really an effect
way of really Distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or an
infographic okay the ways to create
content these days especially in digital
marketing and the great thing about
content marketing is you're writing
content for a targeted audience so if
you're trying to Target an audience on
say Instagram then you know who your
audience is and you know what the type
of content you're gonna post on there so
it could be in the form of a video or
infographic or just a graphic and so
that's the beauty content marketing
really putting yourself out there
um and depending on the platform putting
yourself out there with various types of
content so for example if we look at
YouTube you can see this
Plato here about digital marketing and
certified associate well hey you don't
need to always write the conduce the
form and post this so that's con and
then let's talk about mobile marketing
so content marketing again different
types but if we go now to mobile
marketing you can kind of segue from
content to mobile because the only
difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product
services to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets
is via messaging you could do a via
email or you could be do it via an app
okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or to Jane racist another
example of a mobile marketing via app
install and so you can even compound
that by running a say Google ad as an
example and running your Google ad on
say just mobile you could do a bit
adjustment just for mobile and the goal
could be app installs okay so and you
can even do a mobile or app so there's
lots of ways to really promote your app
or your products or your service Via
mobile marketing
okay let's talk about custom life cycle
so we know why we just digital marketing
we wanted that we want we know
what the digital marketing channel
miles are because we talked about them
from SEO social to Affiliates intent a
lot miles that you're just what we're
going to talk about first so we're going
to talk about different stages of the
customer life cycle okay and the first
one is the awareness stage so we need to
get our customers aware of what we're
selling or what we're promoting okay so
the awareness stage is really what
product does your brand offer that's a
question we want to get out there and we
want to answer okay what does a customer
need your product or excuse me what is a
customer need your product that's a
question we want to answer with digital
marketing okay what solution does your
product provide okay that's an answer to
a question we want to make sure people
understand so these are questions
[Music]
become aware of our product or service
okay so what product does our brand
offer why does a customer need it and
what solution does it provide okay those
are some key questions that people tend
to ask themselves when they look at a
brand okay and when they look at a
product hey do I really need this is it
going to help me in my life okay and who
who is selling
this brand
I mean that's those are just things like
run people's mind intuitively that with
the right messaging the right channel
the right type of asset the right
targeted audience you can quickly
make somebody aware of your Brand's
product or service it's helpful to just
to help channels the content if we have
a website we need a Blog because if
somebody does come to our blog from say
organic search SEO then we can write
about that product or service via blog
and talk to our customer talk directly
to our targeted audience through that
blog and if we're not ranking
organically we can use paid search to
promote it because paid search on Google
for example
basically we can be right at the top of
the search results and so somebody
really see it when they do a search
because
search on a daily basis you could do
social media marketing okay so you can
publish that product service on Facebook
why you're building your community you
can use affiliate marketing to help get
out by you support these are gonna play
to me in the awareness stage these are
the digital marketing channels you can
focus on now I will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display
ads meaning that if you're on Google's
display now or you could pick and choose
your size your demographics keywords
topics and audience you focus on all
those different demographics to really
attract a large number of people so low
priority but it's probably also good to
focus on
you must call for searching about
content it's hard to get found and so to
me this is you know where the blog comes
in SEO take that content get it
optimized okay sem if we're not ranking
organically we can make sure with the
top of the paid search results or the
the search results for a particular
keyword we want to be found for and then
social media marketing using different
channels depending on the channel
for selling you know training
like simply
because you know LinkedIn is a good
platform for us okay and then affiliate
you know basically building up a nice
network of Publishers to get the word
out so these are all good channels that
we can focus in on so track sources may
include paid
yeah traffic from mobile or email so now
that we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so you know
people are aware of us now they're
considering us and that's kind of the
next stage in the process okay so a few
essential questions to address on the
consideration stage hey what features
make your product valuable to others and
how will I increase customer engagement
towards my product so those are answers
to questions you want to ask okay what
features make your product valuable you
want to basically separate yourself of
from the competition basically that's
what you're trying to answer okay so if
you're promoting your product service on
paid search and or better how are you
going to increase customer engagement
towards my product so for example if
you're on Facebook okay and you're
trying to get people over to your site
to purchase your product then how are
you going to improve that engagement you
gotta create something really snazzy or
really it's going to be attention
grabbing or something that's going to
get them to become aware of it that's
going to separate your post from all the
other posts that are in somebody's
Facebook newspaper okay so you really
have to work hard to really convince
somebody to get their consideration
towards your product or service so in
this stage your customer considers your
product so help them understand how your
product is valuable okay to me email
works really good here I have a Target
to do the real affiliations I don't know
email you can support that with a
promotion and display I think display is
a good option here too because even
though you know people are trying to
become aware you know you can really
hone in and really get them to take that
next step okay with display you can even
do remarketing so if somebody's been to
your site because they're aware of your
product they're curious you can cookie
them and remarket to them the display so
display to me is a good a good channel
to use here so you have email mobile
display you know sem these are all you
know good shells to use and
consideration stays especially on search
because somebody's looking for something
and they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity make sure if
you're offering and get is to increase
our engagement so people are aware we're
moving them further belong the funnel
with email marketing we have the
opportunity to promote the product by
sending an email directly to our
audience so with this stage plan your
campaigns around welcoming emails
newsletters we can talk about product
descriptions add ratings and reviews in
the email you know we really just want
to encourage people to purchase the
product that we're trying to sway them
over so email is a good source to allow
us to do that so with mobile marketing
we can promote the products by setting
relevant messages to our target audience
again retargeting because we can
retarget it tour we already did some
brand or product or service and now
we're going to reach back out to them to
sway them so remember we want to
encourage customers to buy a product by
creating detailed articles about the
product that always helps and that's
content okay we want to opt for a
customer testimony okay that helps sway
people and add some guest blogging okay
we can have ambassadors blog on our
behalf
or we can go out and blog on somebody
else's site okay so blogging works both
ways ways of showing yourself and tell
people
we know you're looking for this product
here's why you want to choose us
okay moving on from the consideration to
the purchase so there you go on to the
purchase really make sure we address
here our how are my prices compared to
my competitors and is my brand more
credible than others okay so they're
considering you but that price point and
it may not even be the price it could be
the shipping for example the price could
be good but the shipping cost could be
high so you really want to do some do
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility
that goes back to the consideration
stage and testimonials you want to make
sure you have reviews and testimonials
to really Elevate what you're trying to
tell customers and that that is hey I
have a good brand I have a good product
I have a good service come by come by
Monday the support can't go and so
supporting that comes in the form of
what other people say and that could be
that could be fun a social media
platform it could be you know stars on
say Yelp or Google my business you know
make sure you do your due diligence and
make sure you get people to you know
review you or provide testimonials
because people are gonna do their Duty
diligence before they purchase
especially if it's on Google my business
or Yelp or TripAdvisor whatever it is
you're trying to sell so they're going
to be able to see those reviews and so
do your due diligence to get the reviews
hey cam you're gonna get them that's
them just you show your upper hand and
respond even to the negative as well as
the positive reviews that you get that
actually bodes well to some people
because hey it shows that I made a
mistake and you're willing to correct it
and so people actually see that that
could be the Tipping Point to getting
them to purchase say look hey this brand
really cares because they're really
responding to people
negative
okay just this small things that can get
people to change their minds now with
the purchase stage according to eat
consultancy 83 of the online audience
require and encourage governmentally
purchased could mean provide that F I
don't see on the email and the example
we looked at earlier sending out an
email means that if the promo is going
to end at midnight send that email out
and tell people they have until midnight
and if they purchase today you'll even
increase it to 20 and email is a good
channel for that mobile can reach a lot
of PMS okay social media reaching people
instantaneously and then you know really
what the purchase is just
prospects an offer to help them make
that purchase so you have plenty of
channels to choose from back most of
these channels the only one really that
doesn't fit the instantaneous mode is
SEO but you can really focus on
affiliate even it's a little priority
hit or you publishly those Pub proven
their worth and have sold your products
in the past you know get them to help
promote it and incentivize Their
audience so let's move on from the
purchase to the purse post purchase
stage so this is after somebody
purchases okay so some essential
questions we want to be able to address
here so what additional product could my
customer buy now
because
customer
what else
you know
could if they buy a coat or gloves to be
able you know customers these are
customers customer buying let's go you
know what about it they don't give you a
full complement of five stars they only
give you three and a half stars then you
know what that's great feedback because
then you can learn from that and then
the other question is will the customer
refer us to others and if so why so
that's definitely something you want to
be able to address in the first person
to take a look here
so with post purchases
stage
you know it's me
emails at the top of this list
you can send on my email because if
their emails
and a nice social media thank your
community for supporting you on this
recent campaign that you ran you know
even throw in an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase as a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media
you know you could even post a blog you
know promoting you know the success of a
product and then
okay so there's a lot of things you
should be doing here
on the Press purchasing stage so it's
been looking at you know put a server
you put a server billion you could even
post working channels about your mobile
customers with other content mobile if
you have somebody's mobile number hey
text them a simple thank you goes a long
way you know you could say hey look if
you're satisfied let us know give us a
call you can even in the ee mobile text
message you can put a link to a survey
send emails
tips
foreign
Network give referral opportunities to
your customers so if it's an affiliate
publisher hey if they're getting people
to your site or them or if it's an email
and you put a four to a friend get an
extra 10 off it doesn't hurt because
you're incentivized
people
sell all your product so we're saying
condos or content that you display all
of the ride to get advice Master the
person again you can plot to also what
they say so hey just this problem it's
the idea purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do I get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair
up
s
for example you can recommend products
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 percent of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
Mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average
more than 40 percent of Revenue
is it strategy all the way to Thai stuff
that's what mobile marketing started off
as the main objective with mobile
marketing is to advertise products and
services to a target audience through
multiple channels on smartphones tablets
and other mobile devices
this is done through websites emails SMS
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing first we have focusing
on the customers
marketing
in mobile marketing
has based on their location and purchase
history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying Trends with
data by leveraging data different Trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
graph the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an A B test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what isn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics having some experience with
mobile analytics with some of the
metrics that need to be focused on like
engagement ratio cost per install and
average revenue per user are very
important for mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
ASO advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine CRM or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also CR marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020.
finally businesses that leverage CRM
software see sales increase by 29 sales
productivity increased by 34 and sales
forecast accuracy increase by 42 percent
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what CRM is all about
CRM is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a collection of
strategies tools and Technologies and
crms aim to develop new customer
relationships retain them or require new
ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crm's mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
so here are a few areas to focus in CRM
first we have data analytics crns
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns now although what metric you
focus on entirely depends on your
requirements here are some of the
commonly used metrics
this customer churn which is basically
customer attrition there's NPS which is
a measure of how satisfied your
customers are less customer retention
cost and first Contact resolution rate
which is the percentage of customers
support tickets that gets resolved at
the first short
next understanding how different CRM
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms the
Salesforce HubSpot crms over CRM
Microsoft Dynamics and much more
it has really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like Salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simply learn Dynamics 365 by
Microsoft and finally HubSpot Academy
sales professional credential by HubSpot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers say visual images are the most
important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies in Western content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or Services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good you might wonder what does
designing have to do with digital
marketing plenty actually if you have an
understanding of Designing yourself in
the scenario where graphic designers are
unable to bring your idea to life you
could do it yourself Desiring for
yourself what the content will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creator for the ad
next let's have a look at Key concepts
of Designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about Concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden Point Rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like Adobe Photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by kosera introduction to graphic
design by LinkedIn and fundamentals of
graphic design Again by Coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method through
which a brand can learn about what
customers are saying about them and the
industry online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
Concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
where does most of your audience come
from which platform is better suited for
your content those are the questions
that need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like HubSpot and
HootSuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like PR
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it is stated that 64 percent of B2B
marketers Outsource their demanding copy
needs
next It also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more site traffic and
reduces brand recall which brings higher
engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
Billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
Pursuits individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website buy a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting first
understanding the customers and the
competition so from the customers
several bits of Vital Information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of Engagement what
kind they dislike and much more likewise
from the competition you can find out
what kind of writing they have success
with what they are doing better from
your brand and so on
this one goes without saying but to have
success with copywriting you need to be
well versed with grammar and have
sufficiently good writing skills
get some certifications now
here we have the creative copywriter
Academy then we have the IDM award in
digital and copywriting by The Institute
of data and marketing and finally we
have American Writers and artists
copywriting course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 Global
email users amounted to 3.9 Million by
2023 this is set to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81 smbs rely on
email as their primary customer
acquisition Channel and 80 for retention
next Again by statista it states that 49
of consumers would like to receive
promotional emails from their favorite
brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience in a way
email marketing could nurture the
relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at Key Concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation emails
can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of Engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
today has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them
each of them can impact your customer
base in a different manner depending on
their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics to be successful at email
marketing it is absolutely necessary to
be experienced with tools like HubSpot
and MailChimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much more
next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like HubSpot
Academy email marketing by HubSpot then
email and affiliate marketing Mastermind
by udemy and finally Advanced email
marketing certification training by
simply learn
so now that we have reached Midway I
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat I'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative Tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to Simply lunch channel to
stay up to date on the trending
Technologies and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number four social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 percent
of the world's population uses social
media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of Millennials 77.5
percent of Generation X and 48.2 percent
of baby boomers are active social media
users
so now let's have a look at Social Media
Marketing
social media marketing involves the
usage of social media platforms to build
a brand Drive traffic to your website
and increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your Brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages so it's
important to have experience with them
so that the one that best suits your
requirements can be selected
next we have monetization
on YouTube which is also a social media
platform you could monetize your videos
to get some income out of them other
options include affiliate marketing
influencer marketing events and much
more then we have analytics experience
with social media marketing tools like
buffer and bassumo can help
organizations by providing anodes based
on keywords brand names links domain and
much more
among other things it also tracks
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your Brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your Brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simply learn
then we have social media marketing on
LinkedIn learning and finally HootSuite
social marketing certification by
HootSuite
and now for the top three number three
payoff lake or PPC first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search ad because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38 CTR on Google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in Google ads
now let's talk about PPC
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform PPC
for PPC most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine results page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of PPC
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works each of them have their own but
somewhat similar rules prices
restrictions and so on then we have
Google ads one of the most popular and
lucrative layers among the search
engines Google ads provides marketers
with a sizable chunk of the internet to
advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how Google ADS works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on Google ads why don't you
check our introductory video on it I'll
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
CPC or cost per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as I mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these Concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have Google ads certifications by
Google then Advanced pay per click PPC
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have Microsoft and
Excellence program by Microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.60 of all the
clicks
and according to Google where to buy
Plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to HubSpot 57 of
B2B marketers stated that SEO generates
more leads than any other marketing
initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or SEO refers
to the method adopted by an organization
to grow the quality and quantity of
website traffic by making it more
visible to the users of a particular web
search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results SEO improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from Paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of SEO technical SEO the
technical side of SEO like server side
settings site Maps server Response Code
rewrites and so on will help you take
advantage of both page level and server
level optimization to ensure they are
found by search engines this by
extension helps generate traffic and
conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well versed in content marketing
as both SEO and content marketing cannot
exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and SEO provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
the process of search engine
optimization can only be successful if
there's a combination of both external
link building and internal link
optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability SEO must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like Moz and Google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have Google analytics and
Google webmaster
Google analytics will help with tracking
and Reporting website traffic Google
webmaster will help track your website
search performance with the help of
Google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have SEO training course by Moz
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have HubSpot SEO training course
provided by HubSpot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like Apache Spa
Tableau and SAS can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have Google analytics Google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website
intercourse activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the Google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component understanding data
visualization would help with
understanding data in a quick and clean
manner it enables Brands to identify
emergent Trends and to respond to it
quickly
with it the Brand Story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrator with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by
Coursera then we have data analyst
Masters program by simply learn and
finally we have micromasters program and
marketing analytics by edx today I'm
going to tell you how you can become a
digital marketer so first off let's
answer the most important question who
is a digital marketer now a digital
marketer is responsible for several
things let's go through some of them
first off they're responsible to develop
as well as manage marketing campaigns to
ensure that the goals of the
organization are fulfilled they need to
create a marketing strategy which is
based on analyzing their competition as
well as the benchmarks within the
industry they need to drive website
traffic as well as acquire leads which
are then worked upon by the organization
or the business they need to utilize web
analytics tools so that they can measure
and optimize a campaign which is
basically figuring out how well the
campaign is doing and if it's not doing
well how they can make it better and
finally they need to be able to enhance
brand awareness which is just letting
people know that the brand exists and
how the brand can make their lives
better next up let's talk about how to
become a digital marketer to become a
digital marketer you need a certain set
of skills skills like search engine
optimization search engine marketing or
sem email marketing social media
marketing affiliate marketing content
marketing and finally mobile marketing
so the first step you need to take to
become a digital marketer is to learn
SEO so SEO or search engine optimization
is the process of increasing the quality
of your organic traffic which is nothing
but the traffic that comes to your
website without having seen any paid
advertisements just because your website
is one of the first few results when
they search a particular query on a
search engine SEO involves on-page SEO
as well as off-page SEO so how to do
on-page SEO first off you need to do
keyword research keyword research is one
of the most important steps when when it
comes to SEO it is the process of
identifying popular words and phrases
used on search engines by users you need
to be able to identify keywords with
high search volume higher relevancy and
low competition next up we have
technical audit so search engines around
the world have internet Bots performing
a particular process known as crawling
in this process the search engine
internet Bots these search engine Bots
also known as spiders scanner website
and copy the entire website's content
and store it within the search engine
for it to index now you need to ensure
your site is being crawled and indexed
next you have on-site optimization you
need to develop high quality content
meta tags URL and site maps and finally
user experience you need to provide good
website architecture as well as internal
linking structure next up let's talk
about how to do off-page SEO this is
made possible with the help of Link
building this is the process of
navigating links from other websites to
to your own and by building external
links to your website your organic
search ranking can be improved now let's
talk about some SEO tools you have Mars
Google Keyword Planner semrush and
ahrefs now let's talk about the next
step required to become a digital
marketer which is to learn sem or search
engine marketing search engine marketing
is a practice of marketing a business
using paid advertisements on search
engines and other websites so basically
this is a way of attracting users
towards your website or a particular
product that you are offering so how can
you do sem or search engine marketing
first off you need to determine your
goal and Define a budget you need to
ensure that you have a goal in mind for
example do you want more leads do you
want to increase traffic or improve
brand awareness and much more after
you're done with that you need to define
a budget how much money are you ready to
spend to achieve this goal then you need
to choose a list of relevant keywords
which is keywords on which you'll be
bidding to advertise you need to find
analyze your keywords and then bid on
them which is basically are you ready to
pay for how many clicks you're getting
or for acquiring customers or making
them leads and so on you need to create
a compelling headline for your ad
campaign you need to monitor the
performance of campaigns and measure
results which is basically finding out
whether the campaign is working out well
and if it's not to optimize it so that
it works the next time and you need to
Target your audience with remarketing
campaigns for example if a customer does
not go through with the conversion
process they can be added to the
remarketing audience so that they can be
advertised to again some of the popular
sem tools are Google AdWords editor FB
ads manager Bing ads and AD role now for
the next step to become a digital
marketer you have to learn email
marketing now email marketing is really
efficient as well as inexpensive way to
generate High return on investment it
can be used to convert prospects into
customers by sending personalized emails
to a targeted audience so how do you
perform email marketing first off you
need to discover your target audience
and create segments in which you can
divide them depending on their behavior
you need to select and create your type
of campaign depending on the goals you
want to achieve you need to select a
suitable design for your campaign you
need to have a compelling subject line
and email content which is very
important when it comes to email
marketing you need to send campaigns
immediately or schedule an email and
finally you need to measure results such
as open trade click-through rate
response rate and so on you also need to
perform a b testing to find out what
works and what doesn't some of the
popular email marketing tools are
MailChimp HubSpot Marketo send in blue
and so on and now for the next step you
need to learn social media marketing
social media marketing involves the
promotion of your product and services
on different social media platforms
using different types of content now
this could be just sponsored posts video
advertisements images articles and so on
now how can you do social media
marketing first off you need to choose a
suitable social media platform for your
business it could be Facebook YouTube
Twitter LinkedIn and so on next up you
need to find your target audience now
each of these platforms has a particular
Niche that occupies it now for example
Facebook requires an active social media
marketing strategy Pinterest is usually
used by females LinkedIn can be used for
employee networking and YouTube is a
platform where people create as well as
share video content and that's the only
content that works on YouTube you need
to create as well as curate engaging
content because without your content
being engaging nobody's going to be
interested in your product or service
then you need to choose a social media
management tool and finally you need to
test evaluate and optimize your results
now let's talk about some popular social
media marketing tools we have HootSuite
tweet deck buffer Sprout social and so
many more now for your next step to
becoming a digital marketer you need to
learn affiliate marketing now affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves two players a merchant as
well as an affiliate now a merchant is
an individual who pays a commission to
the affiliate who could be a third party
site or entity to drive sales bring
leads or new customers with the help of
referrals now how can you do affiliate
marketing first off you need to choose a
tool through which you can find
Affiliates who can advertise your
product now you need to choose affiliate
on the basis of how much traffic the
affiliate website gets how successful
the Affiliates previous campaigns were
and and how much commission the
affiliate asks for then you need to
specify the format that the affiliate
must use when they're advertising your
product or service you need to keep a
record of the customers who purchased
your product or service through the
affiliate and finally pay the affiliate
based on the commission rates now let's
talk about some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools there's CJ affiliate
volume has offers and even now for the
next step to becoming a digital marketer
you need to learn mobile marketing now
mobile marketing enables a business to
communicate with a targeted audience
through any mobile device this is
through SMS emails mms's and so on so
how do you do mobile marketing first off
you need to create a mobile buyer
Persona which is you know what kind of
person is using the phone you need to
set business goals like what goes
basically determining what goals you
want to achieve with the mobile
marketing campaign then you need to
conduct your campaign and reach your
target audience with a personalized
message to these users and finally you
need to monitor these metrics and
optimize them if required now let's talk
about some popular mobile marketing
tools there's slick text locality admob
Facebook mobile ads and much more now
for your next step in becoming a digital
marketer you need to learn content
marketing content marketing is a pull
marketing technique of creating as well
as sharing valuable content now this
could be blogs videos or articles which
solves the problem of the target
audience this holds their attention by
adding value to their lives and can end
up converting their interest into a
purchase so how do you do content
marketing firstly you need to Define
your goals as in what you want to
achieve you need to Define your target
audience then you need to determine what
kind of content you are creating it
could be blog posts ebooks case studies
infographics and so on you need to
brainstorm for new content ideas you
need to perform a Content audit which is
to evaluate content elements and
information assets and choose a suitable
content management system now you can
plan create publish and measure your
results all in one place using a Content
management system using a Content
management system such as the HubSpot
software next you need to promote your
content using email affiliate and social
media marketing finally you need to
measure your success and optimize your
content now let's talk about some of the
popular content marketing tools there as
LinkedIn pulse paper.li Flipboard trap
it and many many more now let's talk
about some additional resources now
there are a huge number of videos online
about digital marketing and I recommend
you go through some of them so that you
have a basic idea about their
fundamentals now this is where
simplyon's YouTube channel can help you
you can take advantage of Simply learns
digital marketing tutorials you can go
to this playlist right here and here you
have tutorials on what is SEO how you
can rank number one on Google keywords
research Facebook ads tutorial how you
can rank your YouTube videos Facebook
advertising tips and tricks social media
marketing Google tag manager Google
analytics and so much more now let's
have a look at the salaries of a digital
marketer in the United States the
average salary of a digital marketer is
approximately 65 000 per year similarly
the average salary for a digital
marketer in India is approximately 5
lakh rupees per year now let's talk
about how you can become a certified
digital marketer now there are a number
of different certifications available
for you there's the Google ads
fundamental certification the Facebook
certified planning professional
certification the HubSpot content
marketing certification the HootSuite
social marketing certification and
simply learns digital marketing
specialist Masters program now here's
another way simple learn can help you
simplylearn has a number of different
digital marketing certification has a
number of different digital marketing
certifications let's talk about the
digital marketing specialist Masters
program in this program there are a
number of different certifications such
as the digital marketing certified
associate Advanced web analytics
Advanced SEO and so on the certification
also provides the omcp certification
exam voucher worth 395 dollars upon the
completion of the Masters program it has
45 plus projects and can help you get a
salary of close to 17 lakhs per annum it
is also accredited by HootSuite Facebook
the omcp and so on on so now let's have
a closer look at the digital marketing
course or the digital marketing
certified associate certification
training now this certification provides
53 hours of instructor-led training 40
plus hours of self-paced videos
instructor-led online project mentoring
sessions helping you prep for
examinations from the omca Google ads
and so on it has industry accreditations
from HootSuite Facebook and the omcp and
it covers more than 35 tools such as
Facebook insights YouTube analytics
crazy egg Google Keyword Planner Google
ad manager LinkedIn ads buffer semrush
and so on so why don't you go on to
simplylearn.com so that you can get
started on your journey getting
certified and getting ahead hey guys
welcome to this video on digital
marketing career jobs resume salary
skills roles and responsibilities
so without further Ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to healthcare our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved Our Lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your Brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your Marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
Goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on digital marketing has the
following types
search engine optimization content
marketing social media marketing search
engine marketing affiliate marketing
native advertising marketing Automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a Brand's
marketing campaigns to ensure the best
possible output
a digital marketer of course
so now let's talk about everything
related to a digital marketer but before
we can get started let's go to a more
familiar setting on where a digital
marketer belongs and strives
the office now let's start by talking
about who is a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is use digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
Affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
everything the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for developing and
managing marketing campaigns this means
that the success of the entire marketing
efforts of a brand or an organization
entirely depends on how competently a
digital marketer develops the marketing
campaign the work doesn't end there
though the digital marketer also needs
to manage the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the Brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
Industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they're also responsible for using tools
like buffer HootSuite and sproutsocial
to measure and optimize marketing
campaigns Based on data obtained from
the tools
and finally they are responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or Brands content on
digital marketing channels
talk about the skills required to become
a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing their search
engine optimization content marketing
social media marketing search engine
optimization affiliate marketing and
email marketing let's talk about search
engine optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with SEO you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of SEO has two parts
on page and off page SEO let's have a
look at each of them in detail
first let's have a look at on-page SEO
on page or on-site SEO is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or HTML code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what a page is all about and whether or
not your page address is their search
query
on page SEO is possible with the help of
keyword research technical audits
on-site optimizations and enhanced user
experiences
next we have off-page SEO off page or
off-site SEO refers to actions taken
outside your website to affect your
rankings in search engine result pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
off-page SEO can also be performed with
the help of Link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
the popular SEO tools are Moz Google
Keyword Planner semrush and ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable relevant and
consistent content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies to bring
the attention of a targeted online
audience to the Brand's products and
services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign do you want more subscribers
more conversions increased leads
that's what you need to decide here
then you need to set up buyer personas a
buyer Persona is a profile created based
on Research that represents the Target
customer that might enjoy your products
or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you will need to perform a Content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a Content
management system of your choosing there
are a number of options available like
WordPress MailChimp and squaresis you'll
need to keep brainstorming for new forms
of content that'll attract the attention
of new audience
you will need to focus on a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you will need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools there's buffer basumu
follower wonk and HootSuite
let's now talk about the next type of
digital marketing that is social media
marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build a brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you'll need to listen to and engage with
followers analyze results and run social
media advertisements the process of
social media marketing involves like
before you first need to determine what
goal you want to achieve you will need
to determine whether you need increased
conversions email signups lead
generation or any other marketing goal
at this stage you'll need to determine
what your audience enjoys the most
you'll need to find out which files get
the most amount of Engagement likes or
shares then you'll need to research
about your competition within your niche
see what kinds of content they post what
content of theirs receives the most
engagement from Their audience and how
you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice like LinkedIn Facebook Instagram
Twitter or YouTube and start creating
marketing strategies on how to make the
most out of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same you will then need to create a
social media calendar these are
spreadsheets or applications that will
enable you to plan your social media
posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
finally you will need to keep testing
evaluating and making adjustments to
your marketing campaigns to finally
reach the sweet spot where you have a
perfect social media marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is food suit
tweet deck Sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result Pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising let's now take a look at the
process of search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve with your sem
campaign more leads conversions
subscriptions you decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against large ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning
you will then need to decide on what
keywords you want to advertise and then
start bidding on them to ensure that the
user sees your ad when they search for
that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then being completely
turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments and finally you will need to
make sure you make regular optimizations
and adjustments based on the data you've
collected and retarget potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
a popular search engine marketing tools
are Google ads Facebook ads manager ad
role and binge ads just to name a few
next up let's take a look at affiliate
marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a Merchant's products the
affiliate usually promotes the product
and earns a commission for each sale
they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations email signups conversions
and subscriptions here's the process of
affiliate marketing first you will need
to decide the affiliate Network you want
to choose the affiliate network is like
a favor for both merchants and
Affiliates
here a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with and
vice versa
as a merchant you will need to set up
specific rules guidelines image
specifications commission costs and
other details that an affiliate needs to
accept before they can apply to
advertise for you
after this Affiliates apply to advertise
on the Merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the Merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the Merchant's
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate Network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate and finally
the affiliate is given his or her
commission and likewise the process
repeats itself
here are some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools we have CJ affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign then you decide what
kind of emails you want to send is it a
welcome email a newsletter a lead
nurturing email a re-engagement email
that's what you've got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing these tools can
help you with templates for emails
create email lists Track Performance and
do much more you will then need to
attract users with a reason to subscribe
to your emails with attractive opt-in
advantages like exclusive access to
sales discounts and so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that
will attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design and finally you will need to
perform a or b tests and use analytics
to measure how well your campaign is
doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
popular email marketing tools are
MailChimp HubSpot send in blue and
Marketo just to name a few now let's
take a look at some digital marketer
carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of Glassdoor first we have
digital marketing manager a digital
marketing manager earns approximately 75
000 per annum in the US in India he or
she can earn approximately 7 lakh rupees
per annum next we have SEO manager in
the United States and SEO manager earns
approximately 62 000 per annum whereas
in India an SEO manager earns
approximately 5 lakhs per annum then we
have search engine marketing or PPC
expert a PPC expert in the US earns
approximately seventy four thousand
dollars per annum whereas in India a PPC
expert can earn approximately 4 lakh
rupees per annum next up we have the
social media manager in the US a social
media manager earns approximately fifty
thousand dollars per annum in India he
or she can earn approximately 5 lakhs
per annum and finally we have the
content marketing manager a Content
marketing manager can earn approximately
sixty five thousand dollars in the
United States in India he or she can
earn approximately 5 lakh rupees per
annum let's have a look at a sample
digital marketer resume first off you
start off with the usuals like name
address and the other stuff following
this you will need to add a brief
summary three of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experienced with in this
case this person has two years of
experience in just about every important
type of digital marketing
your summary can vary based on the job
role you're looking for you give them
links to your socials and then add
experience
this is the part where you can highlight
your achievements during your years of
work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for for example for
the role of a sem expert having
experience with Google ads and Google
analytics is mandatory so that has to be
a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education and then talk about the
courses you've completed having
completed the right courses can have a
significant impact on your higher
ability today we're going to talk about
digital marketing tools so fasten your
seat belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the best digital
marketing tools for not only 2019 but
ones that have performed well in the
past that are popular and ones that we
foresee as being the go-to tools for the
future so past present and future
digital marketing tools is the way to
look at this uh with a good focus on a
lot of different marketing channels here
so we're going to focus first on SEO
talk about some of the tools related to
on page and off page we're going to
switch over to paid search talk a little
bit about paid search tools we're going
to talk about email marketing and some
of the email marketing platforms and the
tools within those platforms the center
of it all is web analytics so Google
analytics is the tool we'll be taking a
closer look at in today's webinar and
all that it has to offer okay affiliate
marketing we'll talk about some of the
tools available to you and for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available all the platforms available so
we'll hone in on a couple of examples
there and then we'll also talk about
some competition tools available for you
so there's a whole Suite of tools the
one caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that I use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so it'd be good to kind
of see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are you know best
practices and some of the most popular
or most used tools out there in the
industry so that's what we're gonna do
the goal is to get you to better
understand some of the tools we're using
a little bit more detail and what we're
going to do is start out with search
engine optimization okay so search
engine optimization or organic search we
have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on SEO you certainly
need to use an SEO platform so there's
sem Rush okay you also have Google
search console which is free so if you
don't have a SEO platform you definitely
need to be using Google search that's
all and so we'll take a closer look at
that there's Google Keyword Planner
which is actually situated under Google
ads and so if you're running Google
campaigns on Google search Network or
even the Display Network you have access
to a great tool called Keyword Planner
and if you know anything about SEO
you'll know that using Google's Keyword
Planner is a good tool so we'll take a
look at that Moz is a freemium tool
meaning they have a free trial that you
can sign up for to test drive it but
it's another SEO platform and it does
cost money got a great tool in screaming
frog that's a paid version again not too
expensive we'll talk a little bit more
about that and then we have you know a
tool in hrefs that help us with all
aspects of SEO primarily focusing on off
page so these are just some examples
that we're going to hone in on but this
is just a small subset of what really is
available out there in the market so so
let's go ahead and dive a little bit
deeper and understand why we use some of
these tools well the first reason when
we talk about SEO is to find relevant
keywords not only do we want to find
relevant keywords we want to find
relevant keywords with high volume and
low competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's Keyword
Planner so here I am I'm in Google's
Keyword Planner and as I mentioned
before Google's Keyword Planner is
situated under Google ads okay so you
have to have a Google Google ads account
to use Google's Keyword Planner and so
when you're in Google ads you simply go
to tools and then under Tools you're
going to select Keyword Planner so what
we want to do is look for keywords we're
focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so let's just use one of the
examples that Google's given us here
meal delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
can say look hone in on keywords related
to this website if I wanted to but I'm
asking Google hey just give me something
closely related to mail delivery because
that's my business so I'm going to click
click get results notice I can add
another key to it if I wanted to but I'm
just going to stick with one keyword but
there are certainly other keywords that
I can certainly hone in on in if mail
delivery is my business and so let's
just hone in on that one keyword mail
delivery we want to be found organically
for that keyword so what Google Keyword
Planner does is not only give us the
keyword and other keywords relevant to
that but it gives us the average monthly
search volumes and this is an average
over the course of the last 12 months
and notice here I get a column for
competition so I'm able to see whether
that's a very competitive keyword or not
and then just to give you an extra Edge
when you're choosing keywords you can
get a sense of what the keyword May cost
if you wanted to bid on that for paid
search so for mail delivery I can see
it's anywhere between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range
16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm gonna try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit High well you
know I can see some other keywords here
that you know a dollar to three dollars
okay I could see some other ones that
are even lower than the seven dollars
they're suggesting so that's a
indication that the keyword is highly
competitive so the idea here using
Google's Keyword Planner is one we want
to get an idea of what other keywords
are out there that are relevant so it
helps stimulate some ideas for relevancy
two we can get an average monthly search
volume so we want to know on average
over the past 12 months how many search
queries I can expect from this keyword
and then three I can get a sense of the
competition how competitive is this
keyword so if I try to optimize for this
keyword and I want to rank for it
organically is it competitive if if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
taxes I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total us so you
have settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a mods account so I
logged into Moz and Moz has a tool
called keyword Explorer so if I use that
same keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask
Moz to give me some data on that keyword
so this is for the entire United States
and again I can change that if I wanted
to okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what Moz
is telling me hey for this keyword in
the entire United States I'm looking at
anywhere from eleven and a half thousand
to thirty thousand on monthly volume now
what Moz does is they give you a
difficulty score so a difficulty score
is a score between 1 and 100 and so I
could see this is pretty much right down
the middle in terms of difficulty okay
so if it's zero it's an easy keyword if
it's if it's a hundred it's very
difficult and then that means you have a
lot of competitors who are optimizing
for this keyword that are ranking for
this keyword and so Moz gives us the
volume they give us the competition and
Ma just like Google's Keyword Planner
gives us some other keywords that we can
potentially hone in on so here I could
see keyboard delivery plans delivery
services
Etc so I can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so Moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis related to the
keyword you know they also give you some
good keyword suggestions so Moz is a
good alternative tool and we'll be
coming back to Moz related to SEO for
some other of its features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
Google's Keyword Planner because maybe
you're not running Google ads you can
always use Mazda remember Moz has
basically a freemium version I mean you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you could test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use mods we want to be able to
use Google's Keyword Planner not only to
search for all those relevant keywords
available to you but we want to be able
to choose keywords with high volume and
low difficulty low competition we also
want to select primary and second
keywords wisely so remember when you
optimize you're optimizing a page for
more than one keyword so you want to be
able to have a nice portfolio of diverse
relevant keywords with high search
volume and low difficulty and then you
want to be able to identify those
keywords that your competitors are
ranking for so Moz gives you that
information and so we want to be able to
leverage the tools available to us to
choose the right keywords so if you need
any more information on this we got a
nice webinar on keyword research for SEO
so take a look at that video on YouTube
to get more specific details about using
SEO tools for keyword research and all
about keyword research in general for
SEO so let's talk about some other
reasons under SEO what we would use some
of these tools available to us well we
want to be able to understand the search
engines and how they crawl and index our
site okay we also want to check the
correct format of the site map and we
want to monitor backlinks okay we also
want to analyze linking to our web page
okay which ones are good which ones are
not good okay we also want to perform
some competitor analysis so these are
some of the reasons why other than
keyword research why would we use some
of these SEO tools so we have tools
available to us some Majestic hrefs
again Moz let's take a look at Google
search console and I want to hone in on
Google search console because it is free
and it's a must if you're going to work
on SEO you need to be work working in
Google search console and so the whole
key behind Google search console is you
have a website you need to get that site
verified once it's verified once Google
can recognize that you are associated
with this website then you're going to
be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I could see I
have some issues with 112 pages and some
of those issues are listed down on here
so there could be a crawl issue a 4-4
you know redirect okay so you could see
there's some five unique issues across
112 pages so here I can see submitted
URL Mark no index there's a hundred of
those pages we have some redirect errors
there's seven pages that you know fall
victim to this error and so we can
really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if Google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by Google then we should
probably address the error and so that's
the great thing here about going into
Google search console is you can under
index go to coverage and get a sense of
what Google's indexing and what they're
not indexing so these are the errors I
could see they've certainly were able to
crawl and index
9115 Pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54
000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
Pages indexed we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling us firsthand what the issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so you have an opportunity to
submit a sitemap and a site map is just
a formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it sitemap dot XML XML being
the format so once you have this file
you're just going to let Google know
that that file exists so you're going to
enter in the sitemap URL so if it's in
the root directory all you're going to
do is type in sitemap.xml and click
submit so once you've done it just like
this site is done what Google's going to
do is say hey look we see you've
submitted this and we last read it a
couple days ago and we could see that we
discovered
1419 URLs so I can go back under
coverage and I can see some of the
issues that they found but if I go back
under sitemaps I can see that these are
the URLs they discovered via the sitemap
and so the whole point of a site map is
we want to be able to get and push the
URLs to Google not have Google come to
our site and discover them this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with Google all the URLs
that you have on your site that you want
Google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report okay so Google
is a staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so the beginning on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Googled is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
Via Mobile and when I say fares Via
Mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it format added to Google
standards and so if there are any issues
Google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here I could see
Google's recognized 206 Pages before
different issues okay so here I can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here I could see
for 206 Pages text too small to read
click elements to close together the
viewport not set to device with and then
content wider than the screen so there's
10 pages that fit under this error and
if I actually click on it the error I
can see what those 10 pages are and so
when we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
Google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
Google telling Google look I see what
the issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with Google Google and let
them know hey we do recognize the errors
we are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these Pages
indexed quicker
um so if you ignore the issues then the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether Google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get a little value them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report in
Google search console shows us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the home page is 26 000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I could see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console has given me kind of an
overview of what my linking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so I'll be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search consoles links
report okay there's one more report that
I think's of interest in Google search
console and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you can link up
with Google analytics so you can see the
same report and analytics if you're able
to link up Google search console with
analytics and you should be able to do
that all you need to do is make sure you
use the same email address that you use
for analytics and search console so it
needs to be the same email address you
could certainly link up the two and have
this data imported into Google analytics
so what is this data that we're talking
about well it's called performance so
what we can actually see is the queries
the actual queries people are typing in
to Google so when they're typing them
into Google we can actually see how many
Impressions the keyword queries received
and how many clicks the keyword queries
received and then I can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword on the first line I
could see over the course of the last
three months it received 209
297 Impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used or
typed in as a query at least that many
times and that's how many times my
listing appeared and the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and Google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the 209 297
into the 120 000 397. okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you your click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57 so
over half of of the clicks occur when
this listing appears for this keyword
okay so we can get a sense of the click
the array for each one okay and you
could simply just use the filtering here
now we can also see average position
okay so we could see a little bit more
than that too we can go from queries to
Pages we can go from pages to countries
so we get a sense of how many
Impressions and clicks I'm receiving by
country and importantly we can see by
device so here I can see a majority of
the people who conduct a search related
to my website primarily do it on desktop
now I mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I could
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my Impressions my clicked array bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when I
link up Google search console with
analytics I'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these SEO
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from sitemaps to keyword
research but we also want to hone in on
you know what domains are driving links
to our site so I showed you an example
in search console we also want to hey
maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with the particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and Impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like Moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a Moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about Moz is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and on-page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score out
of 1 and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm
going to be actually able to see the
actual domains pointing to my site as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look at
all the domains that are linking to me
and then I can highlight the ones that
have poor domain Authority what must
even takes it a step further they also
give me a Spam score so Moz is able to
measure how spammy a website is so if I
have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you can see here as I keep going
down for example I can see this
particular website has a domain
authority of 26 and it has a Spam score
of 16 so not a good combination this
should alert me to the fact that hey
this particular site because it has so
many links pointing to me or it has at
least one link pointing to me that I
probably want to disavow myself because
it's probably hurting my own domain
Authority so that's the great thing
about this linking domains report is I'm
able to hone in on not only who's like
link linking to me meaning domain but
how many linking domains does that
domain have what's the spam score of
that domain what's the domain authority
of that domain and then I can get into a
little bit more detail and actually see
you know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about backlinks domain Authority spam
Etc everything you need to use in order
to measure off page SEO so that's the
great thing about Moz is they have not
only on-page SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a freemium so to speak
so here you can see if you just go to
mods.com free Dash seo-tools you'll be
able to use some of these tools
available to you not just for SEO out
but also for local SEO as well so here
you like some of these tools you can
start your free 30-day trial so I use
and lean on Moz a lot for all that it
has to offer from choosing keywords to
rankings report to checking issues on my
website to even checking who's linking
to me so this fits in the mold with
everything I need to do for SEO so in
addition to that keyword research video
you could certainly lean on some other
webinars that we've done in the past on
SEO so we've done a webinar on SEO tools
and we've also done a webinar on SEO
tips and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or SEO in general take a look at those
two videos and check them out and that
should kind of complement what we talked
about with using some of the tools
Google's Keyword Planner Moz and Google
search console okay let's switch over to
email marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us in the form of reporting in the
form of Platforms in the form of you
know tools that really help us go from A
to Z on our email choosing you know what
email to send out to creating a list to
measuring how the email campaign went
and so we could start with MailChimp
because mailchimp's a freemium version
when we say freemium meaning they have a
free trial available then you're
expected to upgrade but you know
MailChimp to me is a tool I use I like
the interface very easy for beginners so
we're going to take a look at MailChimp
but there are certainly many others
available you know more cattle is a good
tool you know Marketo is a good toll
because if you have a business and
you're trying to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning they
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well Marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about Marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a HubSpot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to you
know emails so this is another freemium
tool that you could use you have another
freemium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convertkit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use cost instant
contact vertical response they're plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comment section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you know different
tools because they are so literally so
many email marketing tools out there why
because email marketing has been around
probably the longest amongst all the
other digital marketing channels and a
lot of people use email on a daily basis
so it's no wonder why there's just so
many tools available and so with these
tools you can certainly send bulk emails
now in the case of Mercado you can send
emails to a segmented audience and so
that's a actually what you want to do as
a strategy is always send emails to a
segmented audience you know you want to
use a tool where you're going to be able
to create campaigns then send those
campaigns to again segmented contacts
and then be able to design your email
around that particular audience so you
know you have a good tool when you can
do that when you can really segment for
your audience okay you want to be able
to use a tool that's going to be able to
segment your users you know use
transactional emails meaning hey look if
somebody go ahead went ahead and
purchased can you follow up with an
email and creating workflows just like I
mentioned with Marketo you want a
workflow set up where hey if somebody
does this you're sending email B Etc so
you want an email marketing tool that's
flexible enough to handle what your
business strategy and goals are okay so
you want to be able to also use a tool
that you know has various email
templates available okay you don't want
to be stuck with just a vanilla template
again you want to be able to customize
an email for your audience you want to
be able to manage your list
appropriately meaning if you have 10 000
users or emails in a list you want to be
able to manage them accordingly you know
break them up or or have sub lists so to
speak and then most importantly you want
to make sure you have a platform that
not only does its tracking on its own
but will give you some detailed insights
meaning you know what percentage of
users opened your email what percentage
of recipients clicked on your email what
links do they click on you know which
which emails bounce so you want some
detailed insights right in the platform
that you're using it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want to create that
smart automated campaigns meaning you
don't even have to send out the email
and then you want to be able to have
some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time of day
so these tools also allow you to your
sigmat contacts based on geolocation you
want to be able to use a tool that
allows for multivariate testing again
you want to analyze performance and
optimize campaigns you want to trigger
automatic responses somebody purchases
something are you using a tool that will
automatically send that email out so
these are all the reasons why you would
use an email marketing tool so let's
dive in and take a look at an example
and we're going to use MailChimp as our
example today so let's dive in and take
a look at MailChimp so with MailChimp
once you log in you know you're going to
be able to see some historical campaigns
that you've sent out or are you going to
be able to create your own campaign and
so this is kind of under campaigns you
can kind of see an overview of the ones
you've sent out or if they're in draft
mode you'll be able to see they're in
draft mode so you can go ahead and edit
them so here we have one that was set up
on August 26th and it's still in draft
mode so we can go ahead and edit that so
if we just click edit you know we have
the flexibility to you know pick and
choose who we're sending this to who
it's from what the subject line is and
then we can certainly design the email
so if we click design email again this
is important because with email
marketing you want to be able to cater
your email to your intended audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with intended audience and so
here you can see MailChimp allows us to
do that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste your code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reporting okay
so yes it is easy to choose a template
and map that template to your audience
but I really like make the reports that
they have to offer so you know here you
can see there's some lists that we've
sent to and we choose one of our
audience lists then we can see some
really detailed reporting here and so
here I could see this email that was
sent out in June I could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers this all 2000 Plus open it
and 157 clicks so I can view this report
in more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so I
can get down really to the nitty-gritty
I can actually see you know on the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent two different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16 I
only had an open rate of 2.5 percent so
the industry average is 18 and so here
I'm able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers put the
most opens I can link social to it if I
want to and then I can see geographic
information so the point being is
MailChimp really goes into some nice
detail here about the email campaigns
and how they performed so the great
thing is too with the MailChimp you
could link it with a Google analytics
you can link it with e-commerce okay so
if you have an email and you're you're
selling products and somebody purchased
that product MailChimp is able to
integrate in with your shopping Commerce
platform for example woocommerce so if
somebody did purchase you can send out
that thank you email MailChimp even goes
a step further and if somebody did click
on a link go to your shopping cart add
something to the shopping cart and then
abandon the cart you know MailChimp
allows you the opportunity to retarget
them via email so MailChimp is flexible
and that's what you want in a email
marketing platform you want something
that's flexible that you can cater to
your audience you can manage your
audience list and you can get detailed
reporting on your different campaigns
for that audience so that's MailChimp
and summary and so most email platforms
do a lot of similar features or have
some similar features but that's what
you ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform so here's a tool that
doesn't get talked about enough when it
comes to email marketing and that's
Google's URL Builder and the reason why
we're going to talk about this tool
today is because most people in the US
use Google analytics as their web
Analytics tool and the one thing about
Google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
MailChimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have a URL
that says visit Florida and I'm going to
send out an email I have up to five
parameters that I can use Okay so here's
my email or URL that I'm using in the
email so I have up to five parameters
that I can use to track this particular
email so let's go through some of those
parameters so the first one is campaign
source so what's the source of the
campaign well we could certainly
identify MailChimp if we're using
MailChimp as the source now the the
thing about the URL Builders you always
want to use lowercase because Google
analytics is case sensitive so as a rule
of thumb just stick with a lowercase so
our source is going to be MailChimp
because that's the platform we're using
if you're using you know Constant
Contact or vertical response or you know
some of these other one convertkit then
go ahead and put in that platform as the
source now for the medium which is the
means in which we're driving traffic to
the site let's go ahead and put in email
because that's what we're using to drive
traffic to this particular page now
what's the campaign name well we're in
summer so we're going to call this the
summer promo so there's summer promo
here is visit Florida beaches okay so
we're going to send this email out to
the masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to Florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice I got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so Google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email I would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do I say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say if 10 000 recipient I want to be
able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's going to get
subject line one and one segment that's
going to get subject line two so in this
case I'm going to put whatever subject
line one is in the campaign content
field so now I have four parameters and
once I've entered in my variables in
those parameter Fields I now have a
revised or pended URL so my original URL
was visit florida.com
Florida Dash beaches.html my original
URL I've now appended that with some UTM
parameters and now I see my original URL
appended with the UTM parameters based
on those variables so I can copy it just
by clicking the copy URL I can go to my
browser I can paste that URL in there
and I want to check to see if it works
so here I could see this particular page
loaded Florida beaches with my etm
parameters appended to the URL so that's
for the first subject line that's for
the audience it's going to get the first
subject line I want to do another one
for the second subject line so now I'm
going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
I'm going to copy that URL I'm going to
check it okay so I could see that the
page loads with those U10 parameters and
so now what am I going to do I'm going
to use the first URL and the second URL
in my email okay so any link that I have
in this case I'm using subject line two
so for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link I'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the URL
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
going to be able to see that that click
in Google analytics so if I jump over to
Google analytics after I send out my
email I'm going to go to acquisition I'm
going to go to campaigns I'm going to go
to all campaigns now based on the
variables I put into my parameters
meaning Source medium campaign name
content or term that's what I'm going to
look for in Google analytics so we can
start with source and medium so if I
click on source and medium as my primary
Dimension here I can see MailChimp and
the actual dates was used as part of the
variable for for source and then what
can I see the medium being email so now
I can see for this email that was sent
out in MailChimp in May I could see how
many users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conver versions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email drove in traffic and conversions
and if I'm doing subject line testing I
can choose content as my parameter so
here I'm going to change it to content
and now I can see the subject lines in
this case if I go back to my source
medium I'm going to be able to see what
subject lines from my emails generated
the most traffic and not only the most
traffic but also conversions so that's
the whole point behind using the URL
Builder again you're taking a URL that
you're going to use an email and then
you're going to pan that URL with
different parameters campaign so Source
campaign media campaign name and then
optionally campaign content or campaign
term okay once you've entered variables
into those parameters you're going to
get it appended URL which you can then
use in your email so when the email gets
sent you're going to go back over to
Google analytics and you're going to
look at the results of that campaign of
that source of that Medium of that
content IE subject line and so that's
why the URL Builder is so important
because MailChimp gives us some good
insight as to how the email performed in
terms of open and click rates but what
we really want to see is how that
campaign performed once it drove traffic
to my website so that's the whole idea
behind the URL Builder if you're using
Google analytics you'll be able to use
the URL Builder with whatever email
platform you're using so let's move on
to web analytics tools and this is an
important section because web analytics
tools kind of the central focal point of
all digital marketing and it starts
really with Google analytics Google
analytics is a freemium meaning that
they have a free version that you can
use there is also a paid version of
Google analytics but given the Advent of
Google it's popular especially in the
United States a majority of users are
using the free version of Google
analytics so it's a very popular tool
especially for marketers but there are
also other tools available so it's not
just Google so we have Adobe analytics
which is also freemium you have kiss
metrics you have spring metrics you have
YouTube analytics which is part of
Google but YouTube has its own separate
analytics insights so a lot of these as
you can see are free to use they're
available no reason why you should not
be using uh an Analytics tool to measure
your marketing campaigns or website
behavior and why would we want to use
these tools again well again we want to
really measure Behavior we want to
measure what's going on with our website
so we want to be able to identify the
location of where our website visitors
are coming from and a lot of these
analytics tools use IP address to
identify the location of a website
visitor so if you're trying to Target a
specific country then you want to be
able to see that the visitors to your
website are coming from that specific
country or location we also want to
measure the engagement of our website
Behavior so we get traffic to the
website what are they doing how long are
they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use is web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50 new and 50
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors because that means more traffic
so you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web Analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you could turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
and analytics tools will help us
identify what's not working from our
site perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can can get in a
good Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel
spring metrics you know they all work in
a similar fashion and that they're
really measuring website behavior and so
if we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken down
into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
San Francisco California came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device
and they're a returning users so they're
painting a picture for you okay so
they're not giving you a list of names
that would not be legal but they are
providing you with a good picture of who
is coming and when I say picture we have
to paint that picture and so if we look
at say demographics for example and I
got a demographics overview here's a
picture I'm painting well I can see that
25 to 34 year olds are the majority of
the age group that is coming to my
website okay I can see on the gender
side of it I can see that 63 percent of
my traffic and again this is year to
date that I'm looking at is coming to my
website so two-thirds of my traffic is
female one-third male and they're
between the ages of 25 and 34. so I'm
painting a picture about you know gender
and age coming to my website well I can
also look at Geo so where specifically
might these people be coming from so if
I go to location under Geo I'm going to
be able to see a breakdown of country or
I can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I could see
United States is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the US and then 16 from
Argentina 13 from Mexico 10 percent from
India so we have a nice mix of traffic
from different locations in the world
coming to our website so that's Geo but
more importantly let's take a look at
mobile so if we go to mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they on a desktop or laptop are they
using their mobile device are they using
a tablet and so Google analytics breaks
it down very nice for you and so we
could see percentages in actual numbers
by device category and so in this case I
could see year to date I can see 62
percent are coming from desktop 30 35
percent are coming from mobile and so
that's important because most people
start their Journey from mobile and that
is growing and that's going to continue
to grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from Mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in Google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to acquisition so
acquisition reporting tell tells us how
the traffic was driven to the website so
if audience tells us who is coming to
the website acquisition tells us how
that traffic got to the website and so
really what you want to do is get a
sense of what channels what marketing
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexing your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and I'm a Believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines or indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents the
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by Channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then I can see paid search
then I can see direct which means
Somebody went directly to the site I
could see referral email social then I
could see more paid search broken out so
these are the different marketing
channels now analytics allows you to
look at a specific source and medium so
the source would be the actual website
or search engine in the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or did they
come to the site via organic search and
so all we need to do is change our
primary Dimension from default Channel
grouping to source and medium and we
could see specifically the breakout of
the different sources and mediums
driving traffic to the site so here I
can see Google organic it's 71 percent
and and then Google CPC or cost per
click at 15 16 of our traffic so then I
can look down I can see email in here
being organic I could see some referring
sites I could see some social in terms
of mobile Facebook okay so we can see a
mix of the different sources of mediums
driving traffic to the site okay so you
don't always have to look at Channel per
se you can look at it via source and
medium and if you're running Google ads
under acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the Keyword
Planner in Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non-google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what campaigns drove traffic
to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we can
see it right here so this gives us a
nice snapshot of what what keywords are
driving traffic to the site organically
I could see The Impressions I could see
the clicks then I could see the clicked
array and then the average position so
in theory the higher something ranks the
more traffic you're going to get so
that's the idea behind it we want to
make sure that we're ranking for our
coveted keywords and if we are we want
to be able to measure how many times our
listing was seen and how many times it
was clipped so that's the great thing
about you know Google they have a family
of products and those products tend to
talk to one another in the form of
Google search console and Google ads you
can connect them directly to Google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in Behavior we have
a number of different reports so
Behavior tells us what's the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so really what I would
do do is from there go to site content
all pages and so this gives us an idea
of how many pages were actually viewed
so site content all pages tells us what
page and how many times it was viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year to date so I can see
engagement related metrics associated
with a page so this particular page here
on line one I could see how many pages
unique Pages which is equal to sessions
so I can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session I could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and I can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so I can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site for
from so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where I want to react
and optimize my website performance so I
if I see a page now performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe low time on page then I'm probably
going to optimize it meaning test it or
change it to improve performance so
these are all pages but I could
certainly look at landing pages okay so
landing pages tells us the behavior of
the page when somebody landed on it so a
landing page means that somebody came
from organic search or paid search or
another Channel landed on this page so
here I can see this particular page on
line one had
4970 sessions okay and I can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our Pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speech suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here I could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized I can remove
unused CSS okay so there are a lot of
different things I can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop I can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
in page load time we see lift and Page
load time we're going to probably see a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me site speed is an important report
under Behavior now one more report here
that I want to point out under behavior
is events and to me events are important
so if you're trying to measure
engagement on your website you need to
make sure you have event tracking set up
and when we talk about event tracking
we're talking about measuring things
that analytics doesn't measure by
default so if you have a button on your
website if you have a PDF download if
you have a submit button on a phone form
submission if you have a subscribe
button if you have a video if you have
an external link anything that is going
to trigger engagement on your website
you need to measure with event tracking
and event tracking is simply set up by
breaking out the event into a category
and action and a label and so here we
could see for our particular website we
have categories already set up for event
tracking so here for example I can say
on line six video I could see how many
people actually watched our video okay
so here's the action video Start okay so
over this period of time I could see I
had 49 unique events 50 total so that's
how many people actually watched the
video and you can always report to label
and that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if we
go to events under behavior and you
don't see any events listed you probably
need to get that set up and that is set
up through Google tag manager so what
you want to do is you want to be able to
set up your events through Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category in action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under Behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so I'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a PDF uh submitted a
form played a video did whatever we
wanted them to do so events are
important so let's move from the
Behavior to conversions and this is
important because we want to be able to
measure conversions on a website so
analytics has four types of conversions
so if I go to admin down at the bottom
and then I go to goals I could see that
I have four different types of goals
that I can use now right now I have
event related goals set up for the
website for this particular website so
we just talked about event tracking so
if you're measuring a button click on
your website you can certainly turn that
into a goal and so all you need to do is
tell analytics hey this is the
particular category this is the
particular action so for example if I
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it I can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here I could see if
somebody goes to donation Dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like Channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if I look
at this example here if a user came to
my website and looked at more than three
pages in that particular session then
analytics is going to fire a gold
conversion so four types of goals you
don't have to set up all four different
types my recommendation is at least have
one goal set up if you're not sure what
goal to set up then at least set up a
duration or pages per session okay so at
least you can measure how long somebody
stays on your website or how many pages
they went to okay so when you actually
do have these goals set up you can go
back into conversions we can go back
into goals we can go back into overview
and we can measure our goal completions
over this period of time so here I could
see 313 goal completions total with a
goal conversion rate of 1.88 and then I
could see it broken down by goal type so
remember the only goals I have available
and set up all are event related goals
so 69 newsletter signups 156 donate
click buttons I have 32 contact form
submissions 37 email click completions
and then 11 phone number click
completions so I can measure engagement
as a goal and so goals generally are
important to the business so you want to
make sure that if you have a goal for
your website then you want to be able to
set that up as a goal in Google
analytics so that way when you're
looking at example channels if I go back
to my channels report I can then measure
Channel by goal conversion so these are
all goals but if I want to look at for
example how many people from organic
search clicked on the Donate Now button
I could see that I could see
year-to-date 10
887 users which meant 11 1000 sessions
76 clicked on that donate Now button and
that comes out to 0.65 conversion rate
okay so that's important so you want to
be able to measure any Dimension whether
that be Channel Source medium keyword
campaign mobile device could be
demographic gender or age you want to be
able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in Google analytics
again audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so a lot of data in Google
analytics but you want to be able to
take advantage of the data in order to
improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube If you you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your video is
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version of YouTube and then from
there I went to analytics so my account
YouTube Studio analytics and analytics
here is going to give me all sorts of
information about my videos okay so here
I could see over the last 28 days my
videos produced over 8 600 views my
watch time in minutes totaled over 17
000 and I've netted 48 subscribers and
this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here I
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here I could
see 25 came within YouTube itself I
could see how many times the video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so I could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here I could see
externally how people were able to find
my video us and I could see 46 percent
found it via Google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so I could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
I was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times they saw
it and watched it here I can click on
interest viewers so again I could see
the top videos in terms of watch time I
could see the top playlist so here I
could see my partners playlist was the
top playlist so I could see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I get see 88 of
the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them if they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our video is
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of us if you're publishing videos on a
regular basis you want to hone in on how
your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
YouTube analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spine tools very important
to keep tabs on what the competition's
doing and there are a lot of tools out
there so when it comes to social we can
use a freemium tool like Sprout social
to listen in on our competitors we can
use another freemium tool all social
blade there's a popular tool out there
called spyfu that's freemium as well Moz
we looked at Moz earlier for keyword
organic Moz is a great tool for also
leveraging our competitors in terms of
backlinks and buzzsumo so that's another
Freeview tool get there lots of tools
out there these are just examples of
some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn I use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition's doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because SEO organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off page
website very tactical and creative
there's a lot going on with SEO a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
SEO does depend on relevancy relevancy
being how many quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much a
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competitions doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
Relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our compare
editor's data and compare it with their
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with Sprout social
and Sprout social is a tool I use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with Sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
post that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example RV rentals in Twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about RV rentals so we could do this for
Twitter we could do it Facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on Sprout social is to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going General here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at you know what some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals Cruise America RV we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I can take a look at
you know what they're doing when they're
posting or tweeting how long ago the
time of day get an idea of what they're
actually saying what campaigns they're
promoting okay I can get a sense of
everything about out this tweet and so
here I can scroll down and I can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and I can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on Twitter as to
what our competitors doing okay let's
start our attention to SEO so remember
that first bullet point we want to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
when it comes to backlinks and so Moz
has a great tool called link Explorer
and Link Explorer there allows us to
actually compare link profiles so for my
domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know how
many links my competitors have external
Intel internal I can get a sense of the
domain Authority I can get a sense of
page Authority linking domains so I can
really do a uh comparison across my
domain and my competitors domains to get
a snapshot of how I compare against my
competitors so this gives me an overview
of everything I need to know organically
now Moz also has a another great tool
under link Explorer called link
intersect and I like link intersect I
use it a lot because if our competitors
really have a number of external links
and domains pointing to their site and
they have a better domain Authority and
Page Authority then you know I want to
be able to you know see what they're
doing where they're linking who's
linking to them I want to get be able to
get a snapshot of why is their domain so
much better than ours in terms of
authority and so the link intersect
actually allows me to do that so I can
go ahead and put my competitors domains
in there and then I can find
Opportunities and so you just click on
opportunities and you can see where my
site intersects with their site and if
it doesn't actually intersect then I
have an opportunity to actually try and
get a link on that particular site so
that's what the link intersect report
does it allows me to see where my links
intersect with my competitors and if it
doesn't intersect then I have an
opportunity to generate a backlink so
that's ideally what the link intersect
tool is in mods it allows me to really
get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and where my competitors linking
now what we can also do is also take
advantage of another report under moz's
link Explorer and the discovered and
lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within Moz
we can get a good snapshot of what
websites are linking to our competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites and
specifically what sites so the whole
idea is if it's good for our competitors
meaning they're linking from a site that
has a good domain Authority and low spam
score then it's probably a site I want
to be able to tackle as well okay so you
have discovered and lost okay you have
comparing link profiles and you have
link intersect so those are three good
reports you can leverage right in moz's
link Explorer tool now there's one more
report we can leverage in Moz and that's
the inbound links report and so we can
go ahead and type in our competitors
domain here and again we can get a
snapshot of what their domain Authority
is Page Authority for the home page but
really this is what we're after linking
domains so this particular domain has
over 9 000 linking domains so what we
can do is actually go through and see
based on domain Authority I can sort by
domain Authority where these pages are
being linked from and so here I can see
Reddit
so a lot of Reddit here which is a good
site for backlinking New York Times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here Washington Post so I can get
a good snapshot of my competitor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course I don't want to go
through 9 000 links I can really just
hone in on a specific link Source or
link type or link state so I can really
filter it if I wanted to I can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as I
could see what URL is linking to this
particular competitor site what the
anchor text is with the page and domain
Authority is so this gives me a really
really good Insight on all the
backlinking that my competitor has and
again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need to be on Reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from Reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the gander so they
say so inbound links is just another
good report you can leverage in Moz
under the link Explorer reporting tool
now if I want to get a good snapshot as
to what my competitor is doing on search
exactly well look no further than spy
food so spyfu is a another tool that you
can leverage from a PPC SEO perspective
you know from an SEO perspective you got
some back linking data as well just like
you did in Moz from a PPC perspective
you can get some good keyword insights
and so here I just went ahead and typed
in the domain and what this is going to
do is just give me an overall snapshot
but for my competitor's domain so here I
could see you know how many organic
keywords they're found for the estimated
monthly SEO clicks they're getting based
on the volume of those keywords okay I
could see here the keywords their top
competitors also rank for the rank
history 12 years so this particular
domain's been around a long time okay so
that's on the Organics I can flip over
to the paid side and I could see that
they are doing paid search I could see
5000 plus keywords they're bidding on
okay based on that what they're actually
paying and then I could see you know
some of the other competitors listed
here from a paid perspective and an
organic perspective I could see the
shared keyword overlap okay now again
you can pay for this because it's
freemium and get some really good
insights as to how your domain compares
to your competitors so I'm using the
free version and here the free version
spy Fusion just giving me some overall
data on the specific domain I entered in
and so I entered in my competitors you
can certainly enter in your own domain
to get a sense of organic keywords and
paid keywords so you can see top
keywords top paid keywords okay this is
Google ads okay so this is what
recommendations as to what to purchase
okay here you can see some even some at
Google ads history I could see exactly
what ad copy my competitor actually
wrote and for what keyword and then I
could see some organic ranking history
here as I keep scrolling down this
overview report so I can see for RV rent
where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz spy
food is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spyphus a spy
view gives you kind of an overview for
free some really in-depth analysis if
you actually pay for it and it just
really hones in on what your competitors
are bidding for paid wise and what
they're ranking for organic wise and so
spy food is a really good tool to
leverage if you just want to get a
snapshot of how your competitor uh
overlaps with you so let's turn our
attention to Google analytics because in
Google analytics under audience I can go
to benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous data so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a Pacific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
I'm sharing
8863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our Locale and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment it we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're gonna
go with the
4999 and so we could see there are about
you know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to this report so for
focused on the New Zealand region and
this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
Anonymous web properties so now if I go
back to the report after I've honed in
I'm looking at channels and I can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how I compare against the
competition I can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels I can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your your industry so you're
getting a good idea as to how you
compare against your industry just by
making some adjustments in the
benchmarking report you obviously want
to make sure you're looking at the same
industry adjust for your country or
region adjust for the site size meaning
how many sessions you actually get on a
daily basis and then analytics will do
the rest they'll compare you against
those in your industry and so I find
this to be a good tool because it allows
me to stack up our site against those in
the industry and obviously if we're not
driving as many sessions especially say
from organic then we have our work cut
out for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
further you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a key
word and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I could see some organic search
results okay if I scroll down I'll be
able to see some other companies bidding
on that same keyword meaning they're
paying for RV rentals so if I clicked on
somebody's link here they're actually
going to pay Google for the click and so
this just gives me a good sense of you
know how many people are actually trying
to rank for this keyword or trying to be
found for this keyword so that's all I
did I just did a search now from an
organic perspective if you really want
to hone in on your competition you can
always do the syntax all in title colon
and then hit enter so now I could see I
have 163
000 results and when does that tell me
that tells me that I have a 163
000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have a
000 different listings ahead of you that
you need to jump over in order to rank
for the keyword RV rentals so using the
All entitled syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keywords so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax and
you can see for RV rentals I have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword RV rentals in the title Tag and
Title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind you using the All
entitled syntax it gives us a good idea
as to what our competition is doing and
how many sites we have to jump over to
get to number one on Google Now if
you're running Google ads just as we did
with RV rentals we went out there and we
saw we typed that in as a query and we
saw how many advertisers there were for
RV rentals now if we are running our own
campaigns Google ads actually has a good
report that I really like it's called
auction insights and so you can get to
auction insights just by clicking on
campaigns and then from campaigns click
on auction insights and when auction
insights allows us to see is what
competitors or domains are bidding on
the same keywords we are and so what
Google does here is it allows us to
actually see where we stack up against
our competition for all the keywords
we're bidding on and so here I'm looking
at year to date and here we can see us
and I can see our competitors okay so I
could see impression share so for if
we're talking about one key word every
keyword has a hundred percent impression
share how much of that impression share
are you getting and when we say
impression share meaning eyeballs when
we talk about eyeballs are we getting a
majority of the eyeballs or our
competitors get a majority of the
eyeballs so we can see our average
position I can see how often I overlap
with my competitors okay I could see how
often I'm above a particular competitor
I could see what percentage I'm at the
top of the page versus my competitors
the absolute top of page rate and then I
can see how often I outrank my
competitors and vice versa how often my
competitors outrank me so I could see
all this good insight as to what
competitors are bidding on the same
keywords I am okay so this is if you're
running Google ads okay so if you're
running Google ads okay you can just
click on the auction insights report you
can find them at the top navigation just
by clicking on campaigns and by doing so
you'll be able to gain some insights as
to where you stack up from a paid search
perspective against your competitors so
let's turn our attention to paid
marketing tools so if you're doing some
advertising on Google Bing LinkedIn you
probably want to work within those
platforms as the tool of choice so you
know if you're doing paid search on say
googlesearch.com or display you could be
doing display advertising on you know a
network like adroll or Google or you
could be doing social media paid ads say
on Facebook so whatever it is you're
doing you probably want to work within
that platform itself to get the ideal
data that you need okay so here are some
of the tools some of the places you can
go of course if you work in Google ads
you also have Google ads editor that you
can leverage okay and I'll show you that
in a couple minutes you have Google ads
Keyword Planner of course both of these
are paid if you're running campaigns
okay so Bing if you're running campaigns
on bang okay you get all this good data
that you can digest through some
reporting okay you also have some
third-party tools out there that you
also have to pay for in word stream okay
so word stream is a third party tool
that you can leverage Bing and Google
are actual advertising Network so you
would advertise on the platform itself
and get all the data you need right in
the platform and leverage a lot of the
tools that they have available in the
platform as I mentioned you could also
use Google ads editor uh so Bing also
has their own editor as well so and as
well as Facebook so you can use an
editor type version and I'll show you
that here in a couple minutes but let's
talk about why we want to use the tools
in the platform itself well we want to
be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting are they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to measure
by device okay so we also want to
analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitor section
Google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so Google itself does
provide some information in the case of
auction insights as to how your
competitors are performing against you
on Google search so that's on the page
search side then you have display okay
so display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example Admiral okayo seltra is
another paid version of or pay tool you
can use in wide orbit so these are some
of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage of course I like to stay if I'm
advertising on Google I like to stay on
and Google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage ad roles reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and AD performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and write customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to to make sure we're
choosing the right audience of course
that means looking at not only audience
insights but our Target insights as well
are we reaching the Right audience when
it comes to display and Google has a
good breakdown that I'm going to be able
to show you here in a couple of minutes
okay so we want to improve our campaigns
by monitoring our competitors display
ads as well so there are tools available
that'll help you do that and that's on
the display side and if we look at
Social okay why what tools can we use on
social well you got Facebook ads manager
okay you got ad espresso quiet tweepy
you get all these cool paid search tools
again I usually stick with where I'm
advertising so if I'm advertising on
LinkedIn or Twitter I'm going to
leverage that platform but just know
that there are other tools available for
you so a social like display it's all
about targeting our audience so for
these some of the tools like on Facebook
we can review and relaunch our ad
campaigns based on target audience we
can measure conversions and gain
insights in this example about Facebook
users how are our users interacting with
our ads and then we want to Target
People based on their activities such as
purchase intent device usage travel
preferences Etc so social allows us to
do that and then with Facebook as an
example we can monitor any a B test we
run for example if we're running call to
action tests we can measure the results
that right in Facebook and I'm going to
show you an example of that here shortly
so let's jump right into Google ads and
look at some tools available to us from
the search side of the house so if we're
running search campaigns right in Google
ads we could see campaign data we can
see keyword data we could see add data
so for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks
click-through rates
Etc and so that way I can go ahead and
pause ads activate ads so that's right
here in the Google ads platform itself
now if I want to look at specific
keywords I can do that so I can see what
keywords are driving traffic and clicks
here I could just sort by clicks and now
I can see not only what keywords are
driving clicks I could see what the
click-through rate is I can see the
Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm betting on I
could see how much I've paid by keyword
and more importantly I want to be able
to see conversions or conversion rate
and then with Google ads you have
quality score so we want to be able to
measure quality score so so this is a
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if I
see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or I
want my ad shown for then I can go ahead
and just select it and I can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in Google ads
okay and then you have the auction
Insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what their overlap
rate is positioned above rate top of
page absolute top of page right now
rankings here so once we have Google has
data then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
key words but there's a cool tool that I
really like and I leverage it for SEO
and pay-per-click and that's Google's
Keyword Planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on Keyword Planner
we'll be able to Leverage The Keyword
Planner and the whole idea behind the
Keyword Planner is do we want to
discover new keywords or for the
keywords we have selected we can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
of volume I'm going to get and how much
I can expect to pay so now once I've
added my keyword to that plan I can go
ahead and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of two dollars so I can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
I want to in order to see basically how
much I can expect to spend so that's the
whole idea behind the keyword Banner in
terms of choosing new keywords and once
you choose keywords you're interested in
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
Impressions you can expect to get and if
you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of Google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
different tools and features within
Google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so really I'm just going to
highlight some of the more important
tools and features so I mentioned the
Keyword Planner I imagine the campaigns
keywords and ads reports another thing I
would look at in Google ads again we
mentioned this as one of our key
defining why would we use it bullet
point and that's because of devices so
we mentioned devices why would we use
Google ads reporting tool because we
want to look at devices and we want to
be able to see what devices are driving
traffic from what campaign and then the
cool thing about Google ads is write in
Google ads platform you can go ahead and
do a bit adjustment so if I increase my
bid adjustment for example on mobile
phones then my particular ad in this
particular campaign is going to show
more than on computer so I can always
decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
right in Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices while you also
have locations too so we mentioned that
as one of the reasons why we want to use
some of these tools and if I see a
particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bit
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned and search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your can with
your campaigns on locally so you're
making changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I could see the ad groups here okay so
for example I just wanted to turn off
all these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status enable to
pause and I can revert back if I want to
okay so you can make household changes
so here I could see the campaign the ad
group level if I choose an ad group then
I can see some keywords and again I can
make changes at nauseum here I can copy
I can paste I can delete okay so I can
make a lot of changes really quick write
in Google ads editor and that's the
whole point of editor is to go ahead and
work locally while somebody else is
working locally on the same account you
could both be working simultaneously and
being more efficient on getting things
done in the campaign now if you are
working with somebody else on the
campaign you want to make sure that you
get recent change changes so if I say
get recent changes to all campaigns what
Google editor is going to do is contact
Google ads in the cloud and download all
those changes so here I can see the
changes being download and editor from
Google ads and when it's done it's going
to highlight all the changes that have
been made and so once I'm done reviewing
those changes I can go ahead and click
done and now I know I have the recent
latest changes in editor so now I can go
ahead and continue to make some changes
and when I'm done making changes I can
go ahead and post them so that's the
beauty of Google ads editor Bing has a
version Facebook has a version it allows
you to again go with the keyword level
the ad group level okay you can look at
ads itself and make changes to the ads
okay you can do a lot of different
things write an editor in fact you could
do pretty much most of what you could do
in Google ads you could do in Google ads
editor and so that's Google ads Editor
to me I would recommend it if you're
experience with Google ads again it's
software you have to download it you're
going to use it on your computer as
software but when you make changes all
you need to do is post those changes or
get recent changes that have been made
on Google ads and so that's Google
editor ads editor in summary now let's
go back into Google ads and talk about
display advertising because display is a
different network but the platform's
still the same and some of the same
tools are available from the search
Network as well as for the Display
Network right in Google ads so if I want
to take a look at a campaign and AD
group on the Display Network I can just
click on that ad group and I can look at
the ads that are running for that
particular ad group on the Display
Network so here the difference being on
the display network is you can use image
ads on the search Network you can only
use text ads so here I can look look at
image ads and I can see how they're
performing in fact you could even go a
step further and use responsive display
ads so Google has responsive display ads
meaning it's going to respond to what's
performing best okay and so now I can
see clicks Impressions click-through
rate Etc right on on my ads and
extensions report in Google ads platform
now this happens to be retargeting
campaign so if we click on audiences
we'll be able to see what audiences
we're targeting here okay so when this
report loads when you run retargeting
campaigns you're targeting a specific
audience and so we want to be able to
see okay of the audiences we have set up
what audience is performing best okay so
here I can see a Breakout by audience
again I could see the same metrics I
could see on the search side I can see
clicks and Impressions click the rate
more importantly I want to be able to
measure conversions okay so that's the
whole idea when you're in these
platforms and you're paying for ads is
you want to be able to measure against
conversions and you can also measure
against cost per conversion conversion
rate okay so those are some key metrics
to measure up against whether it's
audience keyword add whatever the
dimension is so here on the Display
Network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
Network the Display Network allows us to
see demographic data and so now I could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that Google provides us and I
could see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks Impressions
Etc including conversions so you also
have the opportunity on the display
networked at keywords you have the
opportunity to add topics and you have
the opportunity to see placements or run
placements so here if I click on where
ADS have shown I can actually see where
my ads have shown up for this display
campaign and Google ads allows you the
ability to go ahead and you can exclude
it from the ad group exclude a specific
placement from a campaign so you could
take action on a specific placement and
I could see the type of placement
whether it's a mobile app whether it's a
site I can go ahead and see exactly
where that placement was so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising I
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on Google ads okay
so take a look at the Google ads
tutorial we have set up on on YouTube
okay if you search for Google ads
tutorial 2019 this is a good uh tutorial
on everything related to Google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you could see just how powerful
it is and all the different features
that are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complimentary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on Google ads and if you have any tools
or features on Google ads whether it's
the search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into to
uh Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and I can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now I can go
in and I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the creatives I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has a
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
I could see some standard reports by add
add set age and gender and then I can
see all reports here listed out by
placement by placement and device time
of day country Etc so if we just look at
age and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so you can
see by campaign I'm looking at all
campaigns here and I'm looking at just
age and gender I can certainly deselect
one of these and I can look at a
specific time range so now I could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here I could see 35 to 44 female I can
see the reach Impressions and how often
they're actually seeing my ad now this
is key for Facebook because if
somebody's seen your ad a lot they're
probably going to tune out to it so
that's what makes the frequency metric
so important on Facebook because then we
can go ahead and you know turn off that
particular age and gender if we needed
to and we could see how much we spent so
this just gives you some idea of the
type of reporting that's available in
Facebook ads manager now the great thing
about phase Facebook reporting and ads
manager is you know I can group or
ungroup uh my Dimensions if I needed to
I could change the view and arrange
columns I can get rid of columns just as
you would in Google ads reporting very
similar stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you can pick and choose as
well okay and you got lots of different
flexibility when you're looking at the
reports on how your campaigns are
performing now here I can pick and
choose I can choose campaign ad set ads
objective again I can choose different
demographics so I have a lot of options
available to me in terms of how I want
to you know view the performance of my
campaign view the performance of my ad
set or my ad now remember if you're in
Facebook you can always go in and edit
the campaign you can edit the ad set
remember in the ad set that's where a
lot of your decisions are going to be
made including how you want to drive the
traffic okay what your budget is okay
you can basically choose your audience
here so you're going to be able to
choose what type of campaign it's going
to be and based on the campaign you're
going to go ahead and choose the kind of
audience you want to focus in on you're
going to be able to choose the location
the age range the gender so all of this
is going to be set up in the ad set or
the campaign or the ad if you go ahead
and edit an ad remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you writing ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
Facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and Facebook ads
manager check out the Facebook ads to
tutorial 2019 a webinar that we did
earlier this year in addition you can
also look at another one that we did on
Facebook called Facebook advertising
tips and strategies so that should give
you some sense of everything related to
Facebook ads and how to take advantage
of the Facebook ads manager platform so
if there's anything on social that we
may have missed or that you use feel
free to add a comment below the video
we'd love to hear your feedback okay
let's talk about some affiliate
marketing tools let's turn our attention
affiliate marketing a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms out there the number
one probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ they're an affiliate
platform they have a freemium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click Inc A1
so a lot of these are Brokers per se and
when I say Brokers like for example with
CJ you as a merchant or you as a
publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and it's a lot of a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually going
to take a look at CJ and go through some
of the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know Affiliates
influors employees other Advocates you
want to partner with so again you can be
on the merch inside you could be
actually selling a product and you're
going to want somebody to help you sell
that product somebody with a website
who's an influencer who drives a lot of
traffic to their own site who you know
does sell reputable brand
Etc so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so CJ
and some of these other marketing
platforms affiliate marketing platforms
do that okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with Affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am I only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use You're Gonna Want to be able to
set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you can set up a
terms and conditions for say 10 off all
sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and this is
affiliate helping me sell so you the
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain a High website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social so
you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics Okay
so so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click EPC as an example
most platforms measure EPC from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say Google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
Impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many Impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
Impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so these platforms are
really built on helping you manage your
relationship with the affiliate by
offering uh all sorts of reports and
tools you know the other big benefit
here to affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody see our product does
somebody click on a product did somebody
go into the shopping cart with our
product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publisher's link so we're going to click
on the Publisher's link and remember
when you sign up Publishers you have to
have program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember you
could set up your own program term for
any publisher so as a best practice if
you have Publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know These Guys these Publishers get
better program terms versus say other
Publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you
could see what the terms are the action
and the different policies here so
everything you you need to do to manage
that publisher in terms of payment is
done under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the ones who are going to
initiate the payment based on the
program terms so be careful in the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program program
terms and so you can align Publishers
with different program terms and so
that's the whole idea behind program
terms is you want to be able to align
Publishers with that so when you sign up
a publisher they're going to get a line
with the program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click and
in terms of Publishers now you can
select under Publishers groups now you
can group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea Beyond affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping in them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm going
to repeat it is you want to get
Publishers and you want to start
building your base of Publishers because
the more Publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's gonna buy your
product so if you have Publishers who
are promoting your product for you then
you have a good opportunity to sell it
so the more Publishers you have on board
the better the opportunity so now once
you have Publishers you can start
grouping these Publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in CJ to group Publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one I can think
about here is HootSuite HootSuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here you you basically a
base account and then you can use
HootSuite to do a lot of things anything
from setting up landing pages to
actually publishing content to listening
HootSuite to me is one of the most
powerful social media marketing tools
available you got buffer buffer is a
paid version but you can actually set up
a low cost or free account actually on
Buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got tweet deck it's been around
a long time that is actually free and I
would recommend tweet Tech and we're
going to take a look at that here in a
couple minutes okay and then you got
Sprout social Sprout social is another
social marketing platform similar to
HootSuite do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're going to take a look at
Sprout social today as well before we do
that let's go over why these tools are
important to us from a social media
perspective you're pumping out a lot of
content so you need to be able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like Facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products Etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be Instagram Pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything in one place then the social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one Twitter account
but multiple Twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor the results
so monitor social media posts that help
Drive leads and sales in other words
you're going to have a lot of different
metrics associated with each social
media marketing platform okay which one
is actually doing its job okay so you
want to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform you just log into
one place get a sense of what's been
posted what the engagement is did they
purchase Etc and what you want to do is
be able to individually customize every
social media post across different
platforms so it just makes it a lot
easier to do that in these social media
marketing tools okay you don't want to
send out a blanket message across
different platforms you want to be able
to go ahead and customize a post
depending on what that post is depending
on what the product is what time of day
what target market what target audience
so customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook insights
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can and measure all that in one place so
if we log into sproutsocial I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I can see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is our ready and
Facebook insights so if it's available
on Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you could
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do we could schedule
it for tomorrow at a specific time and
there you go voila scheduled so this is
on Twitter okay so you know we could
choose another platform here it's just
that easy to schedule so you want to be
able to schedule accordingly because
again when you schedule something then
you want to look at the behavior of it
so it's just as simple as going from
publishing to reporting and then based
on one something got published you could
see the reaction of it and react to it
so another thing here that I like about
it's about social HootSuite a lot of
these other platforms do it really well
you got listening tools so you can
listen in on conversations that are
being had for example uh mail delivery
you know if we do mail delivery and
Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local Okay so
this is Sprout's social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar to sprout social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can out label for it
so that's another benefit to later is
that they have this media library here
they have conversations so I can
actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being had similar to The Listening tool
in Sprout social and they have analytics
so you can actually see right in
later.com how your particular social
media platform is performing so I could
see it here over seven days I can see
the number of followers have increased I
could see the growth rate I can see the
number of Impressions that I've received
okay so I want to be able to see how my
particular platforms performing over a
period of time so I can look at reach
the law profile views website clicks
okay so I can get a lot of good insights
here right in the analytics platform of
later you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your post and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweet deck does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see the
you got the Cricket World Cup you got
you know the soccer football World Cup
going on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging are you
using that hashtag Friday feeling in
their tweets and so the whole idea
behind you know tweetdeck it serves up a
interesting overview so to speak of not
only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweaktag it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter now we do
have a good video out here on YouTube
how to start social media marketing so
if you haven't had a chance to look at
it take a look it goes over some of
these tools that we cover today like
Sprout social later.com you know
Facebook insights so it does cover in
more detail some of what we covered on
these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plug-in if you will so I can go and take
a look at a specific a specific video
and see how many hours it's been watched
how many views minutes watch subscribers
Etc you know the great thing here I can
look at the entire entire account so I
can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid IQ extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because it's good
for video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content on your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site checkup or site analyzer these
are pay tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for Content optimization you know
there's also other key Reddit but but
you know this Keyword Planner uh in
Google there's also a word stream
there's a lot of different keyword tools
out there so you may not have a Google
ads platform and so if you don't have
Google ads then you may not be able to
gain access to Google's Keyword Planner
so having a third-party keyword tool
will pay divins and say well because
those dividends pay off in the form of
not only pay-per-click but also SEO and
if you're heavily invested in content
heavily invested in Social then you may
want to take a look at the keyword tool
keyword it and it's primarily used for
Reddit we talk about page load time so
we looked at that in Google analytics we
know that it heavily impacts SEO so
there are other tools available you got
a third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of and determine in how you
can improve your page load time my
favorite topic conversion rate
optimization so you got a couple in here
crazy egg and zarget okay so I'm gonna
show you another tool called hot jar so
here if you log into hotshot.com you can
set up an account it's actually free and
with the free account you can have hot
chart measure the heat map not only the
heat map but the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hot jar allows
me to you know see on that page where
people are clicking
um I can also see where people are
moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you can see here on the page I could see
people are moving over here to the right
that's where they're clicking mostly if
I switch over to move mode then I can
see on that particular page page where
people are actually moving their Mouse
and then I have my scroll analysis so I
could see you know how far down people
actually scroll on the page and so again
with a paid account you can measure up
to 10 000 page views with the free
version you can measure up to 2000 pages
and so two thousand Pages allows you to
get some insight as to what people are
clicking on or where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so I definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hot jars so hotjar.com is a
tool I would recommend as well so one
final tool and I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention it and that's Google optimized
so Google optimize is a Google platform
that allows you to a B test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with Google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of Google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see I have
an account set up and optimized you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go in a report in here Google
optimize does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at Google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me Google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests and that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
Google optimize is a tool that I would
recommend
call has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on Google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is SEO to solve this
issue I have a few important tracking
factors that Carl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well before we get started with the
ranking factors let me first explain
what SEO is SEO is the practice of
getting traffic from organic search
results on a search engine like Google
Bing Etc depending upon the keywords
search engines shrank websites based on
what content they consider most relevant
to users without further Ado let me tell
you the top 5 ranking factors which can
help Carl to rank his website
first is content quality then its page
speed of a web page after that its
website structure next is SSL
certificates and finally it's backlinks
which is the most important ranking
Factor let's have a look at good content
quality a good content quality is an
essential factor that helps a website to
rank on Google Google ranks content that
completely answers a user's query in our
case cake recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction this article
on the best vanilla cake I've ever had
is a good example of having a
comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include LSI keywords in your content
in SEO LSI stands for latent semantic
indexing they are used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serps an easy way to look for LSI
keywords is on Google serp some of the
LSI keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link Equity across the site
it is important to create a simple
internal website link structure in the
below example a bot crawls on web page 2
by following internal link of the web
page 1. next add suitable images with
descriptive alt text here using relevant
images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for Carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes Etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
Carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your web page is completely
crawlable for Bots as it will enhance
website ranking here as you see this
website is high up on the Google serve
because every web page in it is
crawlable by Bots
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good user experience for
a mobile-friendly design always prefer
short and crisp sentences for easy
reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile-friendly designs are shown here
importantly update the content regularly
by doing this search engine rearranges
your site's ranking for example the
Sally's Baking Addiction cake recipe
blog ranks at number one on Google the
reason it updates content regularly
next we have page speed
page speed defines how fast the content
of a web page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a paid
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate
page speed can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of adequate memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
next use a Content distribution Network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content and multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code Minify
files if your website has numerous CSS
and JavaScript file you can Minify and
combine them
Google says slow page speed results in
high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and URL
a title tag summarizes the website's
content and URL is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example chocolate cake recipe cake
recipe callcake.com is a title tag of a
website where chocolate cake recipe is
the primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and carcake.com is the
brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
[Music]
now talking about URLs always refer a
well-structured short and simple URL
according to backlinko analysis short
URLs tend to rank better than long URLs
moving on to our fourth ranking Factor
let's talk about SSL certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost and rankings
https is used for secure communication
over a computer network
as you can see here Google confirms
https as one of the ranking factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling DNS SEC protocol or use hsts to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking
the next ranking factor is website
architecture the famous digital marketer
Neil Patel says the better your site
structure the better your chance of
ranking higher in the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
Bots to find and index all of the web
page a good site structure results in
good use experience
some of the ways to optimize your site
structure are creating a logical
hierarchy structure which means a good
site architecture not only makes content
easier to find but also helps to gain
traffic
[Music]
includes site Maps so that the Bots can
easily access and index the content
[Music]
go to site navigation in CSS or HTML
because these two languages are easy to
quote and understand
build a comprehensive structure of
internal linking as it improves indexing
of a website and helps in spreading link
juice
coming to our last rifling factor that
is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
Authority
in SEO the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
Google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
LinkedIn Etc participating in high PR q
a sites like quora and post answers to
the questions related to your business
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using SEO and SEO as
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also May us here a
say organic listings where we're going
to talk a little bit about why you'd
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
optimization then we're going to follow
that up with how does Google rank
websites so why does it rank one website
over another and how do we get our
website to rank number one then we're
going to talk about the different types
of SEO or search engine optimization
techniques so you can get your website
ranked number one and then we're going
to finish that off with the do's and
don'ts of SEO so let's get right to it
and talk about why SEO so we're going to
use a basic example and let's just say
you have a Blog you're a food blogger
you're passionate about food and your
Niche is ice cream and let's just say
you have a lot of ice cream recipes you
want to get traffic to your blog you
want people to read your blog and you're
curious why am I not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say Google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for Google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or actually a lot more
about you know keyword usage in your
content so what kind of keywords do you
want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is poor link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say WordPress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
Google would you really want to rank a
website site or blog posts in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result result is we want all our
pages to be ranked number one for
particular keywords so if you want to be
ranked for ice cream recipes well
there's certain things you need to do so
that's generally how it works we need to
apply search engine optimization to
increase a page for keyword we want to
be found for so let me give you an
example so let's just say there's a
hundred students that participated in an
essay competition and so the competition
in this particular case is evaluated on
the basis of is the content relevant are
they using suitable titles for their
essay do they have structure when
they're participating in this essay or
talking about the essay and do they have
a suitable synopsis and is the content
neat and readable these seem all logical
for an essay competition well guess what
they seem logical for SEO because that's
exactly how SEO works it's exactly all
those points I just mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again that the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page SEO
how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well so they basically
follow links you might have heard the
term spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what Google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index So based on
this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
Relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I could see I have one man 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they they may not all be simply learned
pages but nonetheless simply learned is
ranked number one here organically and
there are 1 million 10 000 Pages related
to the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where Google
counts the one million 10 000 results
and so that's a whole idea behind
crawling and indexing Google's able to
cross simply learns website and based on
all the pages that they gather they're
going to make those pages available in
organic search so if you type in a
keyword and your web page is not
available for indexing then you're never
going to show up for that keyword so
that's why it's important to make sure
your website is available available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
the most relevant websites that are in
Google's index are going to pair in the
search results so in the example I gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is SEO and why
SEO we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learn example simply learn
is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not see exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe and say San Francisco you're
going to see different results now if
you do a search for cafes in Mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two Google
search engines in India and United
States google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how Google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of SEO now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on Google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on-page SEO and off-page SEO so first
we're going to talk about on-page SEO so
on page SEO is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on Google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for our web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keywords you want then you
can go and apply on page SEO you can
change the title tag The Meta
descriptions the headers all those
elements can be changed but first you
need to choose your keywords and so
again the primary components we're
looking for are how much traffic you can
get or the search volume how much
competition there is for that keyword
and of course relevancy okay you need to
be able to choose a keyword that's
relevant to the web page you're trying
to rank for and so let me show you
example how to go through this so the
first thing we want to do is we want to
use a tool and the total tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google is going to do
is they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data for from mobile as well
as desktop and so we could see a trend
here that for each particular month over
the last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I can
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media a
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is one
thousand per month on average of the
last 12 months I can also see the
competition is medium but for some other
keywords I can see the search volume
being high like digital marketing course
at 2900 per month but also the
competition is high and so what I would
recommend is a best practice is to
collect all your relevant keywords okay
and put all your relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet and when you put all these
relevant keywords in a spreadsheet you
want to get the data on those keywords
and the data I'm referring to is the
volume and competition so in this case
we have volume from Google planner
Google's Keyword Planner and I have
competition from Google's Keyword
Planner and so if I go into a
spreadsheet and I put all that
information in here I'm going to be able
to see the volume and competition and so
that's important however one thing to
note here is that Google's Keyword
Planner if I go back just give gives us
low medium and high and if I want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe I want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
all in title and then your keyword in
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO
okay you want to
create content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk candidate meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because we have the right
keyword in the title tag and somebody
types in that keyword then chances are
it's going to be relevant they're going
to see it and they're going to click
through to your website and that's the
whole idea behind ranking we want to get
clicks so that's how the title tag
appears so when you optimize it you're
going to update the title tag and this
is how it shows up it's going to show up
at the top of your listing okay and it's
going to be bigger and Bolder than
anything else Google displays so the
second thing you want to optimize is the
meta description and The Meta
description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keyword
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's in included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organization relational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building on a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the content 10
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link any of you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SCS
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing Specialists and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation
thinking naturally and seamlessly go
from one relevant article or page to
another and so that's the whole idea
behind link building and internal link
building it allows Google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to Google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end you
user experience and it's about allowing
Google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to internal linking we want
to be able to use natural language and
so what do I mean by natural language or
natural language processing so what
Google does is in terms of natural
language processing they're looking for
the content and the keyword it needs to
be relevant so when your website is
about digital marketing you don't
necessarily want to rank or try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key or
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing and examples or what
is a digital marketing strategy or how
to become a digital marketing specialist
so those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap and XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply type in say sitemap.xml just as
an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keyword you
want to be found for so it all starts
with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking chain
and also updating the sitemap well those
are elements that you can do on your
website so we're going to switch gears
and talk about a different strategy
off-page SEO because without on page or
off page you can't have a page ranking
so the two work together so you can do
as much as you want on on page but you
still need off-page SEO and you could do
all the off-page SEO you want but you
still need on page so both of these
strategies have to be in full effect in
order for you to rank so let's now
switch gears to off-page SEO and so
off-page SEO is simply the process of
linking or promoting your website using
link building and so if you remember I
talked about this earlier on there's two
types of links internal and external
linking and so for on-page SEO we used
internal linking for off-page SEO we're
going to talk about external linking and
external linking allows us to improve
our website sites recognition or
relevancy or credibility and why do we
want to improve our relevancy and
credibility and trustworthiness and
Authority because we want Google to know
that our web page is trustworthy it is
recognized by other websites and it is
relevant for a particular keyword and so
if we can do that using off-page SEO
methods then Google's going to rank our
web page for the keyword we want to be
found for so it's really off-page SEO is
synonymous with link building and
there's plenty of opportunities to do
link building it just comes down to
creating a strategy so again some of the
benefits to off page well we talked
about you know being credible and
trustworthiness and relevant we need to
do that in order to rank but there's
some other benefits there so if we're
have a link on another credible website
then it's likely going to increase the
traffic to our own website it also
creates high domain Authority and so
what I mean by high domain Authority is
if we have basically links to other web
pages pointing back to us then basically
our domain Authority is going to improve
and when our domain Authority improves
other websites are going to want to link
to us so the higher authoritative we are
for our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
have any link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are incredibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build cred
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing Specialists on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
want to rank and the key behind off-page
SEO or link building is always going to
be content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or it can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that some people could link
from so the whole idea is understanding
who else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web sphere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out there that has content somewhat
of yours so that you can you know get a
link on that particular website or blog
post and so some other ideas behind
having external links pointing back to
your website is social media so social
media is not just Facebook or Twitter
but it expands beyond that there's
there's core there's media there's all
sorts of content generated websites like
Reddit so the list goes on and on you
just need to find what's relevant for
your content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your end user experience if you add
somebody who has say a Blog about cakes
having their link on your blog post so
there's nothing wrong with it because it
also adds to the user experience and if
you're going to ask somebody to put an
external link on theirs you might want
to be open-minded and make sure that
you're are able and willing to put an
external link on your blog post or
website pointing to their content that's
how the web Works especially if the
content's a quality relevant and of good
nature okay so let's move on and finish
up with the do's and don'ts of SEO so we
talked a lot about why SEO what is SEO
how do we rank for SEO what is on page
SEO what is off-page SEO and so let's
just wrap up with some of the things you
again want to do to rank your page for a
particular keyword and some of the
things you don't want to do so the first
thing on the list is optimize for white
hat techniques and what I mean for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything I just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black cat
techniques and blad hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off page
SEO again it's what I mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same
same way as if you were on a quality
website we do want to use our keywords
naturally because title tags are what
people see first on organic search but
you don't want to use the same title tag
on every page of your website so we want
to stay away from doing that so you want
to have a unique title tag for every web
page on your website and ideally what
does that mean that means using our
keyword research to choose one or two
keywords per page and optimizing your
web page for those one to two keywords
so you ideally what you want to do is
have one to two different keywords for
every page on your website we definitely
definitely definitely want to write
engaging content so the content should
be engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a key word that has low volume
High competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keywords that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl they're going to index it the
process take next time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimized for on-page
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's user friendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly search
engine optimization starts with the
keyword because we want to be found for
Relevant keywords and so the first step
in search engine optimization is always
going to be keyword research so it is
the most important step and so what is
keyword research all about well it's
process of identifying keywords we want
to be found for on the search engines so
millions of people use search engines on
a daily basis we want to be found for
those keywords that people type in that
are relevant to the content we want to
be found so going back to the Italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about Italian restaurants or
somebody types in the best Italian
restaurants or Italian restaurants in a
specific City we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
fat based on the factor of how much
traffic or volume a particular search
engine query has and it's based on
competition and really the underlying
Factor here is that all keywords in your
keyword research should be relevant so
you need to understand what those
keywords are so are they relevant to the
content that you want to be found for if
they are then really the two factors you
want to look for is the volume how much
volume or traffic each keyword has
associated with it and then the
competition how many of other websites
are trying to be found for the same
keyword so those are the factors
involved with keyword research you
always want to choose relevant keywords
and then once you find or choose those
relevant keywords you want to be able to
find out exactly how much volume and how
much competitions associated with each
of those keywords and so when you look
at keywords you're always going to
choose relevant keywords but there are
two types of keywords there are short
tail keywords and there are long tail
keywords and we're going to talk about
both of these here so let's start with
short tail keywords so short tail
keywords are generic keywords generally
they're less than three words in a
keyword phrase for example Italian
restaurants so short tail keywords
generally have very high search volume
that means that if somebody types in
Italian restaurants then there's going
to be a large amount of volume with that
meaning that generally a lot of people
type in the keyword Italian restaurant
however with high volume always comes
High competition so if you want to be
found for Italian restaurants know that
if you are ranked number one or number
two or even on page one of Google you're
going to get a lot of traffic however to
get to page one of Google or even
position one or two it's going to take
you a while because there are probably a
lot of websites who are in front of you
who want to be ranked and found for the
same keyword so the whole idea with
short tail keywords is it's a lot of
visibility it's a lot of traffic a lot
of volume but also a lot of competition
and generally the underlying Factor here
is that if you are ranked for very broad
or short tail keyword like Italian
restaurants then chances are it's not
going to be as relevant so if you get
the traffic to your website then chances
are the conversion's not necessarily
going to happen because we don't
necessarily know the mindset of somebody
typing in a very short tail generic
keyword like Italian restaurants they
could be doing research on Italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for Italian food
it could be a tourist looking for
Italian restaurants in a different city
or it could be a person just looking for
Italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances of
the conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example of a short tail keyword let's
just stick with Italian restaurants so
I'm gonna go to a tool called Moz and
while Moz has a tool called the keyword
Explorer and within Moz so if you go to
moz.com and then use the keyword
Explorer you can get an idea of how much
volume and competition are associated
with your a particular keyword so in
this example we're using Italian
restaurants it's a very broad keyword we
could see that the monthly volume is
between seventy thousand and a hundred
and eighteen thousand per month okay so
that means for a particular keyword in
the United States on a search engine
you're going to get about 70 000 to 118
000 people who type in that keyword and
so if we were look at the difficulty of
that keyword you could see that it's
fairly difficult because out of 1 to 100
it's got a score of 43 so it's fairly
difficult however if you notice the
click-through rate is very high so Moz
estimates that we'll have a forty
percent organic click-through rate for
that keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to longer tail words
however if you want the visibility then
you want to use short tail keywords if
you want the conversion then you want to
switch over to longer tail keywords so
longer tail keywords are more specific
they usually consist of more than three
keywords so tie in restaurants very
generic if we add a few more keywords
that keyword phrase it then becomes
longer tail so compared to short tail
keywords longer tail keywords are
generally less competitive and The Surge
volume is not as high okay some point so
if we go back to Moz and then we look at
the keyword Explorer and we'd actually
type in Italian restaurants and let's
just say Orlando Florida
Moz is going to generate some monthly
volume for us and they're going to allow
us to understand how difficult that
keyword is and so here you can see very
very little search volume in fact so
little volume there's 11 to 50 okay so
that means on average that this keyword
generates 11 to 50 queries a month so
very low compared to our short tail
keyword Italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less uh competitive so
if you're interested in conversions and
you have an Italian restaurant in say
Orlando Florida then this is the keyword
you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in Italian in Florida
Florida branded shoes in Florida
something very specific is going to
generate probably a higher conversion
rate than something more generic so
that's the trade-off and so I went to
use long tail keywords well we want to
use long tail keywords and for targeting
pages with a product or specific article
so for interested in that particular
conversion then longer tail keywords are
likely more the way we want to go versus
something more generic which means if
you're using a generic shorter tail
keyword you're more interested in the
visibility and the traffic not
necessarily the conversion when you're
setting up your brand and you need to
make sure it reaches the Right audience
and provide the best results there's
really only one place to turn to it's
one of the largest online advertising
platforms really in the world and that's
on Google and so today we're going to
talk about how to advertise on Google
and let's get right to it and talk about
Google ads and its effect with
advertising so we're going to start out
with what are Google ads well Google ads
used to be called Google AdWords and
it's been around a good while almost 20
years now so really Google has grown at
a really rapid Pace it's become one of
Google's main sources of revenue uh you
could say probably in the 90 percent
tile of its Revenue comes from Google
ads and when we say Google ads we mean
people who pay for advertising on
google.com so Google ads really what it
does is it provides services that fall
under the category of PPC which stands
for pay-per-click UA Also may hear
Google ads or PPC referred to as cost
per click or CPC or sponsored search
really what it comes down to it's a
model so when you advertise on
google.com com and somebody clicks on
your ad basically you're paying Google
for the click okay so it's just really a
business model where an Advertiser pays
Google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay Google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
I want to advertise my business I can go
to Google ads and say Google place my ad
on google.com and then if my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as I pay Google a
fee so Google ads is just an online
advertising platform developed by Google
with which advertisers can pay to
display ads they can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobiles involved so you got
all the necessary devices and platforms
available in Google's ecosystem so for
example if I go to Google Search you
even if I type in you know what is
Google ads here I could see a total of
1.8 billion results for what our Google
ads as my search query so in search you
got a lot of different things going on
here you have organic results you have
videos that are being pulled from
YouTube you got a Knowledge Graph here
you got feature Snippets you got an
organic listing but really at the top
this is what we're going to focus on
today we're going to talk about
sponsored search so you can see here for
this particular keyword query that I
typed in what are Google ads really two
sponsored search or pay-per-click ads
appeared now if I happen to click on any
one of these two and go to that
particular advertisements website
they're going to pay Google a specific
cost per click so that's how it looks on
google.com it really depends on your
query and what ads show up but the great
thing about you know Google ads is they
make it known for the user who's doing
the search query what the ad is so here
I can easily pick out what's an ad a
sponsored search or pay-per-click ad and
what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an Advertiser
advertising on google.com I'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an Advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
Okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have a little ad box next to the
listing so you know if it doesn't have
the little ad box you know it's a paid
search ad now why do we want to
advertise on Google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so what I mean by that is you
know search is really a great place to
advertise because because you're meeting
the consumer halfway meaning somebody's
typing something in and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so Google ads advertises your
product or service to the relevant
audience to ensure the users perform the
action required of them so it's really a
great way to get quality audience to
your website because if somebody types
in something and you happen to offer
what they're looking for basically your
ads going to show up somebody clicks on
it you pay Google for the click and you
get quality traffic and return so the
other great benefit to being on Google
ads is increases brand awareness so it's
a great way to get your product and
brand out there Google has a vast
network
uh also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search Network
itself the search engine itself means
the people you use it every day in fact
here in the United States it's been said
or study that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the United
States so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
Mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of Mind
awareness another benefit to being on
Google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use Google's Display
Network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or such subscribing to a
newsletter or visiting a certain page
okay so if somebody doesn't do what we
want them to do it's okay maybe they're
ready to commit to our product or
service and that's why Google offers up
retargeting so it allows us to reach
that audience a second time so they're
going to be familiar with their product
they're going to be familiar their
website because they've been there and
so we can offer up a very unique
specific ad to that audience so that's a
really good benefit to being on Google
ads so some other benefits here
increased intelligence so you know we
can certainly get data about who is
coming to our audience so we can look at
what device what you know browser Etc so
we can really gain some information
about who's coming to the website we
could certainly measure our performance
so with Google we're paying cost per
click and So based on that model you
know we can certainly measure what
keywords what ads are generating traffic
to the website and how much we're paying
for that okay and if that traffic turns
out to be a lead we can measure that
against that specific keyword or ad or
campaign so we can certainly measure our
performance all the way down the keyword
level and can we can measure up against
how many conversions or what we're
paying for those conversions so Google
ads is a very highly quantitative
approach to advertising because there's
lots of numbers involved and you're
constantly collecting information about
your advertising on google.com and its
Network and another benefit really is
this High flexibility so Google ads has
a number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads Dynamic
responsive ads video ads display layout
so Google ads has very flexible options
in terms of advertising and we're going
to talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what I always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider Google
ads because as we've shown here in our
example if I go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are Google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help in
advertising on Google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option I always say that you know search
is like a frupal okay you have apples
and oranges in that fruit bowl well all
the Orange is organic search and the
apple is paid search they're different
approaches but they share the same fruit
bowl the same real estate so you can
really really help yourself by using
Google ads to complement what you're
doing organically so if you're not
ranked organically for keyword you can
certainly use Google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use Google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with an organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
Google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility Google ads does offer up a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when I say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who's looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor or directions search is
there to serve that that person needs
there's no other advertisement platform
or another Channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be TV or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps OR also known as organic
search but the great thing is Google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift Focus now and talk about the
various formats and Google ads on Google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on Google Search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so JBL headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about Google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we we
call AD extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running Google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad all help you get
that click yes you're going to pay
Google for the click but that's the
whole purpose is to generate the click
from search because remember search is
there to respond to somebody's need or
query and so if you get the click on
your ad chances are it's going to be a
highly relevant visitor to your website
so Google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text that on google4 google.com so
Google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean Google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are all responsive they
adjust their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like Amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let Google do the
heavy lifting why not let Google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows Google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on Google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to Facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on Facebook versus
Google you have multiple multiple sizes
that you can choose from in terms of
running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on Google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for Uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so Google owns YouTube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on YouTube so they could
be Standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say a pre-roll meaning people are going
to look at your ad before actually
watching the actual video they went to
YouTube for so you have a lot of
different options with video
advertisements on YouTube so the other
AD format you have on Google are
shopping ads and shopping ads are really
a great way to get your product in front
of the right user so somebody's looking
for shoes or running shoes it's an
opportunity for you to run shopping ads
so you could put that particular shoe
with a description with the price with
your brand name in front of that user
and so with a cost per click model if a
user clicks on your shopping ad then
chances are they're probably going to
convert because they could see the
product they could see the price they
could see the product name they could
see the brand and so it's an opportunity
for you to really drive high quality
traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if I go to Google Search and I
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here I could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names I could see the
price point if I hover over it I can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews return
policy so so if I actually click on this
ad chances are I'm going to buy it
otherwise why would I click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on Google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on Google search by certainly really
giving Google access to your product
inventory connecting in some reviews
connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up Google shopping ads within Google
search and the great thing about about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if I'm on Google search you know I can
go to shopping or I can go to images and
I'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and I will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on Google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with Google
okay you also have call ADS so when we
say call ADS really call only ads are
great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on Google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and Google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion in for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the ad because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so Google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
Google showing your ads I showed you an
example of Google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
Google search networks so Google search
Network really allows you to advertise
on Google search so with Google search
if I go back to Google search and I go
to all I typed in running shoes okay
here I can see shopping ads here I can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show up the top and and if you're
not at the top then Google will place
you at the bottom so it really depends
on the keyword that somebody's querying
in Google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what Google does if I didn't have any
shopping ads here Google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on Google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and I would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember Google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on Google with a text
ad you want to make sure you're always
at the top so let's have a look at the
different types of search networks that
Google ads is affiliated with so the
first is Google search Okay so let's
focus on Google Search and so basically
when we say Google search or search
sites we really mean google.com or all
Google search engines for that matter so
if you want to advertise to a mass
audience you want to probably start with
google.com because again millions of
people use it on a daily basis and so if
you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a Google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device Oswald so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
Google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above some featured Snippets and
the organic search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again I've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if I scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again I can see the
logo add here okay so I can see simply
learn using three headlines I can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and I can see simply learn
using some other extent tensions with
the ad now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
Google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on Google search if you're
on Google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if I change my search query and
typed in coffee in San Francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different I'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to Google my business not Google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on Google search so Google my business
is tied to local listings or Google Maps
and again and with desktop which is what
I'm showing you the search result on
you're going to see likely Google local
listings above organic results okay and
if I go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing I'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to Trump any other type of
results on Google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called Google search Partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in Google ads you have the
option to choose Google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
Google search partner sites and so some
of their search Partners can range so
basically these are sites that that have
partnered up with Google that's allowing
Google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between YouTube
to Amazon to New York Times let's take a
look at an example it could even be
another search engine so if I go to say
ask.com and type in classes on digital
marketing it's a completely different
search engine but I can see the same ad
for simply learn so I can see same I
could see a different headline here
actually but I can see the description
and I can see some site link extensions
and so notice the ad is still at the top
in this case it's in position one and I
can see multiple companies running
advertisements why because I could see
ad next to it and I could see those over
over organic listings so these are
Google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that Google or other sites that Google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of Google search and
that option is Display Network so
Display Network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of Google
search and if you're going to advertise
on Google's Display Network you have
more ad formats Available to You
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the newyorktimes.com or
WebMD or marriott.com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell Google hey this is the site I want
to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the Display
Network so if you don't want to
advertise on Google search Okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the form
I'm out of the ad okay so put in your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on Google's
Display Network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because the display the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so retargeting as
we said earlier is really reaching out
to people who have already been to your
website and didn't perform a particular
function that you want wanted them to
perform meaning somebody came to your
website from Paid search on google.com
and they went to page a and then they
left so you really wanted them to go to
page B add a product to a shopping cart
and check out and purchase that product
however if they didn't do that you could
certainly run ads knowing that they've
been to page a and Page B and you can
offer up that specific ad to that person
who's been to your website and so that's
what retargeting really is all about and
you can retarget on Google's Display
Network so remarketing your product to
people who previously visited your your
website or even your app allows you to
really get your ad in front of a
qualified audience and so you could take
advantage of analytics so Google's ads
has all the information you need so
let's actually take a look at some of
these options in Google ads for the
Display Network so if I actually go to
Google ads and I actually go to display
campaigns I can see I have a lot of
different options available to me so if
I click on keywords for example okay I
can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what Google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
Display Network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
Google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the Display Network
you can say hey Google I only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and So based on that
Google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the Display
Network you can also choose choose
topics so if there's a specific topic
that you want your ad to be associated
with you can certainly do that so Google
has a number of different topics at
their disposal so here if I just choose
a particular ad group now I have
specific topics that I can choose from
arts and entertainment food and drink to
news to pets and animals and so under
each one of these topics I can get
really specific so if I go under science
I could see subcategories under the
topic science I can see chemistry and
physics and scientific institutions and
equipment so I can really pick and
choose specific topics where I want my
ads to be shown as I mentioned already
you can pick and choose specific
placements okay so if you have a
specific website that you want your ad
to be shown on you can certainly let
Google know okay you can also advertise
on Gmail you can also advertise on
YouTube so you can really pick and share
choose where you want your ads to be
shown so you have all these different
options available to you to me that one
of the best options for advertising on
the Display Network because when you
tell Google you have a specific audience
you want to Target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
re-target them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with Google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with Google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in Google ads so when I actually pick
and choose how I want to Target I can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or or demographics for example
if I go back to demographics I have all
this data uh that Google's collected on
my advertising so I can see for example
by age range based on my campaign how
many clicks how many Impressions
Impressions or how many times my ads
been seen click-through rate meaning the
rate at which people see my ad and are
clicking on my ad how much I'm paying
per click CPC is cost per click total
cost and conversions how many
conversions am I getting so I could see
all this data available to me in Google
ads so it's a very powerful platform for
measuring performance imagine it's the
year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing a form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing cotfield's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertises
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about this
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phil started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing
since he was already familiar with the
concept of social media marketing his
next step was to learn about the
different types of content he could post
on social media some of the most common
forms of content that bill could post
would be images text posts polls and
videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads these
ads could advertise posts or excerpts
from Phil's blog or his book further
garnering interest from an interesting
audience
you could also use video ads Phil could
use video ads that feature favorable
reviews and customer testimonials to
advertisers books Phil could also use
lead ads through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with them create
an identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos but how
did Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing Phil taken up simply learns
digital marketing course it was thanks
to this course that Phil had the skills
and training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today I mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called The Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising in those Yellow Pages
then you have Billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise via FX just a
few decades ago so these were all the
ways in which people had to get their
product and service out there it seems
like so archaic looking at it now but
back then that was legitimate that was
the way to do it and then one thing made
our lives a lot easier so if you're a
marketer you're thinking to yourself man
I'm glad I'm a marketer in today's day
and age because it's social media
marketing social media marketing has
made everyone's lives better from the
company that's selling the product or
service to the marketer promoting the
product and service to the end user who
wants to see that product or service and
engage with that product service so
social media is a good source of getting
your product and service out there and
it just makes everybody's lives a heck
of a lot easier so we're going to answer
that million dollar question and what's
that million dollar question it's how
can you Rise Above the Rest and so
today's session is going to be how to
start with social media marketing so you
can Rise Above the Rest leveraging this
great platform that we all take
advantage of today so let's start by
asking the question what is social media
marketing social media marketing
involves increasing website traffic it
centers around engagement it offers you
the ability to increase your brand
awareness and it has other marketing
goals you know so you can create various
forms of content for different social
media platforms so that's really in a
nutshell with social media marketing is
so again if we want to increase our
traffic or we want to increase our
engagement like likes or comments then
look no further than social media
marketing if we want to engage with our
users our customers our potential and
prospective customers we can really put
a personalized experience in place using
social media marketing we want to create
different forms of content like videos
and blogs and infographics and other
types of graphics with the potential to
actually go viral what we mean by viral
is spreading like wildfire one user
sending it to another as rapidly as can
be and before you know it you get you
know millions of views and millions of
likes I mean that's the power of social
media marketing so why do we want to do
social media marketing and I think we
just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to really build our brand
awareness and that is no more truthful
well then with social media marketing
more so than any other digital marketing
channel social media marketing allows us
to really put our brand in a good light
in a good position in front of the right
eyeballs so it allows us to really
improve our brand by pushing out the
appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into customers who then turn into
loyal customers who then turn into
lifetime customers we could see at every
step in the process that our conversion
rates may increase we can certainly
leverage social media marketing for SEO
for search engine rankings it's about
off-page SEO it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there there is
some inherent benefits to working SEO
and social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on Twitter or Facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say Google or Bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
Brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from senior
brand for the first time to getting to
know your brand a little bit more to
maybe buying a product or service from
your brand then returning to buy another
product instead service and then
continuing to buy that product or
service I mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing today we are
going to talk about all the different
ads that Facebook has to offer so
introduced back in 2007 the Facebook ads
platform has grown tremendously over the
last few years almost four billion
dollars of Revenue in one year so what
does that mean that means there's a lot
of advertisers why is there a lot of
advertisers because a lot of people use
Facebook it's a popular platform so not
only is it popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on Facebook book you have
the opportunity to share your product
and your brand with users who you think
are going to buy your product or
associate with your brand and on
Facebook you can do that a number of
different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's new feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so I
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spent a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics specific
location so you're really really putting
your product out in front of the right
people at the right time and so the
other positive and pro about Facebook is
it's lesser spend greater reach and what
do we mean by that well traditionally
Facebook is a little bit cheaper than
other online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility already if friends
and family members of a person on
Facebook are associated with your brand
so it has the opportunity to really lend
a lot of credence to somebody who is on
Facebook active on Facebook and is your
targeted demographic and the great thing
about Facebook is it also has other
features other advertising features such
as retargeting so you could Target
people who've already expressed an
interest in your service or product but
if they didn't go through the conversion
process meaning they didn't go all the
way through and and buy your product you
can certainly reach out to them again
just like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform allows
us to do that so it's a great feature
that we could take advantage of that
will talk about more throughout this
session and then it helped helps
increase Revenue sales and leads and and
that's primarily what most advertisers
are after you know more Revenue more
sales more leads so Facebook allows us
to educate our audience again a target
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back to the other
feature higher Revenue less spend this
is the primary reason because you have a
chance to influence somebody who's very
targeted who's very active on the
platform and who may have like-minded
people in their life associating with
your brand and product so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
Facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad or just sing single
image advertisements that have an
optional text on top and a link
description that links to the website so
single image ads are probably the most
popular you can see them on probably
your own Facebook feed if you look so in
fact I'll just jump over to my Facebook
feed right now and if I go there what do
I see I see a single image ad here and
it's from Shopify Partners so become a
Shopify partner at eCommerce to your
list of qualifications so Shopify must
be you know a brand that is trying to
woo my business okay so they know that
somebody that I'm associated with or
maybe I fit their demographic so they're
targeting my newsfeed with a single
image ad so that's what a single image
ad looks like it's simply just one
single image with some description and
the great thing about this single image
if you ever noticed is the pixels are
pretty large it's 1200 by 628 so it kind
of stands out a little bit it's not your
traditional thumbnail it really pops
when you look at the news feed so again
if I go back to my news feed here you
can see it just really stands out within
the news feed so I can't miss it if I'm
a targeted part of their targeted
audience it's hard for me to you know
not see the sad interact in some way
especially again if I know somebody in
my network on Facebook or either that be
a friend or family members associated
with that product okay in addition to
the single image ads Facebook also has
multi-product ads or also known as
Carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you and in Carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different call
to action and so here you can see simply
learn has a example of a carousel ad
where they're showcasing their different
courses so this allows users to view to
a range of all your different products
and services if you have multiple
products and services to offer then the
carousel ads would be a good option for
you so in addition to the Carousel ads
and single image ads it gets a little
bit more sophisticated in terms of
Technology where Facebook allows us to
offer up video ads and so video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put a lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an Advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there and not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your Carousel ad so Facebook also
allows us to advertise something called
lead ads and what lead ads allow us to
do is obtain user details okay so we can
acquire or get an email address or phone
number from somebody whose interest in
our product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave Facebook so
if you look here on the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead at is
that it can sync up with any CRM or most
of your popular serums I should say for
example Salesforce as a good example of
a CRM where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
Facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or Services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
call to action just like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing you know their
different classes is and then they have
the get started today call to action to
really punctuate the slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook is called The
Collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so if you're an
Advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option for you the collection
ad so here you can see the simply learn
example here they're showing you know
not only you know some some good
slideshows and imagery with some good
messaging below that
Instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users Instagram is
a platform drive with marketing
potential
more than 7 billion dollars Revenue has
been generated from Instagram mobile and
it's home to more than two million
advertisers
not only that marketing on Instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one-third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to Instagram's
parent company Facebook Instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by Facebook ads with
this you can advertise to People based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on Instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
bio should also include a URL to where
you want to drive traffic to be it your
Brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how Samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services Samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
Content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
Content calendar
a Content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active a calendar helps you
decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes like on what day date or
time a consistent post schedule will
enable you to make the most out of
Instagram it'll also keep your audience
engaged and also give you access to
historical posts if you want to repost
your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you will need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
Facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more you also have a variety
of AD formats to choose from like story
ads image ads video ads collection ads
and more
moreover they can also be set up from
Facebook ads manager
here's an example from an ad from body
shop in which they are using a single
image ad the advertising works because
of its interesting creative and
attractive ad copy that attracts the
customer to interact with the post and
click on the link let's go to number
four have a visually consistent feed
Instagram is a platform in which people
gravitate towards aesthetically pleasing
content
two authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your Brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted Earthly tones
with a low key editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and
are somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can Captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them this makes it more likely that
they feel closer to your brand and buy
your products your captions can tell
stories that can help your brand appear
more human and build deeper connections
with your audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face here's an example of
how the page Patagonia talks about
forests in America each of their posts
tells stories about a different tissue
that affects nature their brand on
Instagram revolves around bringing
awareness to such issues that's the kind
of stories you should tell with your
brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your post showing up
on the Explorer tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in the sea of
content
your hashtag shouldn't be too generic
like hash New Year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven take
advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also buy them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to converge followers into
Advocates of your brand
here's an example of how Starbucks uses
user generated content and takes
advantages of Their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed and products stalled at
Starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
Branch loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads
most instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising we do
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads single video
ads that can create 60 second ads
carousels are a combination of images
and videos and Instagram stories that
enable you to combine images and videos
to create visually attractive ads
here's an example of the brand Pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions now
for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and Authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how Ralph Lauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest Ralph Lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways contests enable your audience
to engage with your brand with 3.5 times
more likes and 64 times the comments you
can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned Brands need to be partnered with
Contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well here's an
example of a contest run by Domino's
Pizza which encourages people to
contribute their own short stories and
connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic adding links to the Instagram
stories can also help with driving
traffic to your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile-friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews
another new tool they have introduced is
Instagram reels Instagram's answer to
tick tock Instagram released reels
through which users would be able to
upload 15 second clips and since it
released very recently it's a Rife with
marketing potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
Styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
Instagram engagement so let's talk about
how to create a YouTube ad so this is
going to require some access to Google
ads and we'll go over that in a few
minutes here but first we need to think
about setting up a campaign and setting
up a campaign goal okay what's the goal
of our campaign so we get eyeballs you
know we want to pay costs for 1000
Impressions or we want to run some
actionable type ads to get people over
to our website so that really is step
one we need to identify what the goal of
our campaign is then we need to create
the ad so we want to be able to create a
video ad here that is going to show on
YouTube and to our target audience so or
whether it be a bumper ad that's only
going to be 6 seconds long we need to be
able to figure out what type of AD we
want to run so here I am in Google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
YouTube we need to make sure that we're
choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select brand
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video basically what we're
doing is we're going to tell Google we
want to go ahead and set up some video
ads on YouTube and so here you can see
the different types of video ad as we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our outstream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to you know move forward
with selecting our ad so you can see
here after I set up my campaign now I'm
just going to go through some of the
settings for my ad and I'm going to give
it a campaign name a budget okay when it
starts or ends the bidding strategy so
again we're going to focus on cost per
1000 Impressions and then here's the
network so this is an important
selection here so we're dealing with
YouTube videos so we also have the
option to select video Partners on the
Display Network so that means that if
you want your video to show on websites
that want to host ads in video format
then you can select this option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on YouTube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so I'm going
to stick with the video Partners okay
YouTube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what Google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're going to have an ad group
so when you create a campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less a video in every ad group we have
but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're going to go ahead and set
up you know this ad group here and
here's where it gets interesting and
important because here is where we can
start targeting our audience so here we
got demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
YouTube videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our Target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember we're
in this example we're going to Bumper
ads and we're looking at about six
seconds and once we do that then that's
pretty much the campaign but I just want
to stress here that when you're setting
it up ahead of time you want to make
sure you identify what the campaign goal
is and then that's going to align with
the type of video you're going to run
and then once you choose that type of
video then it just comes down to where
you want that ad to be and who you're
targeting so it's really crucial here
that you go through these steps and
these options very closely so because
you want your video to show in front of
the Right audience on the right place
now so let's talk about how you can
optimize your YouTube ads so once you
get your campaign set up once you select
your Channel or the type of videos where
you want your ad to be and you select
your target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing Those
ads and so going back to what I was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully Define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up a campaign remember you have
that option to choose the type of goal
for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask Google to place our video ads
anywhere they want then it's up to us
then to go through and choose the ad
placements and remove them okay so let
me show you an example of what that
means so if I'm back in Google I'm going
to go to my campaign and I'm going to
select placements and here I can see
placements but then I'm going to select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign interactor so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
your placements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get sales or leads if you're
that placement is not converting sales
or leads then you need to remove or
exclude that placement so it's all done
within the Google ads platform and then
you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting special classify who gets to
see your ad and who doesn't Okay so that
goes back to your settings so you can
pick and choose who your target audience
is you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ads all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive okay you can always perform
a b testing on your ads so if you have
one ad version you can create another
one just to see what it which one
performs better testing is always a
positive okay so if you're paying too
much maybe think about reducing your
bids so if you remember we said a 10 CPM
bid that may be too much maybe we don't
need to pay ten dollars so we can always
reduce our bids at the ad group level so
reduce bids in areas where you see lower
performance so in other words you don't
want to pay a lot for poor performance
you can also use remarketing to
re-engage age with customers so if
somebody views your ads and doesn't take
action you can always retarget that
person uh to show your ad another even
another ad format it could be text ads
or display ads but if somebody looked at
your video and they didn't take the
action you preferred them to take then
you can always retarget them with
another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that really you
want to make sure that your ad is you
know is with the end viewer you don't
want to put out an ad that isn't going
to give somebody you know a good feeling
after they watched it okay so you want
to make sure viewers find the content
relevant so if they don't find it
relevant then that means your engagement
rate and your engagement is probably
going to be low so you want to take a
look at those metrics that we viewed
earlier engagement rate engagement and
if they're low then you probably need to
look at the content of the ad so try to
make sure your ad conveys your Brand's
message in the first six seconds so
that's why bumper ads to me are so
critical because you got to get the
entirety of the ad and make it impactful
and so with any AD you run any video ad
you're on you really want to make sure
that that message is conveyed at the
very beginning early as possible
otherwise you know people are going to
be turned off or not engaged and just
going to go ahead and skip it anyway so
you want to make sure you get the
purpose of it right up front and out of
the way okay you can also include Visual
and auditory components in your ad that
can make it more memorable to the
viewers okay meaning music or other cool
visuals okay so again you want to be
able to play around and test different
ads and you want to be able to you know
measure the ad Performance Based on the
metrics we discussed I mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when I say good quality I mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting or so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a B testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry so they're a good success
story on YouTube so super Drive leaned
on some YouTube advertising to help lift
one of their products so in September
last year 2018 super dry if you're not
familiar with the brand they're you know
centered some Asian markets European
markets and they focus in on clothing
all different styles and sizes and
genders from jackets to jeans to
t-shirts and so they're a global brand
they really wanted to take a different
approach here and their approach was
they wanted to focus in on sales they
wanted to see if video can help lift
them with sales and so what they've done
is they set up some campaigns on YouTube
and their focus here was on jackets and
jackets to specific ages across the
board all genders and interests and so
what they did was they wanted to Once
take advantage of all the different ad
types that YouTube had to offer and
let's take a look at one of those ads
here so if we go to YouTube and let's
just take a look at this one minute ad
here 53 second ad by super dry
um
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raising the jacket you'll
I washed the jacket
it's a jacket you're hiding you're
vibing love live and praises
this is the jacket
a jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that's super dry ran
you could see that you know it was it
had some particular goals there and so
super dry is pretty well known so
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on superdry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
Target Their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender some
younger people is who they were
targeting so younger people tend to
slant on YouTube and so they were able
to get some nice views out of it 4.8
million but the more important thing is
because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a hundred and thirty eight percent
increase in brand lip I mean the jacket
ad so it was a pretty successful
campaign see as well choreographed good
audio good video just well
professionally done and they probably
were able to now get a few more loyal
customers under their belt because of
this at alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and Target them with a cool video and
given that YouTube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
those true view in stream ads with a
cost per view through a skippable video
ad format may they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on YouTube so they took advantage
of all YouTube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to Target the
length of the ad and given that their
product or selling a product or
promoting a product they will take
advantage of the trueview shoppable ad
format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again a based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats
today we're going to talk about how to
increase Instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
and best practices is for you to take
advantage of to increase Instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about Instagram so
Instagram is not really an up and coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active Instagram users 500 million daily
May the user base growth of more than
300 year over year so it's growing and
growing and growing it's become more and
more popular ever since it's launched
back in 2010 and then there's more than
100 million photos uploaded daily so
it's a platform where you can upload
photos tag those photos even use and
Implement videos and photos have become
very popular with the Advent of mobile
technology that the Instagram app makes
it easy for you to post your photo so
there's no surprise there's a growth
there's no surprise there's a lot of
users there's no surprise that there's
100 in photos plus uploaded daily and
then there are 400 million stories
posted daily so when you post something
you can create a story out of it and
there's 400 million of those per day and
then there's more than 50 billion photos
shared to date so since 2010 platform
Nat which is now owned by Facebook has
become really really popular a good
place for you if you have your own
company if you have your own brand if
you have your own product it's a good
place for you to really showcase that
service that product that brand because
of the user base how easy it is to use
and the wide reach it has for you in
which to tell your story so imagine
there are lots of photos shared today
close to seven billion dollars revenue
generated through Instagram mobile so on
top of everything I just said there's a
lot of e-commerce going on here too so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers a
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
on Instagram so Instagram is an
e-commerce platform to say the least in
fact Instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
going to go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram accounts for
example using my desktop I could see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not going to
follow you so this is where it all
starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are going to
look at and they're going to decide
whether to follow you or not based on
primarily that bio that's where it all
starts so make sure you have a good bio
that's tip number one so you'll have to
make sure that your landing page is also
mobile optimized since most Instagram
users are on mobile so if you're going
to put a link to your website and
somebody's on the Instagram app and they
see your bio and they like it and you
have a link to your website make sure
that Lanny pays they go to is mobile
optimized so tip number two everything
you do on Instagram when it comes to
posting evolves around hashtags so
that's the backbone of the platform just
like most platforms out there social
media platforms like Twitter or Facebook
Pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so Instagram's
note different but in this case you
really really want to take advantage of
the hashtag so hashtags are there to
help users find your content so you want
to start out by using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
or be in searched on Instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on Instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your Hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the hashtag and the content 10
is relevancy so using the popular tags
on your photos or videos might get you
some immediate engagement but it may not
help with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested fars and sales
so here really what I'm trying to say is
look pick and choose your hashtags
carefully because if you use something
broad or something non-relevant yeah you
may get that click to your Instagram
page but that doesn't necessarily mean
somebody's going to follow you or that
doesn't really mean somebody's going to
be interested in what you have to offer
so if you use something really popular
and Broad yes you're going to get
short-term gratification but not
long-term interest tip number three post
your content at the right time so
according to sprout social which is a
social media scheduling platform among
other things so they deal with a lot of
people using their platform and posting
content via their platform they have
data and they're telling us based on the
data they've collected that the best
time to process between 2 and 3 P.M and
the best data post is Thursday now that
may be all fine and true according to a
sprout social study and so you may want
to go with this 2 to 3 P.M and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone you're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try two to three p.m on
Thursday the thing is what you're gonna
have to do eventually is figure out what
the best time to post is okay so if
you're putting out a lot of content and
you're putting out content throughout
the week at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're going to really have to
lean on a social media platform to help
you determine that because they're going
to have the data that you need to
determine what the best time of day to
post is okay so we'll talk about social
many platforms here shortly we just know
that when you post post with some
rationale in mind ask yourself before
you even push that publish button or
before you even schedule that post this
time of day in this day of the week
makes sense so you always want to post
at the right time because you could be
missing your audience so remember when
you do this you're going to be working
with some platform and Instagram also
has some analytics for business accounts
so Instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more you engage with people
people the more you stand to gain from
them so you could see who your
competitors followers are and you can
add them as a follower just by following
them so start engaging with them if
they're liking your competitor's brand
then what the chance of them like in
your brand could be great so check out
who your competitors followers are if
they seem like somebody who you would
want to be following your brand then go
ahead and interact with them and how you
interact is again you can like something
that they post or you can comment on
something that they posted and engage
with them okay it doesn't take that much
time it's a good way to gain followers
so if we're on Instagram we can simply
just click on the Brand's followers so
here I can see the Sprint has 127
followers and here I can see all the
followers and what I could do is simply
just click on one of the followers and I
can go to their profile and from there I
could see what they've posted in terms
of videos and images and I can like or
comment so just doing something as
simple as this gets you an opportunity
to engage with somebody who can then
turn around and follow you so tip five
pay for sponsored posts and product
reviews so a number of ways you could do
this here so pay for a sponsored post so
you can find an influer who satisfies a
couple of requirements they have large
following and an email address in the
profile so you can connect with them and
ask them for sponsored post pricing so
it's as simple as that as reaching out
to somebody who has a large following
okay so if you do this then it's going
to put shoe in front of a large number
of people and so by doing this it'll
help expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location City or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your text so if somebody's in that
location the chances of them engaging
are going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you so tip 7 use
Instagram stories to track followers and
grow your user base So Stories a really
big feature on Instagram so what stories
could be used for is just show footage
of an environment so it could be your
office it could be your home it could be
you know the playground it could be the
golf course it could be anywhere that
you want to show vintage of so you want
to post new relevant to your industry so
if you're in the food industry hey why
not go in the back into the kitchen and
post a story about how a particular
bread or cake is made okay show off your
products so if you are in that food
industry and say you're in the pizza
making business perfect opportunity to
show people via an Instagram Story how
to make that pizza and how you make that
pizza what ingredients you use how
unique is your particular product and
that's really what you want to get
across when you do a story you want to
show something unique and relevant
that's going to grasp people's attention
you can promote a company event so if
you're celebrating say 200 000
subscribers create a YouTube video or
you can create an Instagram story it
works just as well so you can endorse
your company's blog posts you can post
positive user reviews so these are all
features of a story increased
interactivity with polls sliders Etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have when creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
Instagram story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comment section
below so we want to get everybody
involved here because there's a
thousands upon thousands of great
Instagram stories out there to be shown
and viewed and engaged with so go ahead
and share your Instagram story if you
have any other tips or tricks then go
ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back of your
mind you know for me I always go back to
what industry are you in if you're in
the food industry hey you know people
who are following you are interested in
food if you're a pizza company you know
show off that pizza if you're a bakery
show off how you make your Breads and
goods baked goods whatever it is you
have show it off because if somebody's
following you that's what they're
interested in so tip number eight
highlight important stories so you want
to highlight highlights serve as the
easiest way to create a first impression
for a potential follower so with
highlights can be used to tease what
your content's about create a trailer
for what your brand offers promote and
promote your product so highlights are
there it's a good feature it's a first
impression for potential follower so it
teases what the content's about it
creates a trailer so to speak for your
brand and promote your product so use
highlights and again any users out there
who have good examples of highlights go
ahead and put those in the content
section or comment section uh right
below this video so remember stories
have only a 24-hour lifespan so
highlights can be used to give them a
second wind okay so highlights serve a
purpose it teases what the content's
about it promotes the product and it
really kind of accentuates that story
tip number nine ask for followers so
sometimes people need a little push
before they can follow you on Instagram
even if they enjoy your content so you
can ask users to become your followers
in the caption the comment section even
work it into your content so in other
words when you're posting something
don't be afraid to say hey follow me you
know I got some good stuff here be
confident you don't want to do it for
every post of course but you know pick
and choose if you feel you have a really
good post you know really good image
that you think is going to gain a lot of
followers and engagers then you don't
necessarily need to put a caption in
there but if if it is popular then go
ahead and say hey this is a popular post
you know think about following me or put
something in the comment section you
want to do it kind of succinctly you
don't want to be begging but just
working into some degree okay but don't
be afraid have some confidence in asking
for followers so when you do this it's
very similar How We Do It on YouTube so
you can ask viewers to subscribe to
their channels at the end of the video
so it's if on YouTube basically you're
saying hey if you like what we have go
ahead and subscribe it's no different on
Instagram if you have something you've
posted just go and said hey you like
this you know go ahead and follow us so
that's simple so tip number 10 take on
the latest trends to get more followers
so align your content to cater to trendy
topics or hashtags to improve engagement
and discover ability so really what
we're trying to say here's your
competitors follow influencers what are
the latest trends and you can get an
idea of the latest trends by you looking
at hashtags so what hashtags are
trending which ones are people using the
most so really what you want to do is
whatever's trending in your industry you
know ride that wave so to speak now it
doesn't have to take on your entire
profile but there's nothing wrong with
one or two posts if something's really
taking on popularity then go ahead and
post about it as well you know for
example in the wine industry if there's
a new wine that really came out that's
really gaining some popularity go ahead
and post about it with the same hashtag
and with the unique hashtag so don't be
afraid to you know ride the wave of
popularity so to speak because it shows
that you know you know what you're
talking about it adds some credibility
and it's going to get some you know
viewers over to your Instagram profile
so keep in mind you need to keep your
content relevant because if you're your
audience is interested in what you have
to offer then they're going to be
engaged however you know if you're
joining the discussion in a relevant
manner keeping in mind whether your
audience will interact or not is
important but just always keep in mind
you always want to stay within your
industry and relevancy for your target
audience so tip number 11 run contests
and giveaways and so just like on
YouTube just like on Facebook I mean
Instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
it's an idea of a contest well again if
you're running a pizza parlor you know
you could say hey what's your favorite
pizza or give me your favorite pizza
ideas and you can run a contest and you
know you can have people even create
their own pizza and post an image of it
you can have people create stories on
the best ways in which they create Pizza
or their experience in another pizza
parlor there's lots of things you can do
to create a contest and you don't always
have to give something away you could
just do something for fun especially if
you have a lot of followers if you have
a lot of followers and somebody's going
to take part in it so don't be afraid to
run contests just to make it fun and
light it up a little bit so each tag can
bring you a new audience member who
could be a potential follower so anytime
you run a contest people are gonna tag
their friends to let them know about
that contest so those friends are gonna
come over and likely engage so that's
the beauty of running a contest or
giveaway is chances are words gonna
spread and it's going to get you some
new followers so that's the the end
benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with posts so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consist it you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within Pizza you could Branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complimentary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we wanted
to stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of Instagram content
so than me what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's going to muddy
the water supposed so to speak and
you're probably going to get less
engagement so set a theme on Instagram
by maintaining consistency in your
personality filters colors and layouts
and really what I'm referring to is post
and when you have post something you're
really creating a personality for
yourself okay so if you're in fashion
for example and you're in the jeans
industry well jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but you know when you start talking
about dresses and shoes and and that
kind of blurs your your personality a
bit so if you stay consistent within
jeans and outfits that go with jeans
then I think people are going to start
to pick up on that personality so tip 13
keep track of your Instagram following
so you can analyze the growth of your
Channel with tools like socialblade I
could tell you how many followers you
lost over time and how engaged they are
okay so you can use data gather from
here and from Instagram business account
to diagnose where you're faltering so
let's take a look at socialblade as an
example here so if I go over here I'm
gonna go to socialblade here I can enter
in basically any account after I
register and I could see how that
account has performed you know where
they rank you know how many uploads they
have what country they focused on one
industry and the beauty here is I could
see and I'm looking at YouTube as an
example I could see you know how my post
to perform well you could do this for
Instagram you could do it for Facebook
so you can really get an idea of how
your account's performing so socialblade
is a great platform for measuring and
again you do also have Instagram
business insights so with Instagram
business insights basically what you're
going to do is you're going to go to
your app right and then from the app you
could basically look at your insights
from there so in the app itself you're
going to click on the upper right three
lines and from there you're gonna see
insights and when you go to insights
you're also going to see you know what
your reach is how many Impressions and
some engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the Instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns and post what post
receive the most amount of Engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replicate it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mentioned this on other webinars for
Facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if I go back into say
Facebook ads manager I can pick and
choose my placements and really what I
want to do is pick and choose for
example Instagram and so I have
Instagram feed I have insta Instagram
stories so and I could see what the
video requirement or the media
requirement is for running on Instagram
so with Instagram you can run stories
you can run videos single image ads you
can run Carousel so really you could put
your best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're going to run this through
Facebook ads manager and it's going to
tell you you know what your audience
size is your potential reach okay what
your daily results would be so you're
going to get all that information when
you run your ads on Facebook ads manager
but it's a great opportunity for you to
really push forward if you're running a
promotion it's really an opportunity for
you to push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the Facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting you know you
need meaning you know who saw the ad ad
do they click on it okay you can refine
that target audience you can go back
into Facebook ads manager and refine who
your audience is so lots of flexibility
here on advertising on Instagram but the
key here is if you want to run
advertising on Instagram you know think
about what it is you're trying to
promote if you feel something needs to
get promoted then go ahead and you know
you can either again reach out to
somebody and have them sponsor it or you
can run it as an advertisement so let's
move on to tip 15. so we want to create
visually attractive and eye-catching ads
so if you are going to run ads you know
here's some things to keep in mind okay
you want to use images that are natural
and seem native okay you don't want to
use any stock photography first off you
want to use something that you've done
okay you want to minimize the amount of
text so let the image do the talking you
want to ensure your caption relates to
the image and resonates with your
audience okay so you have an opportunity
to add some text below the image okay so
make sure sure it resonates and then of
course use hashtags to show your ads to
Target your audience but a wider
relevant audience so hashtags do play a
role here as well so these are some tips
if you're going to create ads you want
to take these into account the whole
point of the ad is to get people over to
either web page or to your profile page
okay so that they can engage and take
action so Instagram ads will help
showcase your product service or brand
in a way that's memorable and unique so
if you really want to get your vision
your brand your product out there in
front of a lot of people then
advertising on Instagram is a good way
to do that so since we've been talking
about pizza throughout this webinar this
is a good Instagram a profile here about
pizza you know I'm getting hungry just
looking at this hopefully this is an
example for all veg and non-veg pizza
consumers I mean you can see this
profile here they got the website you
know they got the handle oh okay so they
have a lot of followers so you know if
I'm in the pizza industry I can go ahead
and you know click on their followers
and see who who's following them who
they're following so some really good
shots of pizza here it looks like you
know a lot of people are wearing were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples here some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage Instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so here you know you could
say use daily Pizza as a hashtag for
feature okay so they're even encouraging
you to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here on Instagram this
is just a good example of what you can
do and have fun with you know with an
example like pizza just to give you some
ideas so let's move on to tip 16 take
advantage of Instagram tools so you can
use scheduling tools like later
HootSuite and buffer so I can't stress
this enough you know when it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
Instagram posts you're definitely going
to need a social media tool so you're
also going to need it if you do a lot of
you know posting on Instagram so let's
take a look at an example we'll use
later.com so if I go to later here I can
see you know I can use this to upload my
images to my profile so here you can see
it's scheduled throughout the day of the
week so that way we're not overlapping
you know we're scheduling based on the
times of the day that people are going
to look at this so you know here I could
see you know particular stories if any
stories are posted okay I can look at it
from a weekly or monthly preview I could
see what's been posted is dead okay and
more importantly as a schedule tool I
can also see the analytics I could see
you know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing I want to be able to see what
post perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by
location so again I can look at it by
post-performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags did this become particular
company is using on Instagram so here
you can see how many posts with this
hashtag you know and what and kind of
Engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments Impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job I like this
platform especially for Instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition into the Instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how a
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from Best Practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not working then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown in here and later.com
so remember these tools place an
emphasis on automation okay enabling you
to automatically post at a scheduled
time so you want to lock it in at a
certain period of time and not have to
worry about it so it allows you to
really hone in on that particular time
of the day and day of the week so that
you're really maximizing your chances of
getting good engagement it's develop
your own signature style so set up a
style and content theme so that you're
able to stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just
coming back to our pizza example Lots
again had photos of pizza you know but
this is their style this is who they are
you know they're not a particular brand
they're just you know people who like
pizza okay and they're having fun with
it okay so that's their style you know
they're probably staying really good
shots of all this different types of
pizza different styles different
toppings and just to give you an idea of
how popular pizza is and what you can do
with it okay so yeah and this is a good
basic example
um of what you can do with something as
simple as pizza so don't be afraid to
experiment you know try something
different with your profile you know do
something different you don't always
have to follow what everybody else is
doing that's the great thing about
Instagram it allows you to be free and
creative in fact if anybody has any
styles that have worked for them you
know feel free to put something in the
comment section we'd love to hear your
thoughts so tip 18 use user engagement
to your advantage so I just mentioned
that using the later example so we want
to be able to learn from what it's
working and not working so user
generated content shows off your brand
to be authentic and improves your
relationship with your followers so you
know you want to be unique with the
content that you're posting so if you do
that you're likely to build that
relationship and you know increase your
followers and you want to be able to see
of that user generated content that ugc
which is performing which is not
performing okay so basically your
followers and your audience are telling
you what's working and not working so
take advantage of that remember going
back to hashtags you can set up your own
unique hashtag and ask your users to
post images or videos relating to that
which you can post in your Brand's
account so just like the whole pizza
thing they're saying hey look you know
use daily pizza for a feature okay
that's a good example of something you
can do as well so you could set up a
unique hashtag and say hey use this
hashtag and that'll help you gain some
followers that'll help you gain some
notoriety gain some visibility on your
platform tip 19 use high quality images
and videos just like on YouTube just
like on Facebook Instagram's no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original I mean again one
more time going back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality I
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational about causing the
user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know you can make it
short make it fun okay you can see here
these guys are just showing you how
pizza's made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it can be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so worth repeating don't use stock
images on Instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's Instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side be concise high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you could do that you're likely going to
hold the user's attention so tip 20
promote your Instagram page and other
social media channels so face Facebook
and Instagram are part of the same
family so this seems like a natural but
you know don't be afraid to promote it
on other channels like Pinterest or or
YouTube The whole idea is to get users
to your Instagram page and encourage
them to follow it so you know you can
always put that URL in you know other
platforms like YouTube nothing wrong
with that at all okay you can also
promote your page offline with print ads
and during other relevant events and
then I would even take that as to
further as you probably see you know an
Instagram logo on a web page along with
other social media icons so you always
want to help promote Instagram on your
web page as well but you can do it for
offline with print ads so you can simply
just put you know whatever your your
slug is for Instagram whatever your ID
is whatever you're using on Instagram
that's what you can use don't be afraid
to promote it offline or online today
we're going to talk about how to
increase Twitter followers so welcome
and let's get started so with Twitter
it's all about tweets it's actually a
verb now uh when you do something on
Twitter you actually tweet and there are
a lot of people out there tweeting in
fact Twitter has over 1.3 billion
accounts so a lot of tweets going on in
the world of Twitter so as of the third
quarter in 2018 last year Twitter had
326 million Global monthly active users
okay so active meaning every day using
the platform on a daily basis so a lot
of people using Twitter it's very easy
to use as you'll find out and what
you're going to find out today is how to
increase followers on your Twitter
account so they can see more of your
tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information be
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does a lot
of videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better Twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on YouTube or if it's not unpublished on
YouTube use it with Twitter you're going
to get more engagement so Twitter has 75
percent of its users use the platform
for news Okay so people go to Twitter to
get their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website
content-based website they get their
news via Twitter it's just very easy to
digest because it's so few characters 75
of B2B businesses Market on Twitter so
not only is it a b to see or business to
Consumer platform it's a B2B business to
business platform so a lot of businesses
are on Twitter basically promoting
either a product service or trying to
establish themselves in the industry
using the platform so let's take a look
at Twitter and let's take a look at some
of the ways in which you can increase
your followers it all starts with your
profile you always want to make sure you
have a complete profile your name
obviously the Twitter platform that you
have is going to have a handle okay in
this example here it's a totally real
person at totally real person is the
Twitter handle and that's what you're
going to want to use to disseminate your
Twitter profile to others so you want to
make sure that you have a good image you
have a real name and a good handle that
people can associate with and remember
so you want to be able to set up this
profile with a key word friendly bio
okay a link to your website in a picture
that represents your brand always helps
so make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if I go to Twitter here if we go
to Simply learn it's Twitter account
okay their handle is simply at simply
learn okay they've customized the header
they use their logo now if you're an
individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pic here where they're
based a little bit about them so just uh
you know customize complete profile goes
a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand those are best practices in
getting that profile up and running you
don't want to use something Bland and
generic you know take the extra step
create something unique make sure your
profile file is unique you have a good
image okay make sure it's complete with
you know telling people who you are and
what you're all about that's really the
first step on really any social media
platform so you want to promote your
Twitter profile to drive users from
other social media platforms so when you
actually get that Twitter account set up
and you actually do have your handle go
ahead and share it that's the first step
in getting followers if you're already
on Facebook if you're already on
Instagram then use those platforms to
announce that you're on Twitter you can
also take that a step further and you
know send out an email to friends or
family or like I said if you're on
Facebook go ahead and set up a post say
hey guys I'm on Twitter you know come
follow me so you could also use business
cards advertisements marketing materials
and events to put that Twitter profile
on okay so it doesn't have to be within
the social media sphere it could be even
on your website it can be even in email
so you can basically promote that Pro
file again you want to make that profile
that handle easy to remember so totally
real person is the profile in this
example we're going to use that profile
everywhere we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy I can just
simply go to Twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
Twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retweet and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on Twitter so you could just simply I'm
logged in as me and if I want to retweet
something that simply learned it I can
just simply click on the retweet button
and I can add a comment if I want to and
then I'm going to retweet it's that
simple so now that tweet is going to
show up on my profile my handle and I
could simply like it if I scroll down
here okay top 10 it Trends shaping 2019
notice a simple tweet supported with an
image so I'm just going to like that so
I can even comment on it I can click on
the comment and click a reply here okay
and that's going to show up in this
tweet here just like if I click on this
I'll be able to see what other people
have written and so it's that simple if
I want I can just click on the email
button and even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is I can do everything I need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other companies similar to you
look at their tweeting and you can
always retweet that that's a good way to
get going with tweaks that's what I
started doing when I started on Twitter
in 2008 I didn't know what to write
particularly and I didn't know how to
write it particularly well so I looked
at what other people wrote and and
tweeted and just retweeted those that's
a good way to get your Twitter account
started okay so engaging with users is a
great way to get more followers so on
simply learn I retweeted one of their
tweets I liked it another one of their
tweets and it's probably going to get
their attention somebody at simply
learned is going to say okay Rob Sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be somebody who's an audience
member who likes what we have to do
likes what we have to say like what
we're tweeting let's go ahead and follow
him and so that's a good way to get
going with your Twitter account is to
really start retweeting and liking other
tweets from other users so you can find
an appropriate time to post your tweets
to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within Twitter or as I'll
mention later you can do it in a social
media platform like Sprout social or
HootSuite or later or buffer I mean
there's plenty of social media platforms
out there for you to schedule tweets
point is you want to be able to schedule
those tweets when it's the appropriate
time so you don't want to do it in the
middle of the evening because what's
going to happen is likely by the morning
other tweets are going to bury your
Tweet so you want to be able to find the
appropriate time to post your tweets so
according to a survey conducted by
HubSpot the best time to post is between
12 and 3 P.M and why is that well most
people are usually on lunch checking
their phones yes Twitter has an app in
fact most people use the app just like
on Instagram just like on YouTube the
app is very popular on Twitter so it's
very easy for somebody to check tweets
especially during the lunch hour and
then from 5 to 6 p.m that that in
between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have the maximum
amount of Engagement so during the week
when people are working highly engaged
with whatever they're doing depending on
what industry you're in they're likely
going to check the Twitter and react
during those times okay so that was a
survey conducted by Haas Papa really
what you want to do is you want to be
able to use one of these social media
platforms like a HootSuite or later and
find out exactly when are people
engaging with your tweets when I what
time of the day what day of the week are
you getting the most retweets or the
most likes okay that's what you want to
do so you can use this as a starting
point as a best practice but eventually
you're going to have to cater to your
audience based on when you're getting
your tweets engaged so you want to
increase followers by following more
people it's that simple and so it really
is that simple let me rephrase that so
it really is that simple so if I go back
to Twitter you know Twitter's always
going to recommend somebody for me to
follow and normally those are people
that are similar as myself okay so
they're not just going to choose random
people they're going to choose people
who are following people you're
following so there's going to be a
connection to some degree or they could
be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want
want to go ahead and follow people the
rule of thumb on Twitter is if you
follow somebody on Twitter chances are
they're going to follow you back you
know I was once told when I was using
Twitter that hey you want to give
somebody about three days to follow you
back so that's always what the rule I
stuck to you know wait about three days
start following people you can see here
833 people that or accounts Twitter
accounts that simply learns following
and over ten thousand nine hundred
followers to Simply learn's Twitter
account so for me I don't mind having a
nice balance myself I have just as many
followers as I do following and that's a
good thing so because you want to be
able to keep up with what people are
tweeting and so you can retweet at the
same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your Twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use Twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to Twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use Twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
Twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what Twitter is going to
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if I
click on find people I know then I can
upload my contacts from Outlook or Gmail
and they're going to find people who are
already on Twitter based on who I'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way I'm going to follow
simply learn because I wasn't following
them prior so now I just clicked on the
follow button now I am following so now
I'm going to see simply learns Tweets in
my feed so let's take a second to look
at a brand okay so it's time for a brand
watch let's have a look at some of the
best Tweets of 2018. now remember there
are a lot of active users millions of
active users that's a lot of tweets so
what we did we scoured Twitter from 2018
and we went ahead and picked out some
tweets that we thought were pretty good
and so the first one is Wendy's now I
don't know if any of you have actually
eaten at Wendy's I used to eat at
Wendy's a while ago I know their
frosties are pretty good so what they've
done is they Incorporated that Frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
Frosty with any purchase in our app so
they're encouraging people to use our
app and then they're following that up
by saying hey and then join us on Twitch
from two to five eastern as we unlock
all that Frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's going to
happen on a specific point in time this
is last January they're encouraging
people to use their up and you're using
that Frosty as kind of a carrot if you
will okay it's a catch it's a giveaway
so they were able to you know basically
wrap a bunch of things into one so get
encourage people to take part and I'm
sure a lot of people went ahead and took
part of this but we could definitely see
that 206 retweeted this tweet 302
basically commented on it and over 3 000
liked the Tweet so the Tweet was good
and it basically engaged with users who
doesn't like a free giveaway especially
free Frosty so that's why this
particular tweet really does some
justice for the target audience Their
audience they're they're giving
something away to Their audience just by
allowing them to you know use their app
okay so this tweet combines a lot into
one and I like it apparently a lot more
people than I did 3 000 plus also like
this tweet and so moving on to how to
increase your followers on Twitter you
want to mention other people in your
Tweet rates to increase engagement so
what do we mean by that so let's look at
Twitter so go back if we look at simply
learn just take a look at some of their
tweets what they're doing if we scroll
down here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hashtags but you can
also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
either the pound sign but if we scroll
down here if you use the at symbol
you're actually mentioning somebody so
in this case we're mentioning Matt
Bailey so Matt Bailey says is Matt
Bailey's handle and so if you get a
shout out to somebody they're gonna pick
up on that and then they're going to
probably follow you okay who doesn't
appreciate getting recognized for
something especially something as small
as a tweet okay notice I can go ahead
and click follow if I want to follow my
bailey but it's not a bad idea to add
people into your Tweet and you simply do
that by just using the ad symbol and
using their Twitter handle it's a good
way to get recognized by that Twitter
follower it also increases engagement
because it's adding validity to the
tweet and it definitely catches the
attention of the person mentioned
remember if you use that person's handle
they're going to see that that you
mention them okay and what it's likely
going to do is start some type of
Twitter relationship okay they're gonna
then follow you you're gonna follow them
and chances of them retweeting you in
the future or mentioning you in the
future is probably going to increase and
overall that increases engagement so
another important thing you want to do
is finding use hashtags that are
relevant to your brand and audience so
this is a must this is mandatory on
Twitter you need to use hashtags
Twitter's all about hashtags every tweet
that goes out should have a hashtag okay
so what you can do is figure out what
hashtags are trending so here what
Twitter does is it trends for you so
these are all specific hashtags that are
trending it's Mother's Day Happy Mother
hey Sunday morning whatever works for
you these are trends that happen to be
moving meaning a lot of people are using
them clicking on them okay so you can
use a popular hashtag what I would also
recommend is you use a unique hashtag
the rule of thumb is usually about two
hashtags in a tweet but that's a rule of
thumb but rules are made to be broken do
what's best for you if you want to
include more than two hashtags go for it
the only thing I'm recommending is
include a hashtag so find out what's
trending you could just look right in
Twitter or you could just create your
own unique hashtag it works both ways
but when you have a hashtag in your
Tweet and somebody clicks on it then
they're going to go to that particular
handle that hashtag and so when they
look at the hashtag you're gonna see all
the tweets with that hashtag in it so
that's the idea behind hashtags you want
to have hashtags okay so if somebody
clicks on a hashtag that you used then
they're like going to see your Tweet in
that hashtags feed okay so that's how
hashtags work you want to use hashtags
okay but you want to use hashtags that
are relevant to your brand and audience
that's really the key so hashtags help
your tweets to be found through Twitter
search thus improving your reach and
increase the visibility of your post so
that's another benefit Twitter has
search functionality so somebody can
simply go in and start searching on
Twitter so if I go back to Twitter I can
just do a hashtag and start typing in
something like Spanish and I'm gonna get
some of the most popular Spanish
hashtags or Hashtags with the word
Spanish in it and so this is an idea for
me that if I wanted to use a hashtag
with Spanish in it these are some ideas
but they're certainly searchable on
Twitter okay so if I just click on
Spanish okay I'm going to be able to see
all the Hashtags with the word Spanish
in the hashtag so definitely use
hashtags it's the most better official
feature of Twitter Bar None So some
reasons why using hashtags also a good
idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your Tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
Their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the Tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good Twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if I wanted to be just like
simply learn well I could simply just go
to their Twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so I can simply just
click on the 10 900 followers that they
have and what I can do is I can go
through and start following the people
that are following them so just mimic
your competition to some degree or mimic
others in the industry you know look at
what they're tweeting again start out by
retweeting some of the stuff they're
retweeting if it's good stuff if it's
like a tweet don't be afraid to retweet
even your competitors tweets okay use
unique hashtags use the hashtags they're
using look at who's following their
brand so you can really learn a lot from
others in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have the frequency of their tweets what
their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when I say mimic I mean
what I'm saying is pull best practices
from that Twitter account this will give
you an idea what you need to do to get
more followers so it's always a good
form of flattery when you can mimic what
somebody else is doing just like every
other social media platform following
Twitter influencers who belong in your
industry is always a good idea so if
you're in the food industry and there's
these star chefs out there probably not
a bad idea to follow those star chefs
you know if you're in the technology
industry well probably not a bad idea to
you know follow Bill Gates or Elon Musk
or Richard Branson or somebody else and
that's a big influencer who has an
influence on a lot of people okay but
make sure they're in your industry
that's the key if you can make sure
they're in your industry and you follow
them chances are if they look at your
Twitter account and see you're posting
or maybe retweeting some of their tweets
they're likely to follow you and if
they're following you your tweets are
going to show up on their handle on
their feed and so don't be afraid to go
out and connect and follow those
influencers it's a good way to boost up
your followers so again this will help
you gain followers since you can
replicate what they've done with their
profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influence answers so
you're all of one like mine so to speak
okay influencers might retweet or share
your post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their posts so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock Photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from Simply learn so
if I click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are in
engaging in a conference and it might
have been one that Matt Bailey was at so
it was a retweet from Matt Bailey as a
matter of fact but you could see what
simply learns doing is they're including
either a video or they're including an
image in every tweet and so that's
likely to boost up engagement so
according to buffer which is a another
social media platform adding a relevant
high quality image in your tweets can
help you gain more than 150 percent
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an Arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so as a Snowball
Effect just by using images Okay so
let's take a look at another brand from
2018 okay Pizza always my good example
to use on these webinars I like pizza
here this just says it all you know
they're talking about art and they're
using Pizza in the form of art so they
didn't really have to say much else here
this pretty much says it all and they
did get some retweets they get some just
some likes so sometimes you don't have
to say a lot to make your point
sometimes just the image itself will do
the job this was actually not from 2018
this goes all the way back to 2016. so
still holds true if you use an image
that image is going to get engagement
okay so on Twitter just like most other
social media platforms you can promote
your Tweet so you can use Twitter ads to
do that so you can promote your Tweet
and what you do by promoting it is
putting it up above so that most people
will be able to see it okay so see if we
can find an example if I go here I could
see this person is promoting their
handle but if I go down here I can see a
promoted tweet by Constant Contact so
they're promoting their tweet here so
it's not a bad idea if you have some
Media budget to go ahead and either
promote your Tweet or advertise on
Twitter so what that's going to do is
put you in a more prominent position and
get your tweets out there and the whole
idea for that is to get people to engage
here you can see a call to action from
Constant Contact so if I click on that
I'm going to go to probably a landing
page on their website and so the whole
idea when you advertise on Twitter is
really just like any other social media
platform you want to put yourself in
front of the Right audience and so
Twitter's no exception so with Twitter
you could put yourself in front of the
Right audience so what you could do is
you could promote a tweet you know do
promoted Trends or you could do promoted
accounts so you have a number of
different advertising options on Twitter
what we just looked at was you know
looking at promoted accounts and a promo
a tweet so when you do advertise there
are advantages you have to pay only
after achieving your marketing objective
so that's a benefit of Twitter the cost
per click it's a cost per click model so
it tends to be fairly low you could tell
your audience so again you're picking
and choosing who you want your promoted
tweet or Trend or account to be in front
of and it's targeting is based on either
engagement or it's based on keywords I.E
hashtags so really you could tailor who
you want your Tweet or your handle to be
in front of and so that's the really the
benefit of Twitter if you have a lot of
active users on Twitter you can really
put yourself in front of those active
users if they're your relevant audience
at a low cost per click so it's
definitely worth the test so you want to
offer Twitter support to your users okay
so I can't stress this enough okay so
what you want to do is when users have
questions about your product they're
more likely to tweet you for or support
hence they're likely to follow your
account so don't be afraid to use the
messaging option as well so we go back
to Twitter okay chances are somebody
might have a question for you here you
can look at big ads it's great
connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter followers chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these Bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying a Twitter
followers you want to build your Twitter
following naturally Twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of Bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shuts down shut down by
Twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices in organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve Bots
and adding thousands of followers to
Twitter account because chances are it's
just going to lead to no engagement so
create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do retweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's Twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
Twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to Tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
Twitter polls your old recent blog post
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories I mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things I do is I'm definitely one
for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it I
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if I blog I'm gonna make sure
that blog gets over to Twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
Twitter account you definitely want to
get that content out there but you want
to make it useful and relevant quality
over quantity because you want people to
engage so bring variety to the type of
content you share so I'm in digital
marketing I deal with pay-per-click SEO
but am I gonna just do pay-per-click and
SEO no I know that analytics I know that
you know Google tag manager I know that
be testing all of those are elements of
digital marketing so I'm going to Branch
out and talk about some of those things
that support digital marketing so that's
an example of bringing variety to the
type of content you share so don't just
stick to one thing you know feel free to
reach out a little bit shake things up
by sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complemented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
Branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
Forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so here
you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that Insight with you
and so this was interesting when I saw
this so what I did was I simply you see
the hashtag here for digital basically
if you want to look at this particular
study I just went to Twitter and I typed
in that hashtag and now I'm going to be
able to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 it Trends shaping 2019. so
I'm just following the Twitter handle
that they used so Forester does a lot of
good research a lot of good insights and
so what they've done here that makes
this tweet look so good is they've
actually put an image of the results in
the Tweet so they used an image to help
gain engagement or increase engagement
notice they also gave a shout out to
somebody as well as use some good
hashtagging so good tweet this was back
in 2016 but again a good use of the
image with the Tweet so you want to
organize tweet chats to interact with
your users and bring in new followers so
you know you basically want to be
organized when you're dealing with what
at so tweet chats enable you send out
tweets on a particular topic using a
designated hashtag so during a certain
time to interact with your your
followers and other users so you could
do it at a specific time to really get
out a specific topic but you want to be
able to stay organized so that you know
you what you're chatting about is
reaching the wide audience and you're
getting the right following and right
engagement okay you can also pin your
best updates and tweets to your profile
so you can just use that pin and what
that's going to do is pin it to the top
and keep it there so that you know
people who go to your Twitter handle are
going to be able to see that best tweet
that you've done so what you want to do
here is use the one that's most engaging
so pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of Engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see some thing
that other people engaged with and
that's going to encourage them to share
and probably follow you so and and
that's always what you want to do you
always want to put your best foot
forward so pin your best tweet to your
profile so I mentioned this earlier use
tools to schedule when to publish your
tweets so here's some of the most
popular platforms you know I.E Sprout
social so if we take a look at Sprout
social here I'm Inspire social I'm
connected to my Twitter account I can
simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's going
to let me know how many characters I
have remaining so 280 to start out with
when I'm done tweeting notice I can add
an emoji I can upload media I can tag a
specific location okay I can even you
know call out a specific Twitter profile
now I can schedule this myself or I can
use the schedule below I can pick and
choose a time to schedule the Tweet now
again you want to be able to use the
Sprout about social whatever social
media tool you're using to figure out
when the best time of day and the day of
the week to actually tweet when are you
getting the best engagement so ideally
that's what you want to do you want to
tweet when you're likely to get the best
engagement when those eyeballs are
actually going to look at that tweet
okay but you also want to separate out
your tweets so they're not on one on top
of another because if you actually Tweet
back to back then those tweets are just
going to get buried so if you spread
them out a little bit then you're likely
to maximize your number of Impressions
or eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple Tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just Sprout
social HootSuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule posts to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active Okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to fine tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with Wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember Randy's
gave away that free Frosty you know be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have you know
Twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see I just retweeted the simply learned
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active Twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
going to show up on your website and
it's going to show that hey you're fresh
you're engaging you keep up to date it's
just gonna make it look good and make
your website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your Twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming to your
website that may not even know you have
a Twitter account so you can also do
this in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but I would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
Twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from PlayStation
so PlayStation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on Apple TV today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with PlayStation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
Apple TV so you never know what's gonna
happen with a tweet when you tweet good
things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you as
a follower something good is going to
come out of tweeting Twitter is an easy
platform to use and if you take into
account all these best practices you are
going to increase your Twitter followers
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
Storytelling when it comes to Consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson one why storytelling is
essential in Social marketing when we
think about the way that our company or
our brand or our organization is
represented to the world it's easy for
us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
person personality and sort of the
lifestyle that's represented by your
individual company now the storytelling
movement has been an area that we've
really seen a lot of growth and a lot of
improvement in the last several years in
social media with more and more Brands
moving towards this idea of sort of
humanizing their companies by telling
the stories that come out of the company
itself out of the use of the product or
even out of the consumer stories that
you know share how products benefit
their lives or again just what goes on
in that interaction and that dynamic
between the organization and between the
customer side of things now when it
comes to storytelling there's several
different ways in which this approach
offers value to a business and one of
the key ones is on the emotional side
we've talked a lot in the social sharing
dynamic in some of the other areas of
you know the the spread and the viral
concept about how emotion is one of the
most powerful things that impacts
people's decision making and engagement
with the brand so when it comes to
creating that emotional connection or
leaving people with some type of
emotional response storytelling is one
of the most powerful ways to impact that
it gives you an opportunity to sway the
emotion of consumers in terms of how
they look at or view or are receptive to
your brand now another thing that
storytelling can really do that adds a
lot of value is the idea of making you
credible because a lot of times the way
we tell stories especially when we're
incorporating in true to life examples
or you know consumer stories there's an
implied credibility that comes through
that storytelling and comes through
those third-party experiences that can
help people feel more secure about doing
business with you not just more
emotionally positive but actually feel
that security of trusting that what they
think they're going to get or what
they're hoping to get that there's going
to be enough follow-through and enough
other people have had a positive
experience for them to really trust that
that's what's going to happen now
another area that storytelling there's a
lot of value into a company is the in
the idea of making you memorable because
human beings are wired for stories we
are much more capable of recalling broad
ideas and Concepts and emotions when
they're communicated via a story so if
we give someone a list of facts a list
of selling points you know a list of
reasons why to do business with you the
ones that touch them emotionally or that
you know problem solve those tend to
stick with them but a lot of the data
gets lost but when we put it in the
format of a story and someone is sharing
what their experience was our brains
literally archive it and categorize it
differently and our recall level goes up
so again along with building trust and
along with creating that that emotional
impact the fact that people are better
able to recall the information that's
communicated to them via that story
helps make it a very powerful marketing
tool now in addition to that it's
important to keep in mind that on
average people tend to be daydreamers in
fact study after study shows that if our
minds aren't occupied with an important
task if we're not truly focused on
something we tend to drift off and when
we look at that concept of daydreaming
the average human spends literally half
of their waking hours daydreaming we
average 2 000 waking drifts per day with
an average length of about 14 seconds so
you do the math on that two thousand
times times 14 seconds that's a pretty
good portion of our day where our brain
is drifting off but when they look at
the brain's ability to stay focused
versus having those drifts we stay
focused during a story if we're reading
a book if we're watching a movie if
someone is telling us an engaging Story
We Are Better equipped and better able
to put those drifts off and really stay
focused on what's Happening so that's
one of the other sort of scientific and
concrete reasons why that memorable
Factor comes into play when we present
things via stories now stories also
allow us to connect in one of the
easiest ways possible again because our
brain is going to be a little more
focused on being able to receive that
message so by using stories to spread
your brand message or to explain your
offerings or to demonstrate how they
work you increase the chance of keeping
your audience focused on you and giving
them enough recall that they can come
back at a later point to actually do
some business with you now think of
Storytelling from sort of the mindset of
how we meet and engage with other people
so in general when we're meeting up with
a prospective friend or a job prospect
maybe we're coming for an interview a
service workers even just a stranger on
the street any conversation that goes
past just hello how are you doing and
the cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and common
ground and information about who another
person is and in those those
interpersonal relationships the types of
questions we ask you know the words we
use they're indicative of the type of
relationship we want to build so clearly
if you know if you're single and you see
someone else that you know you hope
might be saying well that might be one
of the early questions you ask and then
based on whether you know there's a
romantic interest there you're probably
going to ask different questions than if
it's a interview Prospect for a job or
if you're meeting up with a you know
co-worker for the first time the
relationship that we're looking for
denotes the type of information we want
and that's one of the important things
for us to keep in mind when it comes to
storytelling is we also have the ability
to tailor our story to the audience so
we can put those different features up
front we can weave them in in a
different way if we're appealing to a
group of 60-something females that love
to sew versus a group of 20-something
Millennials that love whiskey tasting
it's a different message that gets put
together with different focuses and
features there's also different and
things that we're going to put forward
if we're proposing you know million
dollar contract versus a 25 impulse buy
that someone can you know click and
order online and have delivered the next
day now on the business side of this we
need to think about what the story that
we need is because a lot of times we get
so focused in business on getting the
conversion that we forget that sometimes
part of getting that conversion is
creating those emotions building that
credibility and trust you know helping
them have exposure to what's possible
and for a long time this has been done
through education we might put up videos
or articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind so a quote that I really love about
this concept that sort of lays the
foundation of why it's so important
comes from the chief content officer
over at digitas and he says the
challenge is clear by now intrusive
interruptive self-centered marketing no
longer works the way it once did and its
Effectiveness will only continue to
diminish in the social age because again
the way that we share information back
and forth with each other and the ways
that that messages spread it happens
differently in the social media age than
it did before when it was more
advertising focused and where marketing
really was more about you know pushing
the advertised pushing the message and
sort of the Don Draper style of you know
if you don't like the conversation
change the conversation and tell people
what you want them to hear because so
much marketing is now driven by
consumers through that conversation we
need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone and spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that I want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach and I love this
Seth Godin quote that really pairs up
with that idea the best part of Show and
Tell has never been the telling part
it's been the showing letting someone
see and experience and inviting them
into that shared experience and that's
one of those things that makes the
social version of Storytelling really
more like story sharing especially if
you want to do it in a way that creates
that back and forth consumer engagement
story telling in its traditional sense
is more the stories that we've put into
commercials and advertising and there's
a place for that there's a place to put
that together in the social realm and
it's very important but the other area
that that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by Brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself to
start building your story but we can
focus in on a couple key areas as a
starting point to build from
one of the first ones is the idea of
whether or not you have a Founder's
story now for a lot of Brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was Steve Jobs and the role
he played at Apple or Walt Disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire Disney complex or
loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are now a great
example of this is Spanx the founder
Sarah Blakely has really embraced the
story but both of how she came up with
the idea which was basically she was
trying to fit into a pair of cream pants
for a party and they didn't fit quite
right and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on everything seemed to lay
nicer so she literally cut the feet out
of a pair of pantyhose and put them on
and that's what launched the brand you
know she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to Neiman Marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room and she went in and she
put on a pair of white pants and came
out and said you know here's what I look
like without them and went back in and
put her pair of Spanx on under the white
pants and came back out and said now
here's what happens when I'm wearing
these and the buyer from Neiman Marcus
ended up placing a huge order and it was
the first major sale that she got that
put her in place somewhere so those
stories and sort of the yeah this is how
it happened you know this is literally
what a difference makes that becomes
part of the brand and sort of Sarah
blakely's Journey as an entrepreneur and
you know moving her way up into the you
know the Forbes list of uh you know
highest earning females in the United
States all of that plays a huge role in
how they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain Wendy's in
the US and Canada where Dave Thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that A working class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was CEO to see him
show up at a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays Into The Narrative of Wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the Cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there Post Cereal paired up with Burns
group and use real factory workers to
create a round of Honey Bunches of Oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
I get out of
work smell cookies I said oh no you
didn't smell me I just got out of work
that's honey bunches oh that's all I
said don't eat me now
[Music]
another short simple easy stories
there's nothing complex to them they
more just make you smile and laugh but
they're the types of stories that come
from listening to the people who work at
your company from thinking about how
your company and their experience
impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem now this isn't about the reasons
you think you're great or the reasons
you think people should buy from you
it's about that unique way that you
solve an issue that consumers or on the
B2B side of things you know the the
buying agent is looking at that they're
trying to fix
though letting you know owners or
drivers earn extra money
you know from something that might have
been sitting there empty anyways you
know that idea that when you're
traveling you don't have to stay in a
bland expensive hotel in fact when I
travel for business pretty much any
place I go I always book via Airbnb
because you know if I can have a bedroom
and a living room and a kitchen
especially for traveling as a family and
there can be you know separate bedrooms
as opposed to having my kids all stay in
the same room with my husband and I it
just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes and even on the side
of trying to recruit people to put their
properties it becomes about the freedom
and the lifestyle that's enabled and
there's tons of examples on YouTube of
people sharing how you know leasing out
that you know their vacation property
the rest of the year when they're not
there you know pays for the vacation
property and more or you know the people
who now travel full-time because they're
able to lease out you know their
apartment or their home or something
else on Airbnb the story side comes from
the problems that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is Dollar Shave Club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors cost a ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull Blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and you
know it shows up right at your house and
you don't ever have to think about it
anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern Millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example as a founder of my own club I'd
love to know how does yours work Dollar
Shave Club presents what the fact it's
simple you choose from one of our three
great razors we'll give you a free
reusable handle and each month we'll
send you replacement cartridges for just
a few bucks that means you get to shave
with the fresh blood anytime you want
which feels amazing
well I'd be locked into a contract no we
wouldn't lock you into anything that's a
relief how long for delivering I've got
a conjugal visit next week
well what if I don't have to shave that
often no problem after you sign up you
can choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
I like that
ew
what's this I hear about Dollar Shave
Club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like Dr cover
shea butter Boogie's hair gel and big
cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen now you know what the fact is
up with Dollar Shave Club so join the
club today
[Music]
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing which is one of
the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing
is a methodology that has Brands
creating and sharing content on social
media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've probably been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video and
advertising that new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
these are just some of the many ways
that you've been marketed to
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals
now this could be increased engagement
more clicks conversions and so on
so how do they do it
with text and image updates videos or
any other form of content that can
attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them now alongside
publishing quality content it also
involves analyzing your data and running
social media advertisements now some of
the more popular social media platforms
right now are Facebook Instagram Twitter
LinkedIn and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
first off social media marketing
provides great brand awareness now with
the help of interactions with people on
social media grants are able to build up
their repetition as a business and with
each interaction each post each share
the brand is exposed to a larger network
of potential customers who might be
interested in the products or services
offered
next it gives you more traffic to your
website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website
outside your usual custom Pace
next it improves your Brand's search
engine rankings
now although this isn't a direct
correlation social media marketing does
have a part to play when it comes to
helping your pH rank higher up in search
engine rankings now if you start posting
high quality content people will start
liking and sharing it this will in turn
bring it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who will be willing
to write about your business
and then this gives you backlinks which
as you know will help you improve your
search engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates
now with your brand being much more
visible and interactive on social media
every text image video or comment could
potentially Drive users to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting your brand and being more
interested in your products and services
then we have improved customer
satisfaction
when your customers interact with your
brand on social media it provides you
with an opportunity to show compaction
for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
now compared to other forms of digital
marketing social media marketing offers
some of the most flexible and relatively
low cost options available
now this opens your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures now
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders
now with your high quality posts
communicating with your audience sharing
content and promoting your Authority you
can have your followers look up to you
now this will allow you to become a
figure of expertise in your industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind
the goal of your marketing strategy will
be the driving force behind every
decision that you make
now this is exactly why setting up codes
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
now here are some things that you need
to keep in mind while setting up your
goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have thousand conversions by the end of
the quarter or 5000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your actions
number three make sure your goals are
smart
now smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
now alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric
now what is the North Star metric this
represents the main goal or a fixed
reference point that will ensure that
your team is on the right course
this North Star metric will also give
your team Clarity and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two
understanding your audience
social media enables you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
audience
Now by understanding what they need want
and desire you can deliver content in a
way makes your product or service the
answer that they're looking for
now there are also other ways you can
understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of your
Audience by conversing with them in
forums responding to their comments on
blogs and social media taking up their
feedbacks or suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here we take in our personal example
here they simply learn now simplulon's
audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
an academy has high school graduates and
the buy juice app has high school
students as users
now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform
now while performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
now while selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform who you'll reach
with this platform what content would
work best on the platform and is there
any content that was unique to that
platform for example YouTube and then
there's videos on it
now answering these questions will help
you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some major ones this
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest
let's talk about the purpose of each of
these platforms
now LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences
now for Facebook just about everyone has
an account on it
content that's related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook
then we have Instagram
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form videos it doesn't
drive a lot of traffic to your website
then finally we have Pinterest Pinterest
is also limited to static images
however it's highly effective at driving
traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four
setting up a social media calendar
a social media calendar determines the
message you want to convey to your
audience
it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
now let's have a look at some of the
most popular types of posts on social
media first off we have competitions now
I'm sure all of you have seen posts like
tag a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that competitions like these provide
great opportunities for engagement with
the audience now they can be used to
encourage your followers to share your
content it could be also for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag
competitions help grow your presence on
social media then we have polls or
service
polls can help you with data collection
that also encourages followers to take
action and interact polls and surveys
also provide opportunities through which
you can learn from customers to
understand what they like about the
product or service or what they don't
and to receive their feedback
then we have videos and live streams now
although we'll be covering this in a
little more detail further on visual
storytelling along with videos and live
streams goes a long way to drive
engagement among your audience
now these help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and so
much more to offer
live stream with its live nature and
having a human face alongside your
business humanizes your brand and by
extension helps increase customer
loyalty and Trust
then there's infographics articles and
images
social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization
with it you can create high quality
content attract new potential customers
and drive engagement
it also helps you with the planning
process you can plan create and schedule
posts on your social calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite bus
Sumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content to creating buyer personas
providing you insights on what works and
what doesn't and giving you templates
for different kinds of posts
now for number six visual storytelling
now visual storytelling involves passing
out a lot of information and the
simplest of forms visually
using pictures and videos your followers
are able to grasp the message quickly
and remember it for a long time
afterwards
visual storytelling is also not limited
by language barriers this helps it
become interesting and entertaining to
anyone watching it this can help your
audience stay interested and engaged
grab the attention of potential clients
and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience
visual storytelling connects with your
audience methods like live streaming
help humanize your brand and help grow
customer loyalty and Trust
it helps the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
have a look at some of our videos
so here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in 5
minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our Channel and now you know
why visual storytelling if you guys are
interested in watching these videos you
can check them out on our Channel
homepage we also have similar videos
about blockchain devops and Six Sigma
now back to our list
let's go to number seven
paying for advertising
this is a method that helps you find
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goals
this can help you improve your reach and
improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay-per-click modern ensures cost
Effectiveness while providing great
results and return on investments it
also helps improve targeting by letting
you control who sees your ad you get to
choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types and so on alongside
the basic use of demographics like age
occasion gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
Define the performance of your ad
campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
paid advertising
first of all your audience could get
exposed to your posts too many times and
tune out your content disregarding it in
the process
second it could get really expensive for
smaller businesses or startups to manage
a campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant and unimportant
you'll also have to deal with a whole
lot of competition smaller companies
with lesser budgets have an uphill
battle to deal with better funded
organizations
next we have number eight news jacket
new stacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of the
current events and drives it to your
brand it also helps shine a spotlight on
your products it also helps you show off
that you're up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant
by extension it also improves engagement
and website traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content a b testing helps determine
which of the variants your audience
engaged with the most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
next up number 10 community and
influencers
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry now
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience it
helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influences we have Marcus Brownlee unbox
therapy Mr who's the boss and Linus Tech
tips each of them with more than 4
million subscribers
and finally pair at number 11 measuring
and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process
it ensures that you're making the most
out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand
now these metrics can be tracked weekly
monthly or in a quarterly basis and
based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
on Facebook you could look out for reach
and engagement on Twitter you could look
out for Impressions clicks and
Impressions and interactions on LinkedIn
likes comments and mentions on Instagram
and engagement and Impressions on
Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a Brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your Target customer buy
a personas help you describe your
Brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you you also need
to set up a Content management system
like HubSpot Squarespace Wix and
WordPress they'll help you with
increased collaboration greater support
run a B test and much more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you and finally you
can publish and manage your content now
let's talk about content marketing tips
number one remarket your content content
marketing is one of the many ways you
can spread your content to a brighter
audience you can Define the audience you
want to Market to and then tag visitors
who come to your site and using Google's
Display Network you can strategically
position your ads in front of people on
Google or its partner websites who
previously interacted with your website
and advertise to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement I would be shown if I was
shopping for a MacBook Pro on Amazon and
change my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually I go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on Google's feature
snippet this position also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engines result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry you can have
different forms of Snippets like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions you could
have tables where data is taken from the
page and displayed in a table you could
have ordered lists where items are
presented in specific order and you can
also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand if you're
looking to grow a following for your
content try not to copy how already
established and successful corporate
blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what is popular and
influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your Brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
Neil Patel see how he himself is the
brand and if you've gone through his
content you know it's pretty great as
well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four ensure that
your content matches your Brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent you need to
ask your audience questions about how
you can develop and refine your Brand's
Voice by answering these questions you
can provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience your
tone of your brand can vary on the basis
of what type of content you are planning
to post and what the goal you want to
achieve from the campaign next up we
have number five back up your Arguments
for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original Source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords now make sure you use specific
keywords in your content this takes care
of the SEO aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found indexed
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
Niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven evaluate the
success of your content with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you backup your content
with data now let's talk about how data
can help you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more with this
data you can make sure that your time
and money are being used in the best
possible way some of the most popular
tools in the market are buzzsumo
Evernote HubSpot Trello and WordPress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached Midway right now so
I've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for Content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a Content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your Niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly it can help you create
valuable content and fix pain points
faced by your audience build a strong
relationship with them and earn their
trust it also leads to increased
engagement and a positive brand
experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from Trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email IDs to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them felt content
marketing was really important to their
digital marketing campaigns and more
than 25 percent of their budgets are
used for visual advertising content like
images infographics videos and other
forms of rich media will help you
enhance the message of your brand and
reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
Coca-Cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and Evergreen content
creating content that's Evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such Evergreen
article people are never going to stop
wanting to learn how to do SEO so with a
little tweaking every few months to
reflect new changes that Google may have
done you'll have an article that you can
get considerable mileage out of next up
tip number 12 is to understand content
that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms for
example you all know YouTube is the best
place for video content Instagram and
Pinterest for visual content Twitter for
smaller Snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like I mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find this out by asking
questions like who you're engaging with
online their age location language Etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now ABS testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more you
can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
Niche to share your content now since
these people already have a trusting
audience they would be a lot more likely
to enjoy your content content marketing
strategy so buckle up and let's get
right to it and we're gonna get right
into some of the best practices some
tips some methodologies some things you
should be doing with content marketing
so right out of the gate let's start
talking about knowing your audience okay
so content is all about writing for a
particular audience so it's just like
speaking except when we're speaking to
somebody we're speaking directly to them
content is very similar and so we have
to be able to know our audience ahead of
time so what you can do is collect
demographics of your target audience
based on who's coming to your website so
you can get that data in Google
analytics under audience email
subscribers I mean who is subscribing to
your emails who do you already have in
your email database and you can look at
social media I mean you look at Facebook
you can look at the people who are
already connected to you okay these are
just some three three of many examples
you could be doing to gather data on
your audience okay you have to know who
your audience is before you start
writing you know for a successful
content marketing strategy you really
just need to know your audience and
basically you're going to segment them
based on their interests so that content
is going to be catered to that audience
okay so if it signs that likes a
specific you know product uh that you
offer or feature that's part of that
product that you offer then that's the
segment you're going to be writing about
so you need to collect your data on your
audience ahead of time then you're going
to segment that audience okay so you're
not gonna write content for everyone
because the shoe doesn't necessarily fit
for everyone okay the the shoe has to
fit for specific foot and in this case
we're talking about an audience we need
to be able to segment our audience out
and you could certainly segment them out
by age by gender by education level by
income by interest I mean these are just
some of the examples again it could be
new returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
are purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past it could certainly be an
age range it could be even going further
on interest level or a combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
Google analytics just got to go in
analytics under audience under
demographics you're going to see age and
age is broken out by age range and
they're going to see gender so you're
gonna see a breakdown of gender and use
that to your advantage so if you're
going to you know write some content and
you know 99 of your traffic is female
the age of 18 to 24 then you know that
contents May catered accordingly so you
could certainly go to Facebook page
insights and get some really good
demographic data there because Facebook
is all about demographics okay so you
could see exactly you know how many fans
you have broken out by Man versus women
and then you can see again same thing as
Google analytics you could see an age
range breakout you could use Twitter
analytics I mean Twitter has share some
really good insights into education
level so you know if you're dealing with
you know highly sophisticated people who
have master's degrees or even higher or
let's just say even on LinkedIn you know
that majority of the people you're
trying to Target are sea level meaning
CEOs or CFOs or CMOS you know Chief
marketing officers or chief executive
officers then you're going to cater your
message a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even VPS so use
your audience information that you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage okay so let's jump into
number two we want to create high
quality content now I know this sounds
like a given but and I say but heavily
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always always create high
quality content it's going to result in
a lot of things are going to benefit you
you know one you're going to come across
as you know somebody who knows what
they're talking about and that's going
to help increase your brand awareness
okay when you increase your brand
awareness people know about you so it's
likely going to increase traffic to your
website diet or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are going to
share that content okay so from an SEO
perspective it can improve website
ranking meaning if you have good quality
content you know and it's really focused
in on a specific topic or a certain set
of core words keywords then you're going
to rank improves website dwell time
meaning hey you got good content people
are going to hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then certainly last but
not least you can gain a lot of leads
here meaning hey somebody likes what you
have to say whether it's a video or blog
post or or infographic you know people
are going to become more interested more
engaged spend more time and that's all
going to funnel through to somebody
taking that next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do The Upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to Google's Keyword Planner
understand how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in Google's Keyword Planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention Okay so give valuable content
to your creators and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say a data point from another source
then you know cite that Source you also
want to create engaging in
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are going to rage
your content because they not they don't
know the subject matter their interests
in the subject matter and they want to
be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a web page
you know put some structure to it maybe
you have to break it out if you feel
like you have too much content there's
no harm in breaking it into part one
versus part two get people uh tease them
a bit get them to come back and read
part two okay use different content
forms in case somebody's interested
maybe you want to capture some data you
know prefer short paragraphs to make the
content readable remember if you're
talking to c-level folks you you know
maybe you don't have to dummy down the
content so to speak but if you're
dealing with you know folks or people
that are right out of high school are
still in high school then adjust your
content and format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done I mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and hey
listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so creating content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you know
don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content I was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you know don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running a B test maybe tests so
important why because with a B split
testing you can increase your conversion
rates okay so four elements to test in
your content marketing strategy so if
you have content say a Blog and you're
testing that blog you test out the
images shifts test out the forms do you
have a long form or short form you know
test out the content length you can have
a variation that is a lot shorter than
the original does that increase or
decrease bounce rates play around with
call to actions your call to actions do
matter you know do you want to use a
softer call to action a softer tone or
do you want to use something very direct
and strong you know test call to actions
to see what's going to get people to
move closer through the closer to
purchasing and through that funnel so a
b testing to me is something that should
be naturally done with Google optimize
it's free so with images you know you
could test a lot of different variations
of images anything from people to you
know outlandish image rates or just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low you know don't write
something very long write something that
you think is going to stick with that
time of page but on your A B test create
something maybe a little longer if it's
engaging enough maybe somebody's gonna
stay a little bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation is going to
play with that length Okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you could push the envelope
one way or the other okay improving the
page with sign up forms really what you
want to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to Facebook or Google so if
they're creating an account they can
create an account via Google or Facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the Middle East or
the Far East Asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know Europe or the West
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is and improve our conversion
rates so what are your competitors doing
what are their baselines we can maybe up
that any I mean that data is also
available in Google analytics so you can
look at benchmarking reports in Google
analytics to get some form or fashion
you can also go to Facebook and look at
your competitors Facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of Engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include Facebook as well or maybe even
LinkedIn so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in The Meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
SEO platform form like search sem rush
or Moz or something like that that's
going to allow you to get some good
Insight on competitor information so
keep in mind there are SEO platforms
that will give you information on your
competitors and that's what these SEO
platforms are good for so number five
moving on choose a suitable content
format so now we've done all this
homework we know what we want to say we
know who we want to say it to we're
ready to do some testing but we need to
find a format because it's not always
about a web page per se meaning content
on a web page there's not always about a
blog post with content in that blog post
okay we need to decide the type of
content that's going to fit what we're
trying to say so again you can go the
traditional route with just post in a
blog post and nothing wrong with that
because with a blog post you can
incorporate video and imagery you can
also go more harder route when I say
harder more I say official route with an
e-book or case study something that a
user is going to be able to take away
with maybe download something more
official
um something more in-depth something
with a harder stamp on it so that that
shows individuals that you've taken the
time you've done this homework you've
done this research you've done some
really in-depth analysis and now the
proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like I am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video and video and YouTube
and some other you know video platforms
out there that allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of YouTube you know people you
use YouTube before they go on to
purchasing a product so think about that
so if you're trying to get somebody if
you're trying to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website visitors on social so that's the
key make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer and in-depth content so and
it shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded and and
you solving that customer's problem so
the case study is always there for you
know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
Reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a Content management system
that's going to work for you so so you
want to be able to choose something
where you can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
Management Systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are WordPress HubSpot
binder I mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know WordPress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share you know hotspot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven Target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to you you know fill
out a survey via email based on that
podcast or if you create a podcast about
some data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly you know you can
collect emails and send out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then May
make sure that particular audience gets
that same email now some of the email
content that you could share with your
target audience or newsletters okay
seasonal emails promotional emails
automated messaging and what we mean by
automated messaging hey if somebody just
purchased from you send them a thank you
email maybe follow up a couple days
later with another email with a survey
or what you could do is if you know who
your lawyer customers are you know
Target them with a promotional email so
there's lots of ways to slice and dice
content via email okay just make sure
you know your target audience is there's
lots of things you can do in email again
you can complement lots of different
formats within email as I mentioned
before with a podcast or a blog post so
keep all that in mind email is a good
way to communicate with your audience
okay the last point we want to make here
is use native ads okay so we talk about
Native ads it's one of the smartest ways
to connect your audience with your brand
so for example this is a native ad on
BuzzFeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably wouldn't exist without Led
Zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who Led Zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to Led Zeppelin okay so
you could see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet Zeppelin you know I'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who Led Zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay who is
this Led Zeppelin group and what are
these 15 bands the key here is not
necessarily the headline or Led Zeppelin
per se but it's a native ad and it's
sitting next to content talking about
music okay so according to Forbes online
audiences are 20 25 percent more likely
to look at a native ad than add a banner
and so that native ad in this case we're
talking about music needs to be sitting
or companyed alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get Peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
the emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so my
favorite part of it all you go into
analytics going to Facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and Pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that you're
aligning the right metric with the right
asset so for example if you have a case
study and ebook you want to make sure
that you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the case study received
again with the video you want to measure
video views now if your pack adding up
emails and sending them out to your
target audience you want to make sure
you look at open rates and click rates
okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metrics because there's hundreds
and hundreds of metrics to choose from
so just be aware all the different
metrics that are available you know if
you're in it for search okay how much
traffic getting from search where are
you ranking so there are a lot of things
you need to think about so think about
the content that you're producing and
think about how you want to be able to
measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here so what you
could do is create an editorial calendar
in fact I would highly suggest you
create an editorial calendar in order to
keep track of all the content you've
done over a period of time are you
making your content worth reading that
means are you checking the results of
that content what we just went over
measuring the content is it worth
reading have a column set up in that
editor our calendar you know performing
or not performing if it's not performing
don't do it again okay create your
content okay you always wanna you know
make sure you're reusing or using or
adding to the content that you've
created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
SlideShare now you can share it on all
social media platforms I'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a Blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
Facebook you know leverage the feed bag
you get from Facebook in the form of a
testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means SEO so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
Right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add H1 and H2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and H1 and H2S help you
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadata is title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
all tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that video infographic or
blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search okay so you want to create a
detailed summary and title and again
that goes along with the title tag and
meta description and then you want to
make it easy for the audience to ask
questions and comment on your blog so
don't be afraid like I'm gonna do right
now in this video is if I'm missing
anything from this checklist feel free
to comment hey I've written my fair
share content but I could be talking to
an audience that is just as qualified as
I am and they may have some tips so feel
free to comment underneath this video
now don't be afraid to ask just like I
just did people are always willing to
provide constructive feedback so don't
be afraid to ask for it and make it easy
so to me every blog post needs to have
some form of a comment box because blog
posts are out there to solicit
engagement now let's recap everything we
talked about because we certainly
covered a lot and there's a lot to cover
when it comes to content marketing so
one know your audience again you can
lean on Google analytics you know
demographic data whether it be age or
gender you could do the same with
Facebook and Twitter and Linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away create high quality
content when I mean high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running some a b tests you know run some
variations and switch out the image
switch out the call to action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the Facebooks of the
world to see what your competitors are
posting see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these SEO
platforms like sem rush and Moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're going to give you some
information about where particular
competitor ranks for keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them so all that's available in these
SEO platforms okay so you want to choose
a suitable content format we listed a
few from ebooks to case studies to
podcasts to infographics to blog posts
to videos it's up to you what you think
is best for your audience just keep in
mind you need to be able to measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out then you
might want to consider changing out the
content format choose a Content
management system
um you know plenty out there WordPress
is a good one if you're going to be a
blogger okay blogging allows you to you
know post optimize that blog post you
know you could have the ability to share
that blog post across social platforms
and you can also have that blog post
show up in search engine results so you
can't do any of that without a good
content management system so you want to
Target your audience using emails okay
so email is a good way to again further
communicate with that particular
segmented audience and again you could
use it to send out promotional emails to
Loyal followers or you can use
systematic emails to send an email a
thank you email somebody purchases and
then another follow-up email and again
you can repurpose some of the content
you've done in another format in the
form of an email so you know if you
created a video you know put that video
in the form of an email sent out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here okay use native ads okay don't be
afraid to put that content and hear it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance I can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging Google analytics
okay with Google analytics or Facebook
insights or Twitter or LinkedIn or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it align your kpi so
if it's an ebook or case study don't
measure just traffic measure how many
people actually die downloading them
okay if it's a video you know how many
people like the video how many people
are commenting how many people are
sharing the video how many people are
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from WordPress to YouTube to to
Reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so let's imagine
you're setting up your own website okay
you're clicking away You're developing
using some good tools you're developing
you're designing you're doing some QA
you're testing you're sharing with
Friends and an alpha version and then
finally your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's gonna happen well a few days
later you're checking on your website
and you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is you spend all
your time developing designing the
website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything or any planning or
any strategy around bringing users to
your website so the two go hand in hand
you just can't build a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before I tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website I mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as sales people
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you get visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
what that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways in which you can bring
traffic to your website well the first
is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads it's one of the easiest ways to
drive traffic to your website so some of
the options available are search ads
social media ads or display ads so
search ads or ads that are displayed in
the search engine results so when a user
types in a keyword a query you want your
ad to show up based on that keyword
query okay so an example is digital
marketing course somebody types in
digital marketing course and simply
learn is the first app that shows up how
do we know it's an ad because you could
see the word ad next to the domain so
when somebody clicks on that link simply
and learn is going to pay Google so
that's how search advertising works okay
the next is social it's a social media
marketing involves increasing traffic or
engagement or brand awareness lots of
different strategies but you're instead
of doing this on search you're doing it
on a social media platform okay so for
example you can advertise on any
particular platform and the way you
advertise could be with an image it
could be with a video so in this case
you could see Cabrio is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have Tech stats but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall into one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram and or Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment if you're a vlogger okay
so YouTube's a great way to promote your
site by getting your product out there
in the form of a video and then you have
Twitter Twitter to me encompasses a lot
of different Industries Beauty and
fitness news and media entertainment
okay you have limited number of
characters but a lot of people are
active on Twitter and it's a great way
to generate some awareness and get some
clicks over to your website so these are
just some of the most popular social
media platforms of course there are
plenty more out there the third way in
which you can drive traffic to your site
is guest plus blogging so most you
already know what blogging is all about
well if you're blogging for your own
site you can jump on somebody else's
site and blog on their behalf so having
the opportunity to guess post on another
website can be very helpful because one
that other blog could have lots of
traffic and have a a well-known brand so
if you're blogging on another blog it's
going to build your brand awareness and
potentially increase traffic to your
blog or website so it exposes to you to
targeted traffic so if you're going to
guest blog guest blog on a site that's
very relevant to your business or
industry that way you're targeting the
Right audience okay you can expand your
personal Network so getting yourself out
there getting your brand out there in
front of a different audience and then
obviously for surfs because it generates
backlink so serps search engine ranking
Pages means that hey if you want to rank
organically you're going to have to
generate some backlinks so guest
blogging isn't a way to generate some
back links to your site and in effect
that's going to help you get your pages
ranked higher because Google is going to
recognize the relationship from one blog
to your blog and build up your relevancy
so some other benefits here to guest
blogging is you can grow your social
media following because you can then
promote that on social media that you're
guest blogging okay again you can
improve your online Authority okay
because when you're guest blogging and
you have recognition on that Guest block
if it's a popular blog then it's going
to help your domain and Page Authority
for SEO and then the end result is going
to improve your backlink score so a lot
of benefits to guest blogging to me at
the end of the day it's just about
reaching out to your audience using
another platform to do that in the form
of a Blog and the results of that is
going to mean more brand awareness for
you and turning that traffic from that
other blog into qualified leads so you
can also interview industry thought
leaders so that's another way an
interesting way to generate traffic to
your site so reaching out to thought
leaders for interviews okay could
generate some credibility for you and
the other person so it's reciprocal so
it means that you're active in the
industry that you're in and it allows
you to engage with other leaders in the
industry and the indirect net result of
that could be increased traffic because
if you do the interview and you record
it or if it's via video then you can
obviously post it on other platforms and
that could in turn Drive traffic to your
website obviously just like guest
blogging it's going to increase your
reach so getting yourself out there
nobody knows who your brand is and they
know who the thought leaders are and
they see you're interviewing the thought
leaders then that's going to put you in
front of these people and so it's going
to increase your reach another way to
drive traffic to your website is just to
make sure your website's responsive and
what do we mean by responsive well we
mean does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
and larges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so as content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else a line just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
contents all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
the those fonts make sure they look good
and then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness a mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
how many brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build the community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that they're
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could it be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I IE post on
social okay it can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve as well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so the next thing you could
do to drive traffic is Be Active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se it could be other sites like Reddit
or core or Mania sites that have a lot
of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation and allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about you have some some
brand Equity you have some thought and
some knowledge on the specific topic and
subject so it just puts you in a better
light when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to search engine
optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability ability and
visibility on search engines and
obviously that comes with advantages one
of those advantages is obviously more
traffic to the site search is still King
in terms of volumes of people using
search on a daily basis so you have a
great opportunity to be found it also
builds trust and credibility because
still a majority of the people who do a
search click on an organic search list
in and so if you're found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement
and engagement is something you define
it could be again a download of a
document or the clicking on the play
button of a video or or submitting a
form or signing up for a newsletter or
calling these are all forms of
Engagement so the the amount of traffic
you drive from organic search to your
website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
an improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do a b
testing and when you do a b testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful in that
you know if you're running an A B test
the variation has a chance to improve or
outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's Nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in new women's red Nike
shoes size whatever at the year 2019
model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with SEO we want to be able to
build backlinks so SEO is a two-pronged
approach meaning you have two strategies
in one on page and off page and so off
page involves backlinking so back when
lengths are just links that direct users
from other websites to your own website
so with that inherently it's going to
drive traffic qualify traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so back linking because
it's an off-page strategy why isn't an
off-page SEO strategy because if Google
crawls that other site that has a link
to you then that's going to give you
credit because Google can say hey this
site's getting some links from some
relevant sites we must think they're
relevant and therefore we're going to
trust the site so by Google trusting
your site it's going to improve your
organic ranking and with the organic
rankings being approved meaning it's
going to mean faster indexing so what
does that mean so you want to be indexed
by the search engines and so the quicker
Google can find your pages even if it's
on somebody else's site then that means
they're gonna follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get index
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credits from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason you want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simple
play the rate at which people land on a
page and then leave so if I have a
hundred people land on my home page and
only one person went to another page and
the other 99 left the site then that's a
99 bounce rate so by putting internal
links in place you're helping people
move from one page to the other and thus
reducing the bounce rate and that's what
you want you want to keep people on your
site you want to be greedy it also
drives traffic to older posts so again
when we say older posts we're really
referring to blog posts so if you have a
relevant blog post and you're writing a
new blog posts then link the two
together if it's relevant link it I
don't you know regardless of how old it
is you know you want to show Google
about these older blog posts just
because they were written a year ago it
doesn't mean they're outdated and
old-fashioned okay or useless you want
to keep them alive by linking to them so
to me that's a good strategy for
internal linking link to older blog
posts you know show people you're an
industry expert you've been doing this
for a while and then you have lots of
content to share okay so the longer you
can keep somebody on your website the
more likely it is they're going to
engage and convert and some other
inherent benefits improves page rank so
what we mean by pagerank is simply just
a rank that Google gives pages so the
more internal linking you have the
better off you are and then it helps
spread link juice across websites and
what we mean by link juice again just
like backlinking it builds relevancy so
just keep all these inherent benefits in
mind to internal linking the end result
is keeping the flow of traffic on your
site and all these other benefits will
fall into place okay so another way in
which you can really hone in on traffic
to your website is long tail keywords
and long tail keywords to me are more
than just one or two keyword phrases
okay so there are usually three or
longer keywords in a phrase okay so long
tail keywords really nowadays account
for most web searches people really take
the time to even post questions as a
search query they likely somebody it's
unlikely somebody's going to go into
search and just type in the word shoes
they might type in red shoes but that's
unlikely what they're probably going to
type in is you know red Nike running
shoes 2019 or some variation of that
okay that's a long tail keyword and some
of the advantages of using long tail
keywords to be found for are less
competition so if you're using broad
keywords like red shoes then who doesn't
want to be found for Red Shoes well you
don't necessarily you don't want to be
found for red shoes because it's too
broad you don't know what type of shoes
somebody's looking for you just know
they're looking for Red Shoes it could
be running shoes it could be work shoes
it could be you know boots it could be
slippers okay it's too broad so long
tail keywords oh narrow it in and the
more narrow and focused a keyword is the
less competition is going to have and
when something's not competitive in the
form of a keyword then that means your
chances of ranking for that keyword are
going to be greater and the chance of
you ranking faster are going to be
greater and then of course if somebody's
looking for exactly what you have to
offer then you have a higher chance to
convert that person so if you have
exactly those 2019 red Nike women's
running shoes and somebody does a search
for that and that's a long tail keyword
and they click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing is specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your email
is targeted if it's targeted it could be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open okay so
email usually depending on the the email
provider you're using really is a flat
fee so just really depends on how many
emails you're sending or how how many
people you're sending the email to as
well so but email generally tends to be
more cost effective than other forms of
marketing so look at the email content
provider you using and just get a sense
of what they charge but if you look at
it and do a comparison email generally
is cheaper than say doing pay-per-click
because with pay-per-click you're paying
for each click okay so that could be
expensive depending on the keywords so
email marketing is also time saving okay
meaning it's a one-time thing and done
so once you send the email it's just a
matter of you know watching and looking
at the metrics and learning what's going
on so you don't make the same mistakes
again but it is time conducive meaning
you send out one email and that's it
with pay-per-click you're constantly
measuring and managing the campaigns and
it provides real-time marketing so when
you do send the email more than likely a
majority of the people on day one or the
day you send the email are gonna be able
to view it open it click on some of the
links and convert so that's normally
what happens in email majority of the
people open it on day one and it kind of
tails off from there so think about it
as real time so when you send that email
and if you have a thousand people on
your email recipient list break it up
send the first 500 first with a
different subject line and then you can
see the data come in and if you don't
see the good results from the subject
line or the body of the email or you
know the page they're going to then make
adjustments before you send the other
email to the next five hundred so that's
a great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email you are
generally going to get results right
away okay within the first 24 hours so
that's a great thing about email okay so
the other thing about email it's less
intrusive so normally people who are
going to get the email are the ones who
sign up for the email so they're almost
expecting your email so when they get
your email again as long as you're not
sending an email on a daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly it's not going to be as
intrusive okay and then it also helps
build credibility increase visibility
and brand awareness meaning you're going
to build your brand in that email you're
going to put content in that email
that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonial in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics okay if you use Google
analytics you're going to be able to
track when you send the email who clicks
on it and who converts so you want to be
able to measure an Roi for these emails
and you can that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for Effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
and another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouning
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target groups you're going to
be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently and interesting to maybe a
larger group of people you can promote
that on social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or Romeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embed it in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves Roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video two is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then chances are
they're going to share that particular
video which is going to bode well for
your brand and traffic okay so video if
somebody likes a video it's very easy to
share video especially from a mobile
phone so YouTube just makes it so easy
to share or like or subscribe to a
channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregator well a
Content aggregators like Reddit that
provides a great platform for you to
post your content so that's what a
Content aggregator is really a site like
Reddit or medium or quora where you
could post content to a large number of
people okay so with Reddit people are
either going to upvote it or downvote it
so the more upvotes you get are thumbs
up or likes or people who encourage that
content the more of a chance it has to
be found and so first thing out of the
gate if you do provide content to a
Content aggregator like Reddit make sure
it's good quality content that's
interesting and that should be a case
the case around across the board whether
it's a social post or blog post make
sure the content's unique professional
and interesting and then if you do say
put something on medium or you do put
something on Cora and it is professional
and interesting and thought provoking
then people are going to react to it and
then that again could lead to traffic
but even if it doesn't lead to traffic
it helps build brand awareness so if you
have content just like videos leverage
it put the content out there okay and
when you put content out there it's only
gonna especially if it's good content
put it's going to put you in a good
light so don't be afraid to share your
content on the likes of Reddit or medium
or core or some of these other content
aggregator websites because good things
are only going to happen and again
referral traffic SEO brand awareness
conversions so all these are inherent
benefits of just sharing your content
okay and then finally we want to learn
from analytics okay so what do I mean
learning from analytics so there are
plenty of analytics platforms out there
one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so all you have to
do is just go to Google analytics via
search sign up add the analytics code to
your website and voila they're doing all
the heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming to your website and not
only are they going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you can
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or are they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they come in from
organic search it is so Google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our SEO efforts
and then with Google analytics you can
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by Page by language
by city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to say so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that information and
analytics if that's your target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so Anna there are a lot
of benefits to Google analytics
definitely want to take advantage of
segmenting in Google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about Google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing once somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data is you want to be able to
fine-tune your website so take advantage
of the data that Google analytics or any
other analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
Linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the lead she's collecting
per day per month and convert them into
custom
okay so customers sign up but they don't
buy her product so she's left scratching
her head wondering what to do so how's
she going to solve the problem of
converting the lead she gets into paying
customers well look no further than
email marketing so you can boost your
sales funnel with the help of email
marketing so email marketing leads to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also in a it's
a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so Linda thinks
this is too good to be true your telling
me is a very efficient way to generate a
return on my investment how expensive is
email marketing well email marketing is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing and
so Linda is now very interested we've
piqued her interest she wants us to
explain email marketing to her in detail
and that's exactly what we're going to
do we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening what's in it for you why
are you going to invest your time in
listening to Simply learn and me talk
about email marketing because we're
going to talk about everything there is
about email marketing in today's webinar
so what is it for those that aren't
really familiar with the intricacies of
email marketing we're going to talk
about how to set up email marketing
we're going to discuss all the benefits
of email marketing we're going to get
into a b testing we're going to get into
the automation of emails the types of
emails how to engage New users and we're
going to give you a demo so there's a
lot going on in this webinar like I said
buckle up and let's get started and talk
about what what is email marketing so as
I mentioned to Linda it's an efficient
way to convert leads into sales why
because we can send personalized emails
to a specific audience a targeted
audience if somebody's interested in our
product we can reach out to them via
email it can also be used to remarket
pre-qualified leads so anybody who's
pre-qualified we can go ahead and
communicate with them as well so email
marketing is a very effective at
different stages in the funnel okay so
when I say funnel customer life cycle so
we have awareness consideration purchase
retention and advocacy okay so let's
talk about each one of these parts of
the final or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top so email marketing allows
customers to recognize their problems
after which you can educate them on how
your brand can solve them okay just like
any other marketing channel somebody's
looking for something a need of
something and we can come to the rescue
in this case we're going to come to the
rescue with email and we can go ahead
and educate them on on what their need
is and how we can collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with our product okay so that's
what email is going to do we're going to
communicate with them via email and
we're going to bring awareness to the
problem by solving the problem that's
what email is good for okay good for
generating awareness for our brand for
example we can share a newsletter with
our customers so we're running a
Cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for Relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer Smooths hydrates and
contains SPF 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
let's talk about purchase the next step
in the life cycle well purchase well
with purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off a moisturizer is pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in
their inventory so what do we do we're
going to send an email we're going to
see an email to active customers okay
we're gonna give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're gonna give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth ten dollars for free so
you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers he is
the offers exclusively just for those
who you want to Target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer men what
we want to do is advocacy last step in
that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
Advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those kind customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy a product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with Friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about the
benefits of email marketing so what are
some of the benefits well we've already
mentioned to Linda that it's cost
effective it's time saving real-time
marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track Roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're going to go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign the key is figuring
out who you want to send it to can we
talk about real-time marketing you know
we're sending this email out basically
in real time trying to meet our
customers needs at the right time it's
less intrusive because we can customize
the emails okay we can as you saw I can
put first name in there to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain credibility when we offer
exclusive offers to repeat customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with non-profits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because you know we could send our
email out to a large group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but Roi so how how many
people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email today we're
going to talk about affiliate marketing
so let's jump right into it and take a
look inside an office environment right
now we have Chuck here Chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing John walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right Chuck
responded hey I'm just worried that I
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done paid search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I'm going to come up with
something new ASAP well John responds
hey don't worry I think I've got your
solution for you man hang tight relax
take a load off here's my solution
affiliate marketing first off before you
ask the question what's affiliate
marketing let's talk about why we need
affiliate marketing so let's dig into
affiliate marketing so John's just
taking over now and he's gonna let Chuck
know everything there is to know about
affiliate marketing so the first
question John answers for Chuck what is
affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me I'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these margins are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchanges you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
John's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away John so
John says first we have the merchant AKA
The Brand the seller the Creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea This
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups it's a large
multinational companies International
companies non-profits for-profits
individuals independent contractors
Freelancers a group of people who have a
passion for something okay it could be
anybody there's no limit the affiliate
aka the publisher so the affiliate is
basically that third party website or
entity which promotes the merchants
products and tries to convince potential
customers of the merchants products
value so this affiliate going to
represent the merchant on their behalf
and try and get their clients to
basically purchase that particular
Merchant's product so the affiliate
could be incentivized based on you know
registrations email sign ups sales and
subscriptions so it doesn't always come
down to you know sales you know if I'm
just trying to get you know build my
email list then hey I can incentivize
that affiliate to push email signups if
I've got this big you know offline you
know promotion that I'm doing at this
particular mall and I want to get people
there well I can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so John what is the
process of affiliate marketing well John
says let's have a look at the process so
it's affiliate marketing time so we're
going to use a tool or platform like
Commission Junction Commission Junction
is a popular you know platform that
affiliate Network platform that brings
merchants and Affiliates together so the
merchants can use those Affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at Commission Junction as a good
digital marketing tool for affiliate
marketing so we're going to use
Commission Junction as an example here
remember at affiliate marketing it's an
ecosystem between Publishers and
Merchants so remember Merchants are
selling products Publishers are selling
those Merchant products on their site
and so Commission Junction is the
middleman so to speak okay so Commission
Junction just known as CJ now is the
middle person they're introducing the
publisher and the merchant and so let's
go ahead and log in here so when you log
in like any other digital marketing tool
any other platform you're going to have
your own settings and whatnot so really
the whole idea behind any affiliate
marketing tool is really there to manage
your Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publisher's link so we're going to click
on the Publishers link and remember when
you sign up Publishers you have to have
program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able able to see all the different
program terms available so here we could
see the different program terms we have
set up for certain Publishers so we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have Publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe you know These
Guys these Publishers get better program
terms versus say other Publishers who
don't and so here we can see the program
terms basically you can see what the
terms are the action and the different
policies here so everything you need to
do to manage that publisher in terms of
payment is done under the program terms
now if the program terms are met the
publisher actually sells your products
CJ is the broker they're the ones who
are going to initiate the payment based
on the program terms so be careful in
the program terms you want to be able to
set them appropriately CJ has templates
CJ has some default program terms that
you could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program terms
and so you can align Publishers with
different program terms and so that's
the whole idea behind program terms is
you want to be able to align Publishers
with that so when you sign line up a
publisher they're going to get a line
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search for
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click in
terms of Publishers now you can select
under Publishers groups now you can
group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea Beyond affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm going
to repeat it is you want to get
Publishers and you want to start
building your base of Publishers because
the more Publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's gonna buy your
product so if you have Publishers who
are promoting your product for you then
you have a good opportunity to sell it
so the more publishes you have on board
the better the opportunity so now once
you have Publishers you can start
grouping these Publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in CJ to group Publishers now when
you're in CJ and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publisher so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling CJ is going to try and
put you in front of some good Publishers
and so here we could see if we click on
recruit we're going to get a list of
Publishers and this search results list
of Publishers that we can recruit into
our Network are all listed here and you
can actually see what's interesting you
can see the name of the publisher and
you can see the URL and then you can
actually see if they're a good performer
or not so you could actually see their
history as a publisher just by looking
at their Network earnings and then also
looking at their seven day earnings per
class effect or three month earnings per
click and so if a publisher has a very
high earnings per click EPC then they're
probably a good publisher somebody
you're probably going to be interested
in so if I see a publisher with you know
three months earnings per click of 105
then that means say if that's my
publisher I'm paying 105 or 106 over
seven days you know they're generating
some clicks for me and they're
generating sales you can't deliver
commission if they don't sell and so to
me I want to be able to look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these Publishers and so I can just click
on any one of these Publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in CJ so here I can
see the particular URL the company some
other URLs that they have associated
with them in CJ I could see the category
that they're in again I can see the
seven three month EPC here you can see
description okay you can see some other
promotional methods that they'd use when
promoting products and you get some
program performance from this particular
publisher just by pulling down the pull
down menu here I'm going to look at this
year and see what the performance is and
why I'm waiting for that to load I could
see hey they're also in other countries
as well so I can get a good snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
Publishers seeing what their
performances over a period of time and
potentially you know recruiting that
publisher would be part of my network
because if they're part of my network
then hey if they're selling products if
I'm selling products and I want my
product on their site and they're doing
a good job of selling other products
then I want them to be you know part of
my ecosystem part of my network now
remember member CJ is doing the
introducing here they're introducing you
to recruits so you want to be able to
again take a look at the site does do
any of the sites that a particular
publisher has interest you you know
again we can just click on it go to the
specific site take a good look hey
Virgin Atlantic okay do we want them
selling our product maybe maybe not
um so you want to take a look at the
website make sure it's not spammy make
sure it aligns with your business goals
it makes your lines with your product
your target audience remember a lot of
things you want to make sure the website
aligns with because they're representing
your brand okay very important here very
important and so that's what you want to
be able to do and you could do all that
just by looking at the publisher detail
in CJ and then again take a look at that
earnings per click if they're selling
products and you can really filter here
so we want you know choose High Network
earners in a particular country a
particular State you know we could
definitely filter in on a particular
type of publisher okay so you want to be
able to hone in on somebody to line with
your geography or you know definitely
you want to align with somebody who's in
the high Network owner now when you get
all your Publishers set up you're going
to need to provide them with some good
promotional materials some good banners
some you know it could be text links
some messaging okay so you're the one
who's going to provide the Publishers
with you know the information they need
now as a best practice remember you can
get on the phone with these Publishers
have monthly calls or quarterly calls
see what they need you know reach out to
them via email or reach out to them via
the CJ platform figure out hey you know
how's your banner is working for you do
you need new banners so you want to be
able to constantly you know push new
content out and so if I click on links
here and manage I'll be able to see
everything that I have available for my
Publishers to use okay and then you can
actually look at banners that have
actually produced for you in terms of
EPC or you know if it's a specific
promotion okay you could set that up
here so you could be able to see it here
you can see all the banners you can see
some text links in here so all the you
know advertising that you want these
Publishers to have is going to be
situated under links and so you can see
what the active ones are you can look at
archived you can look at again text
links content links or banners and as a
best practice if I click on a banner as
a best practice ideally what you want to
do is use UTM tracking okay so you want
to have some type of track talking in
place however CJ does a lot of the
tracking for you so they're going to be
able to tell you how many times a
Banner's been clicked and how many times
a Banner's been seen okay they'll also
tell you more importantly Not only was
that Banner click but did it generate a
sale and so here I can see that I have
three Publishers using this particular
banner I could see over this period of
time 412 Impressions meaning 412 people
viewed the banner and I received one
click on it so you can get some in-depth
detail about your different marketing
materials and how they're performing
okay you can also see what Publishers
are using them okay so the key here is
you want to be able to communicate with
your Publishers give them the
promotional material and that they need
to promote your product now you could
set up specifically you could set up up
a unique Banner for a publisher or you
could set up a banner for a group of
Publishers that's where the group comes
in so you have some options here and
then as a best practice what I would try
and do as you can see here is come up
with different Banner sizes so you can
see here we got a 728 by 90. okay you
gotta have 160 by 600. you got a 300 by
250 okay so you want to have different
Banner sizes and you also want to mix in
some text
um ads as well okay you want to be able
to give your Publishers some options in
terms of what to use on their websites
so that's the whole idea because a
publisher may not have space on the home
page they may only have enough space for
you know a text ad or a 300 by 250. so
you want to be able to mix it up and
then also mix up the messaging as well
so you can have the same 300 250 Banner
but you can have different messaging
just like you see here 3 300 by 250 got
this messaging here and we got a
different set of messaging with the same
Banner size so the more options you
present for yourself the more of an
opportunity you have for the publisher
to use that messaging that Banner that
text that on their website and then that
gives you a better opportunity to get
the click get the conversion that you
seek out so that is links so you want to
be able to continue to push out
different banners and text ads now CJ
also has a great feature in here if
you're selling a lot of products you
have a large inventory of products you
could actually upload a product feed to
CJ so you can see in this example we
don't but if you did let's just say you
have a hundred products that you want to
sell you can go ahead and upload that
fee to CJ and then the publisher will be
able to use that entirety and it's of
the feed or pick and choose different
products to use and sell so let's jump
over to reports in CJ you have reports
so this is really the bulk of where you
want to be spending your time because
you want to be able to you know not only
recruit those Publishers but after you
recruit them you want to be able to see
the performance how are things moving or
are Publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
products so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see over a
period of time you know are we selling
our product and here you can see over
the last 30 days you can see how much
commission was paid out remember CJ gets
a fee they're the broker okay so that's
part of the program terms okay so it's
based on program terms who's selling
okay what program term are they
associated with CJ gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we
could see how many sales were generated
how many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many Impressions so I
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now I can go into detail
if I click on transaction here from the
pull down menu I can look at a specific
order I can choose a specific publisher
or website and I can get details about
that specific order publisher website
Etc just be look by choosing transaction
so I can get really granular about the
data I see for specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports try
transaction now we can also click on
promo codes and if you're running a
promo codes for your Publishers you'll
be able to see how many conversions
those promo codes delivered and the
total sale amount over the last 30 days
so building a network is all about
recruiting the right Publishers giving
them the materials they need measuring
the performance of the Publishers and
then communicating it's just so key so
CJ has a nice message Center built in so
you can actually you know look at the
messages you're getting from your
Publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so communicate
seamlessly and efficiently write in CJ
here so I just clicked on mail and we
can see the messages we have so you can
also click on email campaigns and if you
have any email campaigns that you want
to run you can look at them right here
in CJ so CJ offers up some email
campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted you know how many
people opened it and how many people
joined in this case joined our Network
so here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries Etc so if
you want to run an email campaign right
in CJ it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a Publisher's website and so
here we could see a breakdown of
different Publishers who basically will
offer up some promotional material that
we can leverage okay so here you got
this particular promotional placement
it's a one month placement and review
page with your ad so we can actually you
know take advantage of what Publishers
are offering up on their own website so
the whole idea here is if it's in a
prime position on their website then we
can take advantage of that so then what
we want to be able to do is if we like
what they're offering up you can see hey
this particular publisher is saying they
have a creative the placement is a home
page Banner or full page review provide
an email with a copy of the ad that
you'd like to be displayed and we're
going to email this person here so if we
want to take advantage of a specific
promotional placement on a Publisher's
website then we can do that just by
clicking on placements and we'll be able
to see who's offering up what notice
there's a fee involved so it just gives
you an opportunity to reward a publisher
that's performing well for you and if
they turn around and offer you a better
placement for a little bit more money it
might be worth it so the whole idea is
is to take advantage of placements
because if your product is in place
properly then nobody's going to see it
if nobody sees it then you know they're
not going to click on it and then you're
not going to get sales so that's the
whole idea here is take advantage of
what Publishers are offering up in terms
of promotional opportunities so CJ also
has a pay per call click uh model as
well pay model so basically your paper
performance is based on calls so
basically the whole point here is a CJ
points out you want to promote more High
ticket and consultative products and
services you want to expand your reach
and you want to get more qualified sales
then you can offer up a pay per call and
the beauty here is CJ tracks the calls
so you will be able to see the actual
phone number and calls so instead of
offering up say you know Banner with a
click you can offer you know promotional
number and have CJ track the calls from
the publisher and that just opens up
another opportunity for you to give your
Publishers an option to have people call
if they call then great you know it's
another way for somebody to get in touch
and purchase the product so the
pay-per-call method is available under
CJ as well so if we want to get more
insights about how our program is
performing we just click on the insights
CJ is going to take us to this overview
this dashboard if you will with some
really good data based on a time frame
okay so we're comparing July through of
July of 19 through July of 2018. we're
able to see revenue and and commissions
paid out and how many clicks average
order value so it's kind of an overview
dashboard if you will about how our
overall program is performing there are
other similar tools and resources to
include you know Max Bounty trade
doubler Amazon Associates there's plenty
of networks out there you want to find a
network where you're going to have
Affiliates that are going to be
passionate and going to be relevant and
have the perspective audience that you
need to sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there
with that we have reached the end of day
one of our digital marketing Journey on
day two that is tomorrow we are going to
learn about SEO thank you all for
watching this live session I hope it was
useful and informative goodbye and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign